I don't think we watched this before.
I think we only watched the briefings.
I don't think this is the same as...
No, it isn't, right?
That's where snakes don't belong.
How's the audio, by the way, guys?
Let me know.
It's always confusing for me because the El Gato says something different than what my mixer says.
It's good?
Look at that guy.
Wow.
Audio good?
Who's that?
It doesn't matter who he is.
Roy Campbell says you don't matter.
I'm in charge of this here mission.
Also, I just realized he has the Fox Town logo on his...
Why does he have the Fox Town logo on his...
on his jacket?
Naomi.
Naomi Hunter.
I wonder what Hunter is in German.
It's his old jacket.
Yeah, I know he was Fox Town.
You'd think, though, that, like, you wouldn't want to wear something that the terrorists wear, like, are associating themselves with.
You know what I mean?
You'd think that you'd want to be like, hmm, I'm not with them.
Hahaha.
Wow.
Oh my god, his speed.
Yeah.
Oh, get rid of it.
That's so wasteful.
Sorry, I know it probably feels like we just, like, jumped right into it.
This is just playing the intro, you know?
A little... a little...
refresher, right?
The sushi!
The beautiful and deadly sharpshooter.
Decoy octopus.
Master of disguise.
Thanks, sushi.
For the toy to get.
And revolver ocelot.
Shaman.
You pronounce it wrong.
Colonel?
Giant and Shaman.
Foxhound's blob leader.
Liquid snake.
Giant and Shaman.
Big pumpy welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Mint is in the bandana.
Sheesh.
Were those always there?
I don't think so, right?
Maybe you should have abandoned it, snake!
Maybe you should have gotten rid of it!
Oh, this is why we're messed up in the mission.
Because we're messed up in the head!
From all the clunks!
We have a concussion!
He covers the whole island.
I'll instruct you by codec after you reach your target.
Anyone going with me?
As always, this is a one-man sneaking mission.
Oh, yeah.
Weapons and equipment OSP.
Yes.
This is a top secret black op.
Don't expect any official support.
I brought my controller.
I'm so clumsy.
Wow!
Oh.
Welcome back, master, princess!
Welcome back to Metal Gear Solid!
The twins!
Snakes!
Yippee!
Welcome back!
I'm so glad you're back.
No worries!
I'm glad that I could do a little bit to help with whatever you were going through.
Bells a hurry.
And hopefully you enjoy these playthroughs.
Also, talk strength!
Thank you for the pink!
This got moved to Friday.
I told my manager I could not come into the office.
No!
What do you mean?
Don't!
No!
Oh my gosh, please.
Don't skip work because there's a VOD, you know?
Thank you so much for the ten gifted!
Thank you for the five!
Johnny, thank you for the five!
This is getting out of hand.
Now there's two.
Welcome to membership!
Thank you guys!
Last time we left off with Meryl getting a little pew-pewed.
She's kind of on the ground.
She's kind of bleeding out.
We kind of got to go get a PSG to save her.
But...
I...
I'm going to turn down the music just a little bit.
I plan on not saving her.
I'm sorry.
We are going to be doing the Otacon ending.
So, um...
I think when I play... when I replay the game though...
I'll do the Meryl ending.
But for this one specifically...
There's something that I want to see.
With the Otacon ending.
So we'll be doing that.
Of course!
Thank you for the five gifted!
Thank you guys.
The canon ending.
The best ending.
So sorry.
So sorry to Meryl.
To Meryl.
And I'm sorry again that I had to move this.
There was some stuff that came up.
Some things that I...
There was just...
It was a couple things.
Alvin, thank you for the five gifted.
Thank you.
But...
I didn't want to like...
Cancel it obviously.
And I was like...
What I was planning on doing on Friday got moved.
And so I was like...
I'll just shift a couple things around.
Baby.
Brick!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for the...
Thank you so much.
Meryl?
Meryl, you see?
You heard nothing.
Meryl, you...
Heard nothing.
Oh shoot.
Okay.
It has to be this one.
Welcome to the membership.
Thank you for the gifted.
Thank you for the five gifted.
Meryl, you're bleeding.
Stop hearing stuff.
She's into...
She's in shock.
You know?
Maybe sepsis.
I don't know.
Productivity.
Good luck with work.
Thank you for the five gifted.
Thank you.
Meryl can become a membu too.
Right before...
You know what?
It's perfect though.
If she joins membership because...
Actually, I am going to move the notifs.
Because we'll move them like kind of over here.
So it's a little...
A little less invasive on the game.
Yeah, yeah.
Alright.
Oh, jeez.
Okay.
Guys, give me a second to...
To...
Oh, what is this?
Oh, there's a mission log.
I was just pressing yes.
To stop the terrorist's nuclear attack...
Snake must deactivate the detonation code...
Or destroy Metal Gear itself.
Snake and Meryl...
Head for the communications tower.
Communications tower...
The only way to the underground maintenance space.
Foxhound member Sniperwolf...
Fires at them.
And Meryl is badly wounded.
It is a trap to lure out Snake.
Snake must get up here...
Whoa!
Wait, that's Meryl in the back.
What?
I've never seen that before.
Oh my god.
Wait, that's so awesome.
Sorry.
Oh my gosh.
What?
That's so awesome.
Oh my god.
Looks like Yoji, Shinkawa are too.
So...
That's so cool.
Oh my gosh.
Even when hurt, she's hot.
So true.
Meryl is dying.
Let's go.
This is the last time we'll see Meryl, actually.
Alive.
This is the last time we'll see Meryl alive.
Snake must get a PSG-1 to beat Wolf and save Meryl.
Oh my gosh.
It looks so good.
Okay, I have a question.
When I'm excited about some things like this, do I sound genuine?
Sometimes, like...
Sometimes when I'm talking, specifically to Matara, she'll tell me something and I'll be like, Oh my gosh!
That's cool!
She kind of makes fun of me.
She's like, you don't sound like you mean it at all.
And I'm like, I do!
And I'm like...
I'm excited!
You sound like a freak affectionate.
You know what?
You are a freak, Raymac.
You are a freak!
How about that?
Anyway.
I am excited.
I think... I get very excited, especially seeing new Yoji Shinkawa art.
I recently got the...
The...
The novel version of Peace Walker.
And it has so much art in it that I've never... Oh my gosh.
I was freaking... Oh my gosh.
There's this one beautiful picture of Strangelove like looking up at...
I don't know.
It's kind of hard to tell if it's Zeke or if it's like...
The Peace Walker.
I think it's the Peace Walker.
But you sound like a nerd so I believe it.
Stop liking that!
Stop liking... I can see...
Stop liking that super chat.
You're too much of a nerd not to be genuine about your excitement.
But yeah, there's this like gorgeous, gorgeous picture of her like looking up and I was like, I just need these blown up and like on a... like framed.
Oh my gosh.
I want them so bad.
Thank you for the summertime!
Thank you.
Okay.
Let's get going, baby.
Let me also...
Um...
Okay, this is a good little area to remember how to do stuff, right?
Okay, so this is...
to fight.
B is to attack.
This is to crouch.
For those coming in and maybe didn't watch part one, um, this is my first time...
Well, I guess now.
This is my second time ever playing on a GameCube.
So I'm still... What is Y?
Is it nothing?
Oh no, that's the action button.
That's the action button.
If you were isekai to the MGS verse, who would you want to be reborn as?
Oh...
Maybe Sunny.
I feel like she has the least amount of trauma.
Also, it would be so cute to just make them eggs every morning.
And I can see...
I can see all the good Snake Otacon goodness, right?
Mei Ling...
Practice putting away your gut.
We're good.
I think I got this.
I say.
Right now.
Okay, so we have to go back to the armory.
To all...
We have to go all the way back to the armory.
You know, it might be good to just, uh...
Probably, maybe...
Wait, teleport?
Oh!
Wait.
No.
We have to go through the nuke building.
We're in the nuke building.
So if we go to the armory and then take this, then maybe we can go back.
There's a PSG on this floor in the remake.
Okay.
For what I understand, that PSG is a...
What's the word?
Is a, uh...
Tranquilizer version.
And...
Yeah, PSG-1T.
And honestly...
The tranq stuff...
Having, like...
Doing fights with the tranq...
Feels like it's, you know, like...
Even though it doesn't matter, it doesn't truly matter...
Like, you know, how am I supposed to do sniper wolf scene if I use the tranq PSG-1?
You know what I mean?
You are true VTuber and true patriot.
Mint boss.
Thanks, Ronin!
I don't know!
You enjoy all the killing.
Only in this game.
Because it makes sense, right?
It's not in the spirit of the original work.
Exactly!
So I feel like I have to go all the way back.
Even though I don't want to.
I don't want to, but I feel like I have to.
We're just gonna hide over here while we wait.
Oh, it's open.
That was fast.
And up to one.
They die from tranq overdose.
Maybe.
Oh my gosh.
This area is scary.
This area is so scary.
Recently, I have been feeling so sick.
And I was fine earlier.
Well, I was sick earlier, and then I felt fine, and now I'm starting to feel sick again.
Oh no.
I think I'll be okay though.
Maybe it's just nerves.
Maybe it's just me being a little baby.
Go!
Nice for you!
Um...
Does he turn around?
This is our only chance.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
She doesn't see me, right?
Okay.
This guy's gonna turn?
He doesn't come down though.
Oh, thank god.
Oh, she's We almost started out real crazy.
Okay.
Just a box!
I can't see where everybody is.
Where are you guys anyway?
I can't see at all.
I'm just gonna go.
I don't know if we can make it into the...
Why are your footsteps so loud, Snake?
There we go.
Oh.
Shit.
Oh, shit.
I think, um...
I think I'm doomed.
Um...
Just a box!
Just a box to the heliport!
To the heliport, please!
No!
I didn't... Oh, gosh.
Um...
Oh, I can't use...
You guys can't use weapons here either!
You guys can't use weapons here!
Can I have my box back?
Thank you.
Get out of here!
Oh, shoot.
That's why they have their little masks on.
This is messed up.
Come on, Snake!
Wait, why did that happen to you?
Crawl?
Crawl, crawl, crawl.
Here?
Okay.
Oh.
Uh...
Something over...
Oh, um...
My dad?
No way.
You can't do this!
Me!
If I get in here and I...
use the box...
Will it work?
I wonder.
To the heliport, please!
Okay.
Wow.
That was so...
Great start, everybody.
Great start.
That's okay.
That's so unfair that they can use...
weapons here.
No way.
That is so unfair.
I feel...
I feel like...
that they should also...
just, you know...
That is so unfair.
These guys...
These manomachines don't care if uranium leaks...
from shooting the nukes.
They just want to see the world burn.
Their gas masks, I can guarantee you...
I picked up the same gas mask...
that they are wearing...
and it is not any better.
It is not any better than...
You know what?
I probably could knock this guy out.
But, whatever.
Get down to this.
Oh, oh.
Right here.
Snake.
There you go.
Right there.
Okay.
It is not any better than what I'm using.
So, these guys should be down...
just as much as I am.
Ugh.
Maybe the mask doesn't fit right.
What are you saying?
I have a small face or a big face?
You know what?
I'm just going to leave.
I'm not even going to...
take the special way.
We are just going to go the long way.
We are going to...
Let's go.
The door.
Okay.
Alrighty.
Is there anything over here?
Oh.
Do I need any rations?
Yes.
Nice.
Do I need also...
Mind detectors here.
I can't ever remember.
Oh.
It's just...
Wait.
There is actually people?
There is people.
People?
Oh my god.
There is a person.
Since when?
Oh my god.
No.
No, sir.
You seriously...
didn't see anything.
Where are you?
Oh.
Are you coming around this way?
Just your imagination, dummy.
Can I hit him through here?
That would be crazy.
You can't see me through the...
There we go.
Wow.
The cameras are kind of crazy out here.
Hello?
He didn't even notice my footsteps.
What?
This guy is totally new at the job.
How do I get around here?
Okay.
It's range is kind of insane.
You know what?
Maybe I should...
Why am I making life harder for myself?
Oh.
Who saw me?
Someone saw me.
Oh.
There is people here.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Ah.
Warning shots.
Warning shots at you.
I can't see anything.
Where the hell are you?
Oh my god.
Let's run.
Oh.
That's a person.
Ouch.
I tried attacking you and I don't know what happened.
Um.
Let me in.
Why is everything so bad today?
Um.
Ouch.
Hello?
Oh.
I keep pressing the wrong...
Leave me alone.
Oh.
This is a fight.
Come on man.
CQC.
Something something.
Basics of CQC.
I thought I would be safe over here.
I thought there was nobody.
I didn't...
I should have just stuck right here.
This sucks you guys.
Oh my god.
This sucks.
What a terrible area.
I thought there were only just cameras out here.
I have to worry about people now too?
This is the worst.
Oh shoot.
Don't make me go through this again.
Please.
God.
And I can't even hit.
Can't even aim.
Oh.
I'm
gonna investigate you.
Does this need to be a backup unit?
That's ridiculous.
Why would there need to be a backup unit?
Why would there need to be a...
Oh god.
Why
isn't it aiming?
Hello gun?
Oh there it is.
Cause I need to press a button.
Sir.
Just go down.
Oh my gosh.
Why am I going this way?
Should I just go back?
I think I should just...
I hit him right?
Maybe it's too far.
Don't kick him.
Looks all clear.
It does?
He just fell asleep twice.
Like a big old bozo.
The other way looks easier now.
It actually does.
Oh.
Okay come here.
Go back to sleep and we're gonna go back inside.
Oh shit.
Yep.
Okay.
What a waste of my time.
I almost wanna just get the...
Look at... he's like stomping down.
He's just as mad as I am.
He's like...
There's not supposed to be guys there.
What the heck did they...
Why did they add more security to the...
I'm just so angry.
Where's their men?
I...
I swear.
Those guys.
They shouldn't even realize that he hasn't reported those so quickly.
I just can't with them.
Sometimes they wanna be so dumb.
And other times they actually wanna be 180 IQ.
It's just not fair.
That's literally me.
I can't shoot from...
Oh wait.
I can't shoot at all.
Oh...
God.
Maybe the book would help here.
There's the camera here.
Hey boss, I gotta go.
I promise to watch the VOD later.
Thank you!
Good luck with whatever you're doing or have fun.
GLHF.
Good luck.
Have fun.
Isn't there a truck here?
There is.
It's just that I got spotted so quickly before that I was like...
You know what?
I'm not gonna bother.
But...
Oh.
Here comes this guy.
You did not see me.
No?
Absolutely not.
Excuse me!
Don't be like that.
That was insane.
Time to crawl, crawl, crawl, crawl.
Crawl, crawl, crawl, crawl.
Box, box.
Oh.
I was like...
What do you mean no use?
Don't tell me that.
It's so scary when they say that.
Okay.
The camera is right there.
I can probably...
Go in here.
Oh.
We don't see the other guy.
Okay.
Yep, yep, yep.
Hahaha.
Okay.
I think I see them meeting up.
They're doing their kissing.
I think I need to go.
Slow and steady.
I don't know where the other guy is.
That's why I'm trying to be so cautious.
I wanna get caught.
Wait.
No.
That's the guy up there.
Where?
Okay.
So he takes a really long time to get around here.
There he is.
Okay.
Surveillance camera.
Oh yes.
Here they are.
They're meeting up.
No.
Get up.
Snake.
Snake please.
God.
Okay.
Alright.
We're all good.
Notice me.
I'm just a little box.
I'm just a precious innocent little box.
I just wanna go to the heliport.
Is this all there is to load?
To the heliport, huh?
Yeah.
Take me there.
Oh my gosh.
I'm just a little box.
You know what?
I feel like we haven't heard that line very much this time.
I feel like usually when I play this I always hear Just a box.
But this time I haven't heard it at all.
Okay.
I have some magazines here.
You know what?
I am gonna set one right there.
And I'm gonna crawl under.
Because I think this guy...
Oh.
See?
Let him get distracted by that.
And we're gonna take this guy.
We're gonna...
We're gonna get you in the legs.
And he's gonna fall asleep for real.
He was sleeping?
Yeah, but he'll wake up.
Now he'll fall asleep.
Actually.
Now he'll like pass out.
You got it, box.
There we go.
And our other friend is distracted.
So we can...
I can't tell what is the camera.
Wait.
What is the camera?
I can't...
Is the camera just fixed?
Okay.
You know what?
In...
In we go.
Snake.
Please.
Snake, what are you doing?
Snake.
SNAKE!
What are you doing?
Snake, please!
Why is it so difficult?
Oh my goodness.
Snake.
I was accidentally teabagging him.
That was not the intent.
Where was it?
He's really grateful probably.
Do you think there's anything over here?
At all?
I think I check every time, but...
Who knows?
Something might appear.
Can I shoot from here?
Scoop back a little.
I could!
I could shoot from here.
Oh, but then they'll be like...
Where are you?
Yeah.
This is like class A micromanaging.
The fact that he has to send a little status report every two seconds is insane.
Your manager must be so annoying.
Just always...
Nothing here.
I think I would go insane if someone kept reporting that to me.
Every two seconds.
Nothing here.
I'm a little fish.
I'm a little fish in the sea.
I'm a little drowning fish.
Get out of the water.
The RTO is just lonely.
Look at that.
He'd be a little less lonely if there was something here though.
Nothing here.
I love the way they say it in MGS2.
Okay.
Sounds very close.
Where are you?
Hello?
You are the true Vtuber.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Oh, there he is.
If I get him though...
I think the footsteps I'm hearing are the guy upstairs.
Right?
Okay, he's doing his thing.
Going around.
If I get him though, he's gonna... they're gonna do a status report.
But I feel like I have to get him.
Nothing here.
There's no...
Okay, yeah.
Where is he?
What?
No way.
That way?
Can you just...
Wait, hold on.
I'm just gonna go back and...
Shoot.
I didn't even see you.
Go away.
Yeah, go away.
How the heck did you see me?
Oh my god, Snake.
Just go back to your hole.
Just go back to the hole, Snake.
Where's the hole?
There it is.
Crawl, crawl.
Crawl on in.
No pursuit!
What do you mean?
You're not gonna crawl after me, are you?
That would be ridiculous.
Oh no!
Can you see me?
Oh my gosh.
You and your perfect vision.
Why don't they ever hire guys that need glasses, huh?
Billy, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Yeah, I'll hug the walls next time.
You know, the CQC jumpkick really sells me on the idea that this is Otacon's retelling of the Shadowmode system.
They hired Otacon.
Yeah, but that guy's like...
He... you know, he's a nerd.
They really just said nothing here.
Oh!
Where are they going?
Where do they... oh!
I don't think there's a door in there.
I don't think there's another...
Where do they go to?
Hmm... where?
Have you ever watched animated parodies of Metal Gear games like Metal Gear Awesome?
I did watch Crab Battle before, yeah.
I think I watched Metal Gear Awesome as a kid.
Mint is cute today also, but not as cute as Snake.
No one's as cute as Snake.
But thanks for the super chat.
They hired a whole Otaku convention, exactly.
Okay.
Nothing here.
Yeah, nothing here.
Oh my gosh.
This guy sucks so much.
Oh, whoops.
That's cause I'm crawling.
It's still taking me a second to get used to which one is...
what is, uh...
what is...
crawl and what is not and all that fun stuff, you know.
No, I don't wanna go in there.
I'm hugging the walls.
Where's our friend who comes over here?
Is he gonna come over here?
Actually, I don't know.
I don't know his patrol route.
Hmm...
Lucky Nag.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Oh.
Oh, he thought he saw me.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, did he just say...
He didn't say just a box or anything, right?
There he is.
Okay.
He's reporting.
Nothing here.
One thing I really wanna learn to get better at is like getting the...
shooting the... what's it called?
You know, the...
the...
the remotes.
Trust your instincts as a soldier.
As a gamer!
Yeah, the radio!
What did I call it?
I don't know what I called it.
B1?
No, B2.
It's B2.
Yeah, the radios.
Wait, can I actually go in here?
Ah!
Six.
Did I hear something?
Hmm.
Oh, it was... I heard the music.
Yeah, get in the radio.
Oh, B2.
I could never get down shooting the radio in any game.
It's really... I mean, it's like the tiniest target, right?
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, that guy was right there.
I think every time I start, he's always right there.
Okay.
PSG...
is...
somewhere.
Um...
Somewhere in here.
Alright, let's just let these guys kind of... Oh!
Rendezvous!
Just gotta go for it.
Oh my god, the trap is still open.
This side.
C4.
Akita.
Does he come around here?
Oh my god.
Ah!
No!
I didn't...
I didn't B2.
No.
No, I'm just a box.
I'm...
This is so messed up.
This is so...
I can't believe you can turn on the safety on this thing.
I guess maybe if you're trying to hold up someone and you, uh...
You don't wanna...
You don't wanna kill them for real.
Okay, let's see.
How do I get out of this predicament?
Hmm...
Okay, I'm on rations.
Okay.
Slowly standing up.
And fire!
Fire!
Fire at whoever is...
Oh!
I'm not firing at anyone!
Oh my god.
Um...
I'm... Oh!
Kill you!
Hey!
Oh my gosh.
You don't think they'll see me right here, right?
I hate...
I hate you!
Why do you have to be...
Oh my god!
Where did you come from?
Oh.
I'm so far away from you.
Yeah.
Stop!
Stop it!
Leave me alone!
Okay, let's retry that.
Let's... Maybe there's a ration in here.
I can run.
Oh!
Oh my god.
We were so close!
To using that other ration.
My...
I panicked.
And like my...
And I did a little 360 with my...
With the stick.
Okay, let's see.
There's some stuff in here probably.
Right?
Yeah!
There's still some stuff in here.
Get everything but it.
Anything in here?
Probably can unequip this.
Nice.
Okay.
Let's just take a little bit of stuff.
All according to plan, of course, as always.
Yeah.
It was obviously my intention to just get more...
More stuff.
Obviously.
Duh.
Nothing under here.
Meryl, you stingy.
Just as planned.
Nasty.
More books.
I'll take it.
Is there anything...
Oh wait.
I'll take it.
I can't take it.
Too many of it.
And I don't think...
Was there...
Hmm.
I think there's stuff up here.
Climb.
Oh.
I can't climb it anymore.
It won't let me go into the vents.
I can go into these vents though.
Okay.
Who would have thought that it would take...
It would be this difficult.
Yeah!
I knew it.
That would be this difficult just to get the dang PSG.
Well, difficult for me.
Alright.
One thing I love though about this game.
Is when you are down.
And then you press to stand back up.
It doesn't put you just into the crouch.
It actually stands you up.
Because that would get me so many games where I would be like lying down and I'd be trying to stand up.
And then I stood up like this, you know.
Oh yeah, save.
Good plan.
Wait.
Um.
With A.
Yes.
Start and A button.
Okay.
Campbell!
I wonder if he tells me that there's one.
What's it called?
One.
Have you ever seen a sniper rifle anywhere on this base?
A sniper rifle?
Meryl's been shot by an extremely good sniper.
Sniper.
A high quality sniper rifle is the only way I can fight back.
I wonder if he tells me about the Tranquiline.
I saw one in the armory in the second floor basement of the tank hangar.
The second floor basement of the tank hangar?
I have to go all the way back there.
It's literally me.
Yeah.
What's wrong with you Otacon?
Nothing.
He sounds good.
I'm so...
so shy.
Nothing.
You know.
Don't worry about it.
He wouldn't get it.
There's nothing.
You need to make snap decisions.
In war, the difference between living and dying is counted in milliseconds.
True.
I made those decisions.
I made good ones.
I made good ones, Master.
Like turning around.
You cannot win without a sniper rifle.
You cannot save the girl either.
Find a sniper rifle.
It is the only way to save Meryl.
Only way.
Meiling.
I could have used your advice.
I did.
Let's save since we're here.
We're gonna save.
Yes.
Whatever you say, Nastasha.
Alright.
B.
There's a Chinese proverb.
The mind cannot be in two places at once.
Make sure you're not thinking of something else during the mission, okay?
I'm thinking of you, baby girl.
Okay, turn the sound back down.
For some reason, the...
The um...
The codex are so...
The audio is so low.
Okay.
Back to B2.
I don't even know where the PSG is.
I was just going...
I was going the...
I don't even know if I was going the right way.
I don't even know.
Wait.
Those guys are still knocked out.
No way.
Wait a second.
Yeah, I'm gonna tranq them.
I have to make sure I do this correctly, though.
You know?
Okay.
Never mind.
Never mind!
Well, they can't take the elevator.
Because it's occupied.
I wish I could shoot from the box, man.
It would be so nice to be able to shoot from the box.
They won't look in here, right?
I just gotta wait it out a little bit.
Too OP?
Probably, yeah.
Look at this guy.
What are you doing over there in the corner?
Oh, yeah.
Go look around.
Do your job.
There's a maniac on the loose.
He's absolutely wild.
Oh, there he goes.
Stay sharp, everybody.
Okay.
Okay, they have a reset.
Very good.
Very nice.
Okay.
This guy's gonna come.
He's gonna be like...
The reason I keep going to the right...
Is...
Because...
Well, I guess my left.
The left...
The...
The right of the...
You know where I'm going.
The reason I keep going that way is because I'm most...
Familiar with that guy's...
Pattern.
That guy's route.
So, it's a little easier for me.
The...
The radar...
Right...
My... Like snakes...
Snakes left.
Yeah.
Who's right?
Who's on first base?
Okay.
Can I go now?
I'm so scared.
I don't want to get caught again.
Come on, guys.
Don't even worry about me.
I'm just a box.
Just a little box.
I don't know where the PSG is.
Please turn away.
I keep thinking this is a hole in the ground.
It scares me so much.
Where am I?
Smoking.
A little left.
Is he coming down?
Where does he go?
Where are these two guys?
These guys gang up.
That's why I got caught.
Okay, this guy goes down and he comes...
This way.
Yeah.
And then he goes up?
He stops there?
Turned around?
Turned around.
Then he goes up.
Yeah.
Is this it?
This is the hand grenades.
Dang it.
Nah.
Every second you wait, Meryl gets close to death?
Good.
Are they camping it up there?
It's not that one up there, is it?
It can't be that one.
The one that the guy is literally standing in front of.
It can't be that one, right?
How do I get past this guy?
I can't see it.
Just a box.
I think he's right in front of it.
I think it's that one.
Just prank him.
I'm scared.
Hold on.
Okay.
Once the bottom guy goes to the top...
We're gonna run right past him.
When he turns around.
I think he looks here.
Yeah.
He looks down here.
And he goes up.
And... Okay.
Don't notice me.
Please, God.
Okay.
We're just gonna have to blast through him...
And then go up.
We're gonna...
We're gonna blast through him.
And then go up.
No.
I was trying to...
Wait.
Maybe I pressed start B on accident.
Hold on.
I'm busy.
Please.
I'm busy right now.
I'm busy.
Oh my God.
Please.
I'm trying to...
Oh.
Press the button.
How are you hitting me?
If I can't hit you, you can't hit me, bitch!
If
I can't hit you, you can't hit me, bitch!
Elevator's here.
Oh.
It doesn't work.
I'm...
Oh.
I think they noticed me.
You think?
We have no more...
Why does the thing have to be there?
You son of a...
Bitch.
You son of a bitch!
Snake, are you okay?
Snake!
I'm not okay.
I'm actually molding.
Oh my God.
Why do I have to have...
Why do I have to...
Why?
Why did I have to be like...
I was gonna say...
Why did I have to be...
Why do I have to be so like...
Like...
Oh.
I don't want the tranquilizer.
I want the legit thing.
I want the real deal.
Okay.
Can I get a rock?
This side.
Wait.
I didn't...
They're not gonna notice me.
Okay.
Just kill me.
No.
I won't let you kill me.
Where's the hole?
I'll kill myself!
I knew the guy was gonna turn around.
So I was gonna have to be like...
Oh shoot.
Okay.
When I go in there...
Once I make my move...
You're free to go past the guard.
Okay.
Now turn around.
Are they gonna come in here or...
You know what?
I'm just gonna wait it out and see.
I'm just gonna wait it out.
Are they gonna come in here?
Past me.
I can't get the tranq PSG one.
Because it's not canon to the game.
Me right now.
I hate past me.
You know what?
Past me sucks.
Past me has bad ideas.
I...
It's going down.
I'm too afraid to move.
Because the door is gonna open.
Just let all these guys...
Go away.
Okay.
Now I know this guy stays here.
But I just wanted less guys around.
Okay.
Is the door still open?
I didn't hear it shut.
You know what?
Whatever.
Oh, there it is.
I can't tell.
I think it reopened again.
If I have to go backwards...
I have to go backwards.
No, please.
Please.
I'm just a worm.
I'm just a little guy.
I'm just a little wormy guy.
Why did the door have to open?
Oh, God.
I made it there so...
It was so clean too.
He's gonna turn around.
Okay.
I'm under attack.
Is it open or not?
I can't tell at all.
Okay.
It's open.
How am I supposed to...
I'm under attack.
Stay alert.
How am I supposed to get through?
The red line...
means it's open?
I'm guessing.
You can see in the minimap if it's open.
I couldn't tell before though.
It's closed.
Are you sure?
Red line is closed.
Yes!
Cradle!
You got a sniper rifle?
You can use that against Sniper Wolf.
After.
Hurry up and save Meryl.
You can use that against Sniper Wolf.
I'm trying.
I don't want to save her anymore.
She doesn't deserve it.
She doesn't deserve my lava.
After everything I've been through, Colonel.
Oh, I see it!
I see what you guys mean though.
Okay.
That guy...
Once he turns around...
Pass this.
Here.
Whew.
Okay.
Oh shoot.
We're good.
Okay.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
This guy's gonna come up.
Oh.
Nope.
Press the button.
Books.
Shoooooo!
Oh.
Metal Gear Gaming.
Okay.
Give me a break.
Just give me...
Give me one second in the B1.
Holy moly.
Okay.
So now...
Do you think there's that ration back there again?
No wonder.
Wouldn't it be kind of awesome if it respawned?
Okay.
Basha min!
Hello!
No.
Imagine if you fell into that hole.
What do you take me as?
A rookie?
I could not see that first one though.
Okay.
How do I want to do this?
Let's see.
Um...
I'm gonna go to the Kusa Land concert tomorrow.
But I've never gone to a concert by myself before.
It's not a concert.
It's like...
It's so casual.
Just wear whatever you want.
It's just people playing anime music.
That's all it is.
Yeah.
So...
Don't feel like you have to dress up.
Or dress up.
Actually put on your best suit.
I think it'd be awesome.
Put on your best suit.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um...
I'm trying to think.
Yeah.
Probably going back to the...
Well, if I go back to the truck...
Okay.
We'll have to knock that guy out.
We'll have to shoot his little toes.
That's okay.
We can shoot his toes.
We'll shoot his toes.
You're producing an IDEL group made up of MGS characters.
Name the unit and the center.
He cannot be SNAKE.
Center can be KAZ.
I think he'd be a great.
KAZ or OSALOT.
OSALOT could be a great center because he's got that appeal of...
and I mean this.
in the most loving way...
A little pause... and we are back.
Let's see where this guy is.
Like, who is that over there?
Is that outside?
Like me?
A little quirky?
No, I think I'm...
I don't think like me.
Oh, there he is.
Okay, he's walking up.
Yeah, exactly.
This guy is not...
No.
I'm not having you come all the way down here to investigate my box.
We are not doing that.
Okay.
Welcome to membership, you guys!
Thank you so much!
Like, okay, sorry.
I was like half...
being able to talk.
So like, for example, part of like...
For example, part of like...
Ah-Chan from AKB.
She was like the center for AKB for a super duper long time.
And like...
Oh my gosh.
Why?
Why is my O2 go down so fast?
But part of her appeal was just like how uninterested she was.
People are like, yeah, we kinda like that she's...
Wait.
Wait a second.
Am I gonna...
run into this guy?
Okay.
I was so scared for a second.
Sorry, I gotta get your...
Gotta get your ankles.
Let's get you a couple times.
Where's that coming from?
Got mosquitoes in Alaska?
That's wild.
I know.
I know, man.
Must be hard.
Oh, I forgot about his...
Oh, no, no, no!
Oh, can I...
They already did the radio.
Where is his radio?
Oh, shoot.
But I don't know where to shoot.
But I
don't know where to shoot.
Just imagine...
Freeze.
Just imagining...
I held him up!
It's him.
Everyone stay on guard.
Freeze.
No!
No way!
I can't.
This is so funny.
No way!
Who's that?
It's the enemy.
Oh.
There's no way he should have known.
Do you think if I go back, I'll be fine?
La la la.
Why did he kick the guard?
I don't know.
La la la.
La la la la la.
Okay.
When I shoot this guy, I have the most...
short amount of time to run over to the truck.
But I also have to make sure I am not seen going to the truck.
Which is...
I can't tell...
This guy doesn't like walk around this way.
Like the guy over there by the truck that will see me.
Shoot guy chaff?
That might work.
I do have some stun grenades, but I think that'll make too much of a scene.
Maybe.
That'll make too much of a scene, right?
Yeah, well the camera is what the chaff grenade would be for.
Throw a magazine to lure him away.
He'll come back though, right?
Throw a magazine?
You mean this magazine, not the...
Let's lure him.
We're throwing really far.
All the way!
Can I get between his legs?
There!
Oh, that did not go far, you guys.
You guys, that didn't go very far.
Oh!
Okay, hold on.
Now, I wonder if I can get his...
Oh!
I frozen!
I've got him!
Um...
If I hold this...
Uh...
Now...
Wait, I'm frozen!
I can't do anything!
Uh...
Hmm... Uh...
I literally can't move!
I can't... I can't get out!
If I unequip, it unfreezes him!
Oh, shoot!
Okay, I'm gonna get you in the foot.
Sorry, man.
Uh...
Uh... Get up!
I can't!
I am in...
I am in the thing!
Okay, sorry, guy.
Freeze!
How are you still standing?
Uh...
Stop aiming and crawl!
Is he still gonna be frozen?
Okay.
Sorry, guy.
I'm so sorry.
Wait, actually, where's your radio?
What's that?
Nothing.
It's nothing.
What?
What do you mean?
Um...
Uh-oh.
Uh...
Um...
There doesn't need to be a backup unit.
Uh...
Just a couple guys are down!
We have a man down!
Increase to max...
I just wanna get in here, please.
The AWOL man!
I even got his little radio.
It was the other radio.
They're so fast with the radios.
Maybe because he died on the camera.
But I had to kill the other guy.
Well, maybe I could've...
No, I think even if I knocked him out, it still would've been bad.
Hmm...
Yeah!
Guard 2, remain there.
I think this resets their positions, right?
Okay, so...
If I come out...
Quickly stand.
Oh, no, they stopped.
They just took their bodies.
Okay, can anybody take me to the nuke building?
Uh -oh.
Wait a second.
Did I kill...
Oh!
I was gonna say...
Is there nobody to take me to the nuke building?
No one's gonna walk up and see me?
Is this all there is to load?
No one's gonna...
Nuclear warhead storage, huh?
Mm-hmm.
That's right, sir.
Nuclear warhead storage.
I was so nervous.
I was so worried for a second.
Oh my gosh, I can't believe it's taken me an hour to get this dang PSG one.
Holy cow.
Okay.
Alright, so this is our guy.
We have another guy who walks around.
Wherever he might be.
He's gonna come around.
There he is.
Yes.
And I can't use anything here.
I gotta be, like, all...
skill.
Okay.
So...
Once he goes...
Hmm.
Oh, please.
Snake!
Why aren't you leaving the truck?
Oh, I can't jump out in the box.
Okay, never mind.
I think...
That kind of ruined my plan a little bit.
Sorry.
I did not mean to scream like that.
Our friend should be walking up here.
Just a box for real.
Just a box.
Real.
Alright, we're just gonna go down this path.
Um...
Okay, there he is.
There he is.
Nice, nice, nice.
Alright.
Let's go!
Save Mara!
Okay.
Now where's our friend up here?
Nice.
I wonder what that is over there.
Okay, that's there.
He's coming back.
Oh, no.
That's the guy downstairs.
Oh, wait.
How can I see what the guy upstairs is doing?
Oh, I can't.
Oh, there he is.
There he is.
Just hopping upstairs.
Yeah.
Okay.
Turn around.
Is he turning around?
Yahoo!
Get the PSG.
Get the other one for completion.
Oh, wait.
I went to... Wait.
Isn't it...
Is it in here, actually?
Is it the trunk in here?
Is it... Is it this one?
Uh...
Actually,
I don't know.
Oh, wait.
It might be one of the ones that, uh...
Wait.
Are all these... Oh, I can't go in there.
All the cameras are still down.
That's kind of awesome.
Grenades full.
Oh.
Nikita full.
M9 full.
Oh, it's the Psycho Mantis area.
Oh, my bad.
For some reason, I thought it was in here.
Uh...
Anything in here?
The Lady Magazine is worth it.
Probably.
I keep pressing the action button for...
Oh, oh, oh.
trying to...
look...
in first person.
I think I wasted enough time.
I think we can just kind of go...
to Merrill.
I think I wasted enough time.
When I was playing the Master Collection, I thought of you and I used your box method.
It's actually very effective.
It is!
The box is awesome.
The box is...
life, you know?
I only remember this area from MGS4?
Really?
Okay, I was going to say I think Metal Gear...
Solid is the one that I remember the most of.
Actually...
when I do think about it, I think...
Like...
The point between...
getting caught by...
...
Ocelot.
Like, you know...
Getting tortured by Ocelot.
And...
Going down the elevator...
to Vulcan Raven.
I know I fight the Hind D.
But I just...
I think I've erased that whole...
spot out of my brain.
I cannot remember...
ever what goes on in between there.
I know I have to go up the communications tower, but I'm like...
How do I get there?
And then I have to fight the guys in the elevator.
But I'm like...
When do I do that?
It's just...
I think it's maybe...
I don't want to say the most...
unmemorable spot.
But it's kind of unmemorable, you know?
In a way.
I think it's torture tower elevator.
Right?
Okay.
Now we're gonna be the P-Box.
See?
Doggies love us.
Oh!
That's the PSG...
Trang...
That's so funny.
Doggies, where's the exit?
Oops, sorry.
Did I hit you?
Oh.
Oh my god!
Little doggy.
Nice.
Okay, let's go fight Sniper Wolf.
Yeah, I'm a P-Box right now.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
I'm still P-Box.
Oh!
Dang it.
Actually, I think it's fine.
Because I think we're mostly...
What's going on?
I think it's time, you guys.
They just throw you right in there.
They're like, are you ready?
Are you ready to fight Sniper Wolf?
Okay.
I have not used the PSG in this game yet before.
So, let's see how this goes.
Aim in first person view.
Fire with A.
Zoom in with B.
Out with X.
Time to take your pills.
Wait.
Uh...
Gas mat?
Oh, no.
Wait, why am I over there?
Why am I in third person all of a sudden?
Who am I?
Who are you?
Huh?
Oh, okay.
Can I lay down with this?
No.
Crouch.
Lay.
Turn.
Equip.
I never can get the best angle for this.
I can never figure it out.
Can I just do it in first person?
Actually.
Oh.
Hey, girly.
A B and...
Fire!
Oh.
Ow.
Oh, my meds.
I need my meds.
Oh, I don't even need to lay down?
Wait.
I don't even need to lay down?
It's kind of OP, right?
You're gonna look this way.
Oh, shoot.
Oh.
I was so close.
I was... Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Yep.
There she goes.
Okay.
Oh, girl.
Ouchie.
Hi.
Where are you?
Madam?
Hold on.
I can't see anything.
Let's go this way.
Do I need to be crouching at all?
I shot her in the cleavage?
Exactly.
All according to plan.
Can I just be...
I literally don't even have to be...
Oh my gosh.
This is insane.
I don't have to be sitting?
Is it probably better...
Oh.
It might be better...
Run.
Maybe better...
Like...
Yes!
Your hands tremble less.
That's the word.
Better...
Stability.
Stability is the word that I was thinking of.
Oh my god.
You guys.
How do you even stand me?
Good angle for you.
Hello, madam.
Oh.
I must take my meds.
I must take my meds, ma'am.
No.
Got you.
Oh.
And you got me.
We did a little...
Where are you?
Oh.
Wait.
Actually, where are you?
I'm throwing our offer game, you know?
Okay.
Now I zoom in.
And I take my meds.
I don't know why I cycled through the whole thing.
Every time.
Oh.
She's gonna... Oh.
Never mind.
So sensitive.
I got your cleavage.
Kind of shaky.
What did he say?
There's no cameras here yet.
If I remember correctly.
A heartbeat?
I thought I heard like a little heart...
Oh yeah.
There's like kind of like a really slow heartbeat like sound.
Oh.
Goodness.
There is a camera there.
I knew it.
Hmm.
I want that though.
I can get it.
No.
Snake.
Look this way.
I can get it.
Run!
It was worth.
Okay.
Let's go.
La la la.
Picking up the stuff.
Oh.
This game is way more generous on health items.
But you know what I haven't picked up?
I haven't picked very many chaff grenades.
I have not picked so many chaff...
No.
Not yet.
Rods.
Look at the rods.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh.
Codex.
Calls before progress.
You're so right.
I should have done it.
I'm so sorry.
Don't move.
Robin.
It's me.
Starfire.
You do not wish to hurt me, Robin.
Woo.
It's hard to miss when you're this close.
Yeah.
It's kind of weird that you're using your sniper on me right here.
Slowly.
Something I would do.
That wasn't slow.
Whoa.
The triple kick.
You're a fool to come back here.
Stupid man.
Sorry.
A lady sniper, huh?
Don't you know that the majority of the world's great assassins are women?
Yeah.
Do you want to die now?
Or after your female friend?
Which will it be?
Oh my god.
I'll die after I kill you.
What was that yell?
You okay, Robin?
Yeah.
Sometimes she even falls in love with him.
Snake's eyes here are like...
His eyes are like bulging out of his head.
I've left my mark on you.
Oh my gosh.
I won't forget it.
Wow.
Until I kill you, you're all I'll think about.
Ooh la la.
What's your haircut?
Ooh.
Oh.
Yeah, that was nothing.
Little baby boy.
Yeah, I'm like twice your size.
Oh, never mind.
It was everything.
Take him away.
What do you mean?
Why did you do that?
Don't kill him yet.
I won't kill you alive.
Leave it to me.
I want no more accidents like that DARPA chief.
Like that DARPA chief.
He's my target.
Mine alone.
It is Robin.
I thought it was a bit.
No!
Also, hi Hana.
On her mind, rent free.
For real.
Yeah.
Bro is lagging.
Can you hear me, solid snake?
Brother?
Do you know who I am?
I always knew that one day I would meet you.
I like that we can just kind of see the tippy top of each other.
The man who stole the light from my life.
Because of you!
Forget it.
Your body is strapped down tight.
I salute.
I'm the man from whom you stole everything good.
And now, after the sacrifice of our brothers.
After thirty long years.
Finally, the two of us meet.
The brother of light and the brother of dark.
Let me out of this.
Do you need his genetic information too?
Yes.
I want a sample while he's still alive.
We needed to correct the genome soldier's mutations.
Then we'll be able to cure them?
What's wrong with them?
We still have to get our hands on Big Boss's DNA.
They're only 179 IQ.
Have they given in to our demands yet?
Not yet.
They won't give in.
They're all hypocrites.
Every one of them.
Is that your opinion?
Yes.
As occurred.
They always put politics first.
And also, I'm not going to submit immediately.
That's why they want to avoid any leak about their precious new nuclear weapon.
In case you guys are wondering as well.
about their precious new nuclear weapon.
Boss, it looks like our friend is awake.
Who were you talking to before then?
Were you not talking to me?
Did you think I was asleep talking to me like that?
Woah, why are we so red?
There definitely is a resemblance.
Don't you think?
Little brother?
Oh my god.
Woah, woah, woah.
Or should I say big brother?
I'm not sure.
Anyway, it doesn't matter.
You'd like us to be the little brother.
What?
Who's calling?
It's me.
Oh.
Really?
It's me.
Then what?
I'm the only British person here.
Those idiots.
There's a ninja on the loose.
Alright, Raven.
I'll be right there.
Moshi moshi.
They're not responding to our demands.
We'll launch the first one in ten hours as planned.
Oh my god.
No!
Looks like you read them wrong.
Don't point that thing at me, Ocelot.
Something's funny.
Normally the Americans are the first ones to the negotiating table.
They must think they've got something up their sleeves.
So it's come down to it, has it?
We're gonna launch that nuke and write it all the way into history.
Stop it.
Oh, remember the Alamo, baby.
I've got to take care of some launch preparations.
You're in charge here, Ocelot.
What about you?
Wanna stay for the show?
I'm not interested.
Oh.
Yeah.
Take your meds.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Nice cinematography here.
So, you prefer your wolves to my show, hm?
Hm?
Ocelot, don't screw up like you did with the chief.
Yes, I know.
That was an accident.
I didn't think a pencil pusher like him would be so tough.
Well, his mental defenses were reinforced by hypnotherapy.
Gosh, they love hypnotherapy.
Where can I get me some of that hypnotherapy?
Boss, what about that ninja?
That is regular therapy.
He's killed twelve men.
Whoever he is, he's some kind of lunatic.
Twelve guys?
Bastard took my hand.
How could he have gotten in here?
Perhaps there's a spy among us.
Among us!
Ho.
No.
Mantis is dead.
We've also got to find out what killed Baker and Octopus.
We're short-handed.
Octopus?
What do you mean?
No, no, no.
Decoy Octopus is still alive.
We haven't fought him yet.
This is an interrogation.
Oh, my God.
His nipples were long.
See you later, brother.
Brother?
Oh, no.
He's still alive.
Decoy Octopus.
We haven't seen him yet.
She's so awesome.
You know what?
I get it.
Oh, sorry.
Your woman is still in this world.
That was really close to comfort.
Meryl.
He's like...
God, I wish that were...
What are you laughing at?
What?
What is all of this implying?
Catch you later, Ansel.
Woo!
Oh, he wanted a...
He wanted a kiss.
He wanted like a little kiss on the cheek.
When she picks a target, she doesn't think about anything else.
Sometimes, she even falls in love with him before she kills them.
Wow.
Finally.
Just the two of us.
This bed is too big for just me.
Us a lot.
How are you feeling?
Not bad.
Caught a nice nap on this revolving bed of yours.
Too bad I was sleeping alone.
Yeah!
Glad to hear that.
This is some bed alright.
I'm about to show you some of its nicer features.
Woo!
Where are my things?
Oh, don't worry.
They're all there.
In the floating...
Oh, it's actually just a normal box.
That's so funny.
It's not like floating like in the original.
Washington was taking quite a chance sending you here.
Someone must have a lot of faith in your skill.
Carrier boy!
Huh?
So, Metal Gear is armed with a new type of nuclear warhead, huh?
What does that cat mean?
Huh?
What do you mean?
What do you mean by that?
By the way, you got an optical disc from President Baker, didn't you?
What if I did?
Oh my god.
Can you show, like, at least a little bit of his pants?
Is that the only disc?
There's no other data.
What do you mean?
There's no copy?
If not, that's fine.
I love the kind of woman that will actually just kill me.
So true.
Is Meryl okay?
Yeah.
She's not dead.
Yet.
Thanks to Wolf's whim.
But it's up to you if you want her to stay that way.
Uh huh.
You were holding one card key.
Where are the other two?
What's the trick behind that key?
What's the trick behind the key?
That weasel of a president said there's some kind of trick in using the key.
Yeah.
Hell of a...
You want hypnotherapy?
Just stare into the suspicious app that appeared on my phone.
What does that mean?
Oh!
No!
He's not...
You're going to play a game, Solid Snake.
He's not a revolver.
And we'll find out what kind of man you really are.
Enough!
He can't revolve!
Just give up and your suffering will end.
But if you do, the girl's life is mine.
Okay.
They nerfed him.
Press the resist button repeatedly to regain your strength.
Wait, what's the resist button?
When you've had enough, press the surrender button to submit.
Wait, wait, wait, Ocelot, what's the...
When your life reaches zero, the game is over.
Okay.
Should have saved.
There are no continues, my friend.
Oh gosh, I should have saved.
Don't even think about using auto fire, or I'll know.
Oh, he's looking at me!
It's been a long time since you saved your game.
Yeah?
So what?
If your body can't survive the torture, it'll be game over.
He even knows.
You really want to travel down that long road again?
Wait, he knows.
Come on, I won't tell.
Why don't you just give up?
What?
I'm going to run a high voltage electric current through your body.
If it's just for a short time, it won't kill you.
Wait, what is this?
Oh, it's the resist button.
Did you know that it was the French who first thought of using electrical shocks as a means of torture?
Of course it was the French.
Hey, French films are all right.
But I don't care about that crap.
You're a tough guy, Snake.
What does that have to do with anything, Snake?
But I've got some bad news for you.
You're no POW.
I'm surprised you didn't talk about French fries.
You're a hostage.
There's no Geneva Convention.
No one is coming to save you.
Starting to feel a little scared?
Nah.
Oh.
Yes.
Okay.
Let's get started.
What is the resist key?
Wait.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, we're getting straight.
Oh, that was...
so fast.
Shall we go again?
That was so fast.
Okay.
Nice.
Had enough yet?
He's not, like, screaming the whole time.
Oh, I'm not finished yet.
It's so easy.
It's so fast.
Oh, it's all Snake around your dad.
Don't say that.
Even if it's true.
You're a strong man.
I know.
Just like my father, right?
You're the boss's brother, all right.
Your brother.
He's an amazing man.
Who else could shoot down two F-16s with a chopper?
Oh, my God.
The eyebrow.
The Les Enfants Terribles project was not a total failure.
Les Enfants Terribles project.
He is the one man who could make my dream into a reality.
What is that project?
Oh.
Take me home, Robin.
I like how at the start of every, like, change in angle or, like, the cutscenes, like, their hair all, like, kind of resets.
It's so funny.
Johnny!
Where?
Looks like I got a roommate.
Looks so good.
Decoy Octopus.
Oh, my God!
That's disgust...
Ew!
Oh, my God.
Wait, that is actually disgusting.
Oh, gross!
What a stench.
You couldn't tell when you first came in?
That is some severe...
Ew.
Lord.
Ding.
Snake, are you okay?
I've been better.
How's Meryl?
They got her.
Damn.
Colonel.
Okay.
I know.
Snake, the government has decided not to give in to their demands.
We're trying to buy some more time.
Come on, Colonel.
Why don't you stop playing dumb?
I'm sorry about Meryl, but I want the lies to end now.
Now!
What are you talking about?
You were the type of nuclear warhead, wasn't it?
No.
You knew it all along, didn't you?
Why did you try to hide it?
Colonel!
I'm sorry.
Can't tell the grunts, huh?
You've changed a lot.
Metal gear.
Secret advanced nuclear weapons research.
Does the White House know about this?
Of course it does.
How deep does it go?
Of course they do.
As far as I know, as of yesterday, the President had not been briefed about the Rex Project.
Lies!
No basis.
Is that the idea?
These are sensitive times.
Even sub-critical nuclear tests are causing quite a stir.
Plausible deniability, huh?
Yes.
And tomorrow, the President and his Russian counterpart are scheduled to sign the START III accord.
I get it.
That's the reason for the deadline.
That's right, Snake.
And that's why we can't let this terrorist attack go public.
We still haven't even ratified START II.
Or dealt with the issue of TMDs.
This is ridiculous.
This has to do with the President's reputation.
I don't care about the President's reputation.
Please, Snake, just stop them.
To serve your interests?
Because we're relying on you.
I like this picture because Snake looks so mad.
I told you before.
I don't know the details.
I don't believe you.
Yeah, I don't believe you either, Colonel.
If the situation is so serious, why don't you give in to their demands?
Let them have Big Boss's remains.
Yeah, who cares?
Or is there some reason that you can't do that?
Something you haven't told me about.
No.
The President has adopted a firm public stance vis--vis bioethics.
Vis--vis?
We don't want the existence of the Genome Army to go public.
You're just all covering your butts.
For your mistake.
Yeah.
What the hell with you?
I'm sorry.
The corpse of the DARPA chief is lying right here next to me.
Poor man.
But it's strange.
He looks and smells like he's been dead for days.
All his blood's been drained out too.
Drained?
Maybe to slow down decomposition?
I have no idea.
But the chief only died a few hours ago, right?
Right.
But he's already started to decompose.
What could it all be about?
I doubt it.
Just the nanomachines and the transmitter.
Did the chief tell them his detonation code?
I'm afraid so.
Yeah.
It looks like they've got both codes and are nearly ready to launch.
Damn.
Is there any way to prevent it?
It seems there's some type of emergency override device that can cancel out the detonation code.
Yeah.
It's a countermeasure that ArmsTech installed secretly.
You have to unlock it with three special card keys.
But we only have one.
And where are those keys?
We only have the one.
I've got one of them.
I don't know where the other two are.
Besides, I'm locked up here.
We've got no choice.
Forget about the keys.
Your top priority now is to destroy Metal Gear itself.
I'm sorry to have to lay it all in your lap.
But you're all I've got.
Bust out of there.
And get to the communications tower.
I'm busting all right.
What?
Meryl, right?
Yeah.
I'll save her.
Thanks.
I won't do that.
God damn.
I caught a cold.
That witch.
She took my clothes.
Hey.
Shut up in there, will ya?
I don't think I can call Otacon.
I don't know if I can call him that.
Hey.
Are you okay, Otacon?
Thanks to the stealth camouflage, that is.
Yeah, I could have used that.
Why don't you just...
Why don't you just hide in a locker and I use the stealth camo?
I'm locked up here in this cell.
What cell?
There's a big torture machine nearby.
Okay, I know it.
It's close.
I'll be there right away.
Thanks.
Let's save also.
Melee!
Snake, are you okay?
I feel so scared for you.
It must be horrible.
I'm so scared, Melee.
I've been through a lot worse.
Believe me.
He's so cool.
It's a good thing the codec is connected directly to your inner ear.
You can contact us anytime.
It's always nice to hear that you're alright.
Why don't you contact the Colonel?
If anyone can think of a way out, it's him.
Contact the Colonel.
Okay, let's see.
Okay.
When do I get my ketchup?
Please, Snake, don't give up.
I won't for you, baby girl.
I wonder actually if I call him.
Normally, when a soldier is taken prisoner, he should only give up the big four.
Thank you for the raid!
Serial number and date of birth.
But you're not any old soldier, Snake.
I'm not.
I'm a gamer.
I don't want you to tell them anything.
Oh, yeah.
You're strong enough to resist.
Yeah, I won't tell them anything, Master.
The guard is only human.
He has to sleep and go to the bathroom like the rest of us.
That'll be your chance.
That's so true.
Hey there, Johnny.
Thanks for the gift, Ducky.
Look at him looking at me.
Looking at him looking at me.
Oh!
Cover your nose when you do that.
This guy has no hygiene.
Oh, my God.
Go wash your hands, Johnny.
He's checking me out.
Oh, what just opened?
Shut up in there, will ya?
I won't.
Let me...
Shut up in there, will ya?
What's that?
Snake, it's showtime.
Ocelot wants you.
Oh, I know he does.
Yeah, there's snot all in that mask.
Can you imagine?
Tascaru sneezed.
Johnny, 11 years.
I want to do the catch up, so that's why I'm going to keep resisting.
Wait.
You repeated me to regain your strength.
Oh, no.
I have to give up, though, don't I?
When you've had enough, press the surrender button to submit.
I have to surrender.
When your life reaches zero, the game is over.
I have to surrender, don't I?
There are no continues, my friend.
I know.
I fought wars in Afghanistan.
Ketchup means escape.
Yeah, exactly.
Mozambique, Eritrea, and Chad.
Chad?
Among the Mujahideen guerrillas.
I was known and feared as...
Shalashaska.
I was trained by the Russian groom.
Okay, I don't need your biography to also lie.
I'm not like one of those KGB slugs.
Shalashaska.
To me, this isn't torture.
It's a sport.
It's a fetish.
You're all just a bunch of sadists.
Yeah, he is.
Don't confuse me with those uniformed fools.
Shalashaska.
Lookit, his nipples are kind of long, though, right?
Shall we begin?
I have to submit, though, don't I?
Mmm...
Do we want to go through one more time?
What should I do?
Oh my gosh.
It's so easy.
Submit.
You can go through two sessions.
No, guys.
You're really going to want to see the Otacon ending.
I promise.
Okay.
There's three sessions total.
I just kind of want to like...
I kind of want to just like...
Hang out with Johnny one more time.
You're a strong man.
Yeah, I am.
Well, that's enough for now, I think.
For now.
I feel like a loser submitting.
Even though it's...
You know?
Imperialism.
Totalitarianism.
Perestroika.
Did you save?
I did save.
Yep.
20th century Russia has had its share of problems.
But at least they had an ideology.
Russia today has nothing.
Jan, I'm sleepy.
They're struggling between freedom and order.
And with that struggle, a new spirit of nationalism has been born.
The boss has a close friend high up in the Russian government.
He's currently the head of Spetsnaz.
Spetsnaz.
He's agreed to purchase this new nuclear weapons system.
The hind was just a down payment.
Oh, this is Gurlukovich?
You're in this for the money?
No.
I don't need money.
Oh, no, Snake.
I want Russia to be reborn.
To lead a brave new world order.
Oh, no, Snake.
If only you knew what he's...
What Ocelot is in it for?
If only you knew.
Yeah, Olga's dad?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Colonel Gurlukovich.
Watch.
He loves to watch me be dragged away.
He loves to watch me get dragged away.
I'm back.
I'm back, my girlfriend.
What if I hide under here?
I think he, like, kind of...
He's like...
He's calling me.
I'm good.
I'm dead.
Nothing new to report.
Snake, is there anything I can do?
Oh, my God, Raffle Chief!
Thank you for the 50 gifted!
Thank you!
Oh, I guess I should have...
I increased the level of painkillers in your blood.
To the raiders.
Hi, I'm Mint Phantom.
I'm a ghost maid.
Please talk to me.
Say something to take my mind off the pain.
What can I say?
I love Metal Gear Solid.
Anything.
Too much.
I'm not a very good talker.
Please.
Tell me about yourself.
Myself?
That's a tough one.
Any family?
That's not a happy topic for me.
I don't have any family.
No, wait.
There was a man who said he was my father.
Where is he?
Dead.
By my own hand.
Big Boss.
What?
Big Boss?
There was no way you could know.
It happened in Zanzibar Land six years ago.
Only Snake and I know the real truth of what happened there.
So, is it true?
Was Big Boss really your father?
That's what he said.
That's all I know.
And you were able to kill him knowing that?
Yep.
How?
It's what we wanted.
Me.
And him.
That's patricide.
Yeah.
After Zanzibar.
He was the king of my life.
Just like Mantis said.
Is that why you left Foxhound?
Let's just say that I needed to be alone for a while.
And Alaska was the perfect place.
And your fifty dogs.
Snake.
Yeah, I'm troubled too, Naomi.
We all have our problems, Naomi.
Just a big brother who put me through school.
We weren't even blood related and he was much older than me.
Thank you, Minty, for fixing the soundtrack.
I got you.
Where is he?
He's dead.
I'm sorry.
His name was...
Hunter.
Is there a woman in your life?
I'm sorry, Frank Yeager.
After you've been through as many wars as me, it's hard to trust anyone.
Friends?
Roy Campbell.
You're still calling me friend?
Is that it?
Sorry, I love that part because Campbell's actually so cute there.
Frank Yeager.
Big Boss' most trusted lieutenant.
And the only member of Foxhound ever to receive the code name Fox.
Gray Fox.
I learned a lot from him.
But... didn't you try to kill each other?
It's true.
We did.
In Zanzibar land.
But it was nothing personal.
We were just professionals on opposite sides.
That's all.
And you still call yourself friends?
Hard to believe.
War is no reason to end a friendship.
That's insane.
I first met him on the battlefield.
He was being held apart.
He was a prisoner of outer heaven.
But he didn't look like a prisoner to me.
He was always so cool and precise.
He's so cool.
I was still green.
And he showed me the ropes.
You knew him well?
We never talked about our personal lives.
Sort of an unwritten rule.
The next time I saw him on the battlefield.
We were enemies.
We were fighting barehanded in a minefield.
Yeah, it was so awesome.
I punched him.
Two soldiers doing our jobs.
It's like a sport.
I thought there was an actual BGM.
No, it's just me.
Just violence, murdering each other.
It's just me.
I think so too.
So if you were friends, then how do you explain the ninja's behavior?
I don't know.
It's your genes.
They make you predisposed toward violence.
You really like talking about genes.
I don't even know how to sing the song.
Naomi, why did you get into genetic research anyway?
Yeah, why did you?
I didn't know who my parents were.
Or even what they looked like.
This is the truth.
I guess I got into genetics because I wanted to figure out why I am the way I am.
So you studied about DNA.
I thought if I could thoroughly understand DNA, I could get back my identity.
I thought that by analyzing a person's genetic information, Definitely made the cutscene better.
Oh, I'll keep going.
I could retrieve the blank spots in that person's memory.
Memory is stored in DNA.
We're not sure.
But we know that a person's genetic fate is determined just by the sequence of the four bases in their DNA.
So what about my fate?
You know my DNA sequence, don't you?
Your fate?
I...
I'm sorry.
I have no idea.
Of course not.
You're a scientist, not a fortune teller.
Oh, that's gone.
See, part of me is also like, I want to see these...
Oh!
My stomach!
IBS!
IBS real?
Go, Johnny, go!
You okay in there?
If only we had the mic...
Oh my god!
Why does he walk like Sasquatch?
Otacon, please!
Hey, I'm here.
Oh my god.
It's me.
It's Otacon.
Wow.
They even captured you.
I thought he was saying wow.
Oh my god!
Stop being a high school bully again!
Don't be mean to him!
Oh my god!
He can't do anything if you...
Is that how you ask a guy a favor?
Let me go!
What was...
Oh!
Oh my...
The bones?
Oh!
It's like an animal's cage.
What a smell.
Yeah, cause of him.
It's not me.
Hey!
It's the DARPA chief!
Aye!
Aye aye!
If you don't hurry up and get me out of here, I'll be laying next to him.
Gamecube Snake has anger issues.
It's true.
You're such a high school bully to poor Otacon.
This lock won't open with a security card.
That's...
That's a ration.
So what are you doing here then?
I...
I thought you might be hungry.
If you need more food, I can bring some more later.
Also, I got you this level 6 card.
It'll get you out of that torture room.
Nice.
Here.
Take this.
I gotta submit though.
Sorry.
What's this?
It's a handkerchief.
I got it from Sniper Wolf.
Why?
I don't know why.
But she's nice to me.
Sounds like Stockholm Syndrome to me.
I was taking care of the dogs here.
After the terrorists took over, they were planning to shoot all the dogs.
But Sniper Wolf stopped them.
She even let me feed them when I asked.
Then she fed me when I asked.
She likes dogs.
She must be a good person.
Just like me.
Wake up, you idiot.
She's the one who shot Meryl.
Well, that's all I can do.
They're planning to launch a nuke.
I've gotta stop them.
Don't hurt my girlfriend.
Then you'll have to get past the communications tower.
First I have to get me out of here.
Oh my god, Snake.
Come on, I'm trying my best.
That guard's got the key.
You'll have to take him out.
Give me a break.
I'm no soldier.
I can't take anybody out.
Why is he acting like a zombie in a cage?
You have to.
I'll be killed.
Get out of here, Otacon.
He's coming back.
That's what I just said.
See you later.
Bye.
Bye, Sasquatch.
Oh, it's because he's got the bad leg.
Oh my god.
I forgot that his leg is all messed up.
Oh, it actually tells me to use it.
Handkerchiefs.
Sniper Wolf's handkerchief.
Smells faintly of her.
Oh, we got our card.
Nice.
That's better.
Did you wash your hands, Johnny?
Did you wash your hands?
Johnny.
Johnny, you washed your hands, right?
You washed your hands, right?
Johnny.
Shut up in there, will ya?
Sniffer.
I actually really gotta go to the bathroom.
Hey.
What?
Let me out!
Hey.
CQC.
He fell asleep.
They're giving me every opportunity to use this ketchup.
They're like, hey.
You wanna use it?
Oh.
Shoot.
That cold medicine knocked me out.
And it doesn't even work.
It doesn't even work.
I'm so sleepy.
You know what?
I'm sleepy.
Maybe if I walk a little.
Yeah, walk around.
Walk it off, buddy.
Walk it off.
The funny part, too, is like, it looks like Johnny.
Like, I can see Johnny with those eyes.
You know?
Like, that looks like Johnny to me.
Come here.
Come here, Johnny.
Look at me.
I don't know.
It just looks like him.
Bless you.
I won't.
I won't be silenced.
You can't stop me.
What are you gonna do?
Come in here?
Oh.
Alright, guys.
It's time to submit.
It's time to submit like the little baby that I am.
Remember to give up.
You know, it's really hard not to sometimes.
But also, I wanted to see the cutscenes, too.
So...
Seeing the...
Seeing the Ocelot one was fun.
Once more.
Submit to you, Ocelot.
Catrice!
Welcome to the membership.
Thank you!
Okay.
Let's get started.
So submissive and torturable.
Stop!
Okay.
So it's start and A.
Here.
Go submit!
Victory to the 10 gifted!
What do you mean submit?
Oh, Meryl?
Don't look.
Meryl?
Meryl, shield your eyes.
Forever.
Had enough?
So, you're human after all.
It does feel wrong, doesn't it?
It does feel wrong.
But I'll take the woman in return.
I'll have my fun with her.
Before I kill her.
What do you mean by that?
Did he just head pat me?
Meryl!
I hope you can still look at yourself in the mirror, my friend.
No!
Wait, they're taking me away?
Do I still get to use the catch up then?
Mero!
Metal Gear is amazing.
Man, you can't do that!
The future will be changed!
You created a time paradox!
It's okay.
That's why this is not the canon game, right?
Bless you!
Here it comes.
Oh, not again!
Oh, that sounds like you relieved yourself, mister.
That didn't sound like...
There he goes.
That's me.
That's gonna be me in a few minutes.
I pulled an Otacon.
Oh, wait.
No, no, no.
Lay down.
Lay down, Snake.
There we go.
Okay.
I'm dead.
I'm dead, I'm dead.
I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm dead.
Wait!
My stuff.
Yippee!
Call?
Who should I call?
Call Campbell?
Yes!
Okay.
Um...
Master Miller.
I'm alive.
I'm good.
Right.
I go.
I know.
I know what's in... I know what's in there.
Merrill, you good?
He doesn't know.
No.
I can't believe it actually worked.
Otacon, you genius, you.
Hey, Nastasha.
Do you know anything about the bomb that's in my inventory?
Or...
I guess not.
She doesn't know anything.
Yeah.
Just gonna save.
Bomb?
I have to go to the bathroom so bad.
But I'm waiting to...
Good luck, Snake.
Thank you.
Okay.
Start A button to exit.
Where is that?
Not the book.
Is it...
Is it in...
Wait.
Is it in here?
No.
Where is it?
Mindy.
Palky.
Huh?
Wait.
Oh, there's no bomb if you surrender?
Really?
That's funny.
Hold on.
I wanna...
I wanna shoot him.
Not dead.
He's got a whole life to live.
But, you know, I wanna make sure he's, like, actually knocked out.
Oh.
I guess he's not gonna wake up.
Okay.
Really?
There's no bomb if you...
Huh.
Good to know, I guess.
Pew.
Wait.
Why does this always happen to me?
Oh, man.
Okay.
Johnny without Meryl's kind of a sad future?
Nah, he'll be fine.
He'll be fine.
He'll find someone else who will love his...
Who will love him for how he...
Yeah, I don't think it's a good idea to go in there.
I think it's, like, really gross.
Who just sneezed?
Who just...
Oh, me?
I sneezed?
That's so cute.
Bless you, me.
It was me.
Sorry.
He's not gonna see me, right?
What's this?
Oh, that's an elevator?
Oh.
Yes.
This is where we're at.
See?
Remember, like, this part is kind of, like, a blur to me.
So...
Oh.
Oh, we're back in here.
Okay.
So now...
Wait, Colonel, where do I go again?
I'm so sorry.
Kusami taskaru.
Hakushon!
Um...
Why?
I feel fine.
Oh.
I think I'm catching a cold.
Oh!
He's so cute.
Your body temperature is elevated and your lymph nodes are slightly swollen.
But don't worry.
It appears to be just a mild rhinovirus.
I guess I got it from that soldier.
Ew.
I've increased your nutrition and elevated your blood sugar level.
You can't cure it.
Sorry, Snake.
The nanomachines don't carry antibiotics.
Maybe you could find some garlic.
It contains natural antibiotics, you know.
Garlic?
I'm a garlic girl.
Ugh.
Raw garlic.
Give me a break.
Um, your dad would have said delicious.
I want some more.
There must be some cold medicine somewhere on the base.
That would make you feel better.
Oh.
If not, you'll just have to wait until your body's natural defenses take over.
I'm sorry.
The nanomachines?
The nanomachines can't cure a common cold.
But with what we know about nanomachines...
I'm sorry.
They had...
Huh?
They cannot cure a common cold?
And yet?
Early nanomachines, son.
I actually...
I'm gonna go to the bathroom real quick.
I'm gonna go potty.
Um...
And, uh...
You know, don't clip that.
I'm gonna go to the bathroom.
I'm gonna go to the little...
Go to the little ghosties girl...
Ghosty girl room.
So...
I will be right back.
Actually, I'm gonna rewrite this.
Bathroom break.
And I will be...
Right back.
Okay.
I will be right back.
BRB.
La la la.
I hope.
I hope that everyone has been good.
I hope that people haven't been sending, um...
Wasteful donuts.
Bet she forgot to wash her hands.
I never forget.
Ever, ever, ever, ever, ever forget.
Give me one.
One.
One second though.
Um...
Hmm.
Okay.
Now we're good.
Okie dokie.
I sent you a pizza.
Dang!
I was just thinking I was starting to get hungry.
Alrighty.
Uh, Colonel, where's the communication tower?
Colonel?
Where's the tower?
Okay.
I don't remember.
Where do I go?
There must be some cold medicine somewhere on the base.
That would make you feel better.
Yeah.
It would, but like...
If not, you'll just have to wait until your body's natural defenses take over.
Oh!
Sorry guys.
Thank you.
So sorry.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Okay, okay.
Bathroom break.
Forever bathroom break.
I'm jogging.
What would you consider wasteful?
Oh.
Wow.
Whoa.
Um, you know, just, uh...
Spamming...
Uh...
Ones, you know?
Yeah.
You should...
You could buy a gumball with that.
So calm.
My health is good.
My rations are full.
I'm a healthy guy.
How do I get through this?
Where do I go?
One.
One, one, one.
Oh bless you.
Wait.
Do they...
Do you think they have some in here?
Any cold medicine?
It's a medical room!
There has to be...
Is Johnny gone?
Watch.
It's probably like...
In the...
Oh.
It's probably in the locker that I couldn't get into.
It's probably in here.
Oh shoot.
One dollar.
Oh, ew!
Oh my god, that's nasty!
Snake!
I think there's probably one in here, but I can't get to it.
What should I do?
Seems pretty economic to me.
It's going to a good cause.
Is it?
He's cold.
If you're cold, he's cold.
Let him in.
Oh gosh.
There's something else here, right?
No?
This is the medical room and they don't have anything?
Medical room my butt.
Oh!
Bless you.
He's so cute.
His little sneezes.
You have such a bad constitution, Snake, if you got sick that quickly.
You ran into him one time.
Rations aren't garlic?
I don't know, actually.
Okay.
Bless you.
Oh, in the vent!
Oh, so true, so true.
The vent over here.
There's rations.
There might be medicine down here.
I feel...
I feel like I had some medicine.
I feel like I at least saw some medicine.
Something.
Johnny was carrying sneeze die.
There's medicine in Psycho Mantis's area.
You have to go there anyway.
Oh!
Oh, you know what?
You're so right because...
You're right, you're right, you're right.
Because that's...
We were going to the communications tower and that's when we get stopped.
Yes!
It's all coming back to me.
Sneaky Sneezy Snake.
Oh,
I have to go all the way back to the third building.
This game is the first game to ever start my MGS brain rot as a kid.
Never did play the OG game until years...
Years later, really?
Even though this is so much...
So vastly different from the original game, it is still a lot of fun.
It is still a great game to get your start on.
I believe.
That scared me.
That scared me more than anything.
Nothing to report.
What?
It's no one.
Actually.
See ya.
It's no one actually.
Actually.
Actually, how did he see me?
How did he see me?
Actually.
You don't even know why I'm...
Stream sniping.
That guy is actually 180 IQ.
Okay, now we gotta go through this nonsense again.
Oh, oh, I passed it.
Okay.
Honestly?
Just fake a British accent and pretend you're liquid?
The smartest thing would have to been to bleach my hair?
And...
Nothing here.
Ooh.
Robot?
Was that a robot?
It would have been to bleach my hair and pretend to actually be liquid.
You know?
Kind of like...
Kind of like using the Rykov...
The Rykov mask.
I think I should join the team.
I think I could have given them way better advice.
This poor guy's ankles.
Okay.
Let's see.
Now, this is the tricky part because as soon as we take him down, they're gonna be like...
Something, something, something?
Someone's here?
Where's your status report?
La dee do dee doo?
You know?
So we got to...
Figure out...
Yeah, freeze him again.
But...
If I freeze him, I gotta be fast.
I gotta be so fast.
I'm scared because there's the other guy that...
He doesn't...
He does walk around, I guess, then.
Because otherwise, he wouldn't have...
I don't know his path at all.
The guy...
Oh, here.
Let's check.
Let's see where he comes from.
Let's see.
Because there's a guy...
The guy saw me over there, you know?
Hmm.
Okay, here are the other walking.
Does he...
Does anyone ever show up?
He's sleeping.
Like, there was someone that came and caught me.
How, though?
I don't understand.
Where did they...
Where did they come from?
I hope Snake doesn't sneeze.
He wouldn't.
He's better now.
Right, Snake?
Snake?
Yeah.
He's better now.
Probably the guy upstairs heard you.
Oh, you think he came, like, running down?
Hmm.
Maybe.
Okay, so I freeze him.
I come out.
I knock him out.
And then I get in the box.
Or I get in the truck.
In the box.
Okay.
Here we go.
Freeze.
Freeze?
Freeze!
Dropping specified info.
Freeze.
I don't wanna...
Okay...
Maybe this is not working.
So, he's so shivery.
Hey, cold buddy, you just go inside.
There's no one here, anyway.
Anyway, nothing here.
I can do the report for you.
Nothing here.
Freeze!
Snake, if you were a mirror, 149 set of ears tall.
How small do you think I am?
Okay.
I think he's falling asleep.
I think so too.
But then how did we get it to work before?
Weird.
Okay, hold on.
You know what?
I'm gonna... okay.
This might not work.
This might not work, but...
If we die, whatever.
At least we tried.
Did he wake up from that noise?
Why didn't that work?
It exploded.
It went off?
Why didn't it work?
Yeah, did it stun him at all?
Oh my gosh.
Aren't you 152 centimeters?
Yeah.
Duh.
They nerfed the stun grenade in this game.
Get closer for the freeze?
Okay, let's try it.
Oh.
Wait, hold on.
Closer.
Oh, I got it.
I got it.
Okay.
Then I unequip and crawl out.
And stand up and equip.
Gonna get you, buddy.
Sorry.
Taking you out.
Oh, sorry.
I forgot to...
Okay.
Goodnight and...
Uh...
Run.
Clean.
Clean, clean, clean.
Won't anybody take me to the nuke building?
Please.
I'm just a small box who wants to go to the nuke building.
Won't anyone take me there?
Yeah.
Just a lot...
Just a hunk of junk.
That's what it is.
Yeah, there is a camera!
But...
It's easy to avoid, luckily, for that one.
Toha!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Simple and clean, if you will.
When you walk away...
You don't hear me say...
This might be a mistake, but...
Please.
Oh, baby.
Don't go.
Simple and clean is the way.
Oh my gosh.
I don't know if my voice is ever gonna recover, you guys.
It's so bad.
I wonder if my throat is ever going to recover.
I think if I keep screaming, it definitely won't.
But, you know.
If I keep yelling all the time, it won't, for sure.
Oh my god.
Phew.
Give it time and take it easy will help a lot.
Yeah, I've been like drinking a lot of like...
Throat... like teas for your throat.
Actually, I have a different tea.
A throat tea.
I just remembered.
Okay, I'll start drinking that too.
And just kind of like...
Having cough drops and stuff.
Daily.
There
we go.
Nice.
But...
I fear...
I actually have a genuine fear because like...
I can't hit high notes like I did before.
I'm scared.
Maybe a vocal coach could help as well.
Maybe, yeah.
I was thinking...
I've been trying to like...
I was thinking or rather I was doing like some light vocal exercises.
But I don't want to like do so much.
And then make it worse on accident, you know.
So I'm kind of like...
What do I do?
He's gonna look over.
It was risky, but I took the risk.
Do some hypnotherapy for your throat.
Lead singer of a band...
Wait.
I went to the wrong one.
Again.
He broke a blood vessel and sing...
Wait, I can't tell if you're being serious or not.
He broke...
Burst a blood vessel in his throat and now sings better than ever.
What does that mean?
What are you...
Wait, is that real?
Oh,
I do have the level 6 card.
You're so right.
Wait, where was...
What was in...
What was...
Was there any level 6 down there?
I can't remember.
Let's try it though.
Is it pretty flimmy?
No, it's just like...
Raspier than usual.
Like if I...
Oh...
If I sing high, like sometimes I just can't hit the note.
All of these I can go into.
Yeah, 4.
That one I can go into.
This one.
This is 2.
It's this one.
I can't read.
6!
Body armor!
I think this one I was good to.
4.
Yeah.
Okay.
Gosh, taking out the cameras and them staying out.
No one wants to come back here.
Of course they just keep the cameras dead.
It's awesome.
Last time I had a bad cough, it took like 2 months to recover.
Oof.
It was only...
It wasn't a bad cough.
It was just that I lost my...
I had lost my voice from getting sick.
It just hasn't recovered since.
Oh, we can't see Otacon.
I mean...
Well, obviously, but we can't even see that area.
Sometimes it just takes time.
I'll be patient then.
I will be patient.
The commander is waiting for you, Mr. Foxhound.
Gosh, everything...
Meal ready to eat.
Everything is like so, uh...
So quick to respawn.
It's kind of awesome.
Is there anything else in here?
My eardrums are rumbling.
What's on there?
Nothing.
What if it was...
Can you imagine?
What if it was like Newgrounds?
Something like that.
Like Psycho Mantis, what are you... what are you... what are you doing?
Okay.
Doge meet.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Hello, dog.
Oh, wait.
Oh, this is the tranquilizer.
We don't need any of this.
Oh, up here.
Yes, yes.
Excuse me.
Excuse me, pup.
Excuse me, little... oh, wait.
Oh, it's this one, right?
Oh, I have all... I have full?
Okay.
Is there a dog in here?
Sound Rouge, welcome to membership.
Neils, thank you for the 20 gifts and thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, Meryl's blood.
Snake, you're still sick?
Wait,
what?
My trauma is happening.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
My trauma.
I can help you.
Quiet down.
Save your strength.
I was a fool.
I wanted to be a soldier.
Meryl.
War is meaningless.
Nothing comes out of war.
You got a husband out of war.
Please, save yourself.
Go on living and don't give up on people.
Don't forget me.
This doesn't happen if you save her, right?
Snake, about Meryl.
Colonel.
I'm sorry, Colonel.
I'm sorry.
Listen to me.
Oh, it does still happen.
I wasn't able to protect her.
No, I don't think so.
Snake, it's okay.
You did what you could.
Now let it rest.
Colonel.
She joined up of her own free will.
I'm sure she was prepared for this.
No, you're wrong.
Meryl thought she had to become a soldier.
Thought it was the only way.
She said she thought it would bring her closer to her dead father.
She said that?
She wasn't ready for real combat.
I shouldn't have pushed her so hard.
No.
It's all my fault.
That's not like you, Snake.
Master.
What is it?
Master Miller.
Sorry for eavesdropping.
But I couldn't just listen anymore.
Master Miller jumpscare.
Master.
Snake, you can have regrets if you want to.
It's only natural.
But you can't keep attacking yourself for things that happened in the past.
Nothing good will come from that.
He's right.
Don't kick yourself.
It doesn't suit a legend like you.
And besides that, for all we know, Meryl's okay, right?
Oh, right.
Okay.
Snake, forget about Meryl.
Stop Liquid.
That's what Meryl would want too.
You're right.
They do talk about her like she's dead, though.
Meryl would say the same thing.
Snake.
What?
Meryl.
She's pretty special to you, huh?
Well, yeah.
Special.
Master is such a good guy.
Yeah.
There aren't many tomboys like her.
Tomboys?
That's not what I meant.
She's the Colonel's niece.
And a combat buddy.
Oh my god, combat buddy!
Come on.
This is like a police interrogation.
No, I just...
I guess it's in the genes.
The genes?
What do you mean?
What are you talking about, Colonel?
Tomboy love?
No, I just remembered about Naomi's grandfather.
I think Naomi said he rose as high as assistant secretary in the FBI during Edgar Hoover's time.
Is that right?
Yes.
He was Japanese.
And he became a special undercover investigator to nab the mafia.
Uh, lie.
When was that?
Master Miller clocking her lies.
Where?
Oh!
New York, I think?
Yeah!
Go!
Go, Master, go!
I thought that you didn't have any family.
Oh!
I researched it after I became an adult.
My grandfather was already dead by the time I learned about him.
I never even had the chance to meet him.
Don't...
She's making an all sob story.
Good luck.
Watch your back, Snake.
Master Miller is like sniffing her out.
I love that.
Keep through!
Just imagine Snake David Hayter trying to do a British accent to infiltrate his liquid.
I'm telling you, though.
Oh, bless you.
He sneezes so much more in this area.
It's kind of weird.
K-Barn, thank you!
Wait, oh, my donos are kind of weird.
There we go.
The problem with you being on the team is the second Snake flirted with you, you'd scream, hang up with Kodak, and never call again.
Oh!
Bless you.
Don't say that.
Ah!
Oh yeah, blah blah.
I'm gonna try and shoot this one down.
There we go.
Oh wait, my rations are full anyway.
There's only this one?
Okay.
Nice.
Achoo!
Hahaha.
I can't wait for the call.
I can't wait for the call where he's just like, that girl is weird.
That girl is not normal.
That girl...
That girl is...
Telling lies.
Where's a little rat?
I'm gonna take down a little rat.
Oh, there is one!
There's one!
There we go!
Oh!
I gotta put in the other disc.
Hold on, you guys.
Yippee!
Time to change the disc, everyone!
Take it out.
And let me put it in...
Let me grab the other one.
Oh.
Okay.
My...
The first disc, unfortunately, has some, like, damage.
It's kind of, like, cracked a little.
Okay!
I got it!
Disc...
Wait.
For some reason...
I always thought that disc two...
Wait.
Otacon is supposed to tell you to change the discs, isn't he?
I thought it was after...
I could have sworn it was after...
After Sniperwolf.
Hmm.
Oh, it's just in MGS4.
Wow.
Wait, hold on.
I am gonna call people, though.
Okay.
Let's see where we're at.
Snake.
The launch deadline for the new nuclear warhead is almost here.
The new nuclear?
And get to Metal Gear's underground maintenance base.
I'm getting there.
The overland route is blocked by a glacier.
Climb the communications tower so you can go over it.
Got it.
The communications towers consist of Tower A and Tower B.
Wait.
Do I even need chaff grenades here?
You're in Tower A now.
To get to Tower B, you'll have to use the outside walkway.
Remember, Snake.
Dark power.
Dark places are dangerous places.
You can't see where your enemies are coming from.
Please use your night vision goggles or your thermal goggles.
This technically is after Sniperwolf.
They loaded part one with more cutscenes.
Ah, I see, see, see.
Because I was like, you fight, you kill Sniperwolf, and then you change it, right?
Or...
No response?
What?
Where are you?
Where are you, Master Miller?
Snake, it's dark inside the communication tower.
You should use your night vision or thermal goggles.
If you want thermal goggles, there's a pair on the same floor as my lab.
Be careful.
There are always a lot of soldiers guarding the communication towers.
The walkway is directly between the communication towers.
Head for there.
Don't tell me to use thermal goggles.
Not you too, Otacon.
Who is it, Snake?
Not you too.
Let's just save, just in case.
You know I'm the worst, though, at calling Nastasha all the time.
Gather ye rosebuds while ye may.
Old time is still a-flying.
And this same flower that smiles today, tomorrow will be dying.
Snake, laughter is the best medicine.
You should be happy you've got enough free time to play a game.
Enjoy yourself, okay?
Thank you.
Thanks for anything.
Thanks.
When you're in a dark place, you should use night vision or thermal goggles.
Is it really that dark in- Oh, okay.
Is it really that dark in here?
Or am I...
I feel like I'm being...
Like...
Like, gaslit.
I can see perfectly fine.
Is it that dark?
Eek.
The
night vision goggles did not pick that up.
So...
Thanks a whole lot.
Umm...
Oh, my God...
Oh, this is this part.
Just go, Snake.
Just go.
Just run, Snake.
Just run.
Run!
Just run, Snake!
Just go, Snake!
It's kind of...
Come on!
Oh my god.
Ouch!
Turn this way.
Look up, Snake!
There we go.
Go!
I enjoy all the killing!
Killing!
Oh my god.
They come from behind me too?
Launch!
Oh my god.
He can't throw it because they keep shooting at me.
Thank you!
Oh, it did go off.
Oh my god.
No.
I'm trying to auto-aim at no one.
Oh my god.
Please.
Hey, dude.
Uh-oh.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh!
Please!
Right in the crotch!
Yeah!
Oh my god.
Just run, Snake.
Jeez!
Just go!
Just run!
Oh my gosh.
You were so obnoxious.
How do you have such good aim?
Oh my god.
I'm gonna...
Oh my gosh!
What?
Okay, nice.
Just kill.
Go, go, go.
This is irrational.
Oh my god.
It didn't work.
Oh, I'm stuck!
Wait.
I'm actually stuck!
Oh my god.
Please.
Wait.
Eh?
Hey, dude.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Eh?
There's a ladder?
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
Thank you, guys.
Let's just regain our health a little bit.
Because I remember the other door is stuck, right?
It's frozen shut so you can't get to it.
What a thrill.
Yeah, so that's why I remember running just past it.
I was like...
It's time.
It's quiet up here.
I am.
He's so cool.
I'm monitoring you closely.
Your heart rate is elevated and your breathing is shallow.
What's the matter, Snake?
Snake, you're out of shape from all that dog mushing?
Then, climb down and proceed north.
You're out of shape?
Now, automated response.
Why do you say it like that?
I know, right?
What are you doing, Master?
Why won't you pick up?
Otacon, I'm up on the roof.
That was a pretty fast climb.
Yeah.
I wanted to go slowly, but someone there forced me to move faster.
Oh, gosh.
Well, you can relax because there's an elevator in Tower B.
Good.
That walkway will take you to Tower B.
Oh, thank goodness.
Surely there won't be anything like in the elevator or anything.
We'll just go down.
We'll just go all the way down and we'll relax while doing it, you know?
Oh, my gosh.
Sorry.
I'm like, it keeps kind of stretching because my...
So...
Not last night.
The night before last.
When I was sleeping, my cat, he was sleeping next to me and he started to throw up.
And like you can hear when a cat is about to throw up, they do like the...
You know?
And I like woke up and I was like, no!
Because he was face... he was looking directly at me.
And if I hadn't woken up, he would have just thrown up all over my face.
And so I quickly pick him up and I like try to gently get him off of my bed.
But I slip.
I slip and I...
Right next to my bed, I have a cat tower for him because he likes to climb it.
And I slip and I...
I bash my head into the corner of the... of the cat tower.
I'm like... I have like a little... like a little... like...
I have a bump on my head from where I... from where I hit and on my nose.
You can't really see it.
Only if I zoom in, you can see it.
But I have... like I cut my nose.
And I pulled something in my leg.
And like I... it was just a huge mess.
It was like 3 in the morning.
And I'm like... I had to... I literally like launched him.
I felt so bad because he was like throwing up.
He's not feeling well.
And so I like launched him.
And I like fell out of bed.
And like so... now I'm so sore because of it.
Like my neck is so sore.
You wouldn't think like that.
Because like... I don't know.
Maybe I need to like work my ectoplasm a little bit more.
Luckily, you're already dead.
I know, right?
I know.
Otherwise, I would have been in a big trouble.
And it was so close.
It was so close to like hitting the corner of the cat tower into my eye.
It was... I was like...
Oh my gosh.
I'm such a mess.
It was such a mess.
Marilyn, thanks for the five gifted.
Anyway.
Who else was I calling?
Um... Nastasha.
I wonder how Deep Throat's doing.
I wonder who that guy is.
Hmm.
You were gonna have an eye patch.
It was my left...
My left eye, so...
I would have been... solidus.
No.
Yeah, I would have been solidus.
It was my left eye.
Did I save?
I don't think I did.
We'll do it just in case.
What is it, Snake?
Talk to you later, Snake.
Oh, sorry.
I know.
Typical politician.
Of course.
Beep, beep.
Okay.
What do you mean?
What do you mean, President Mint?
No, I said I would be solidus.
George Sears is the president, you guys.
I'm sorry.
in paradise lost.
Milton wrote, solitude sometimes is best society and short retirement urges sweet return sweet return.
That why you came back, Snake.
You got tired of your short retirement in Alaska?
Huh?
No, I was actually dragged here, Mei Ling.
Let's not get it.
Let's not romanticize my kidnapping.
Let's not romanticize how this happened.
Just kidding.
I'm still going to get you a drink.
It's kind of spooky.
Oh, there's the door.
Seems pretty safe.
Is there anything in here that I can...
It's quiet.
Quiet!
Oh my god!
Run, Snake!
Run!
Oh my...
Snake,
dodge!
Dodge, Snake!
No way.
Throw it, Snake!
Throw it!
Oh my god.
Wait, Snake, you're gonna fall!
That's not how that works.
He stopped the momentum.
He hit the invisible wall and stopped the momentum.
How did that happen?
Let's go, Snake.
Blew that up with a grenade.
Perfect plan.
Exactly what I would have thought of too.
Where did those missiles come from?
I'm gonna take care of some errands.
But I'm now ready for a minute to take on Kojimbo's Wild Ride Part 2!
Time to run from a helicopter!
Oh my gosh!
A hindie!
What's a Russian gunship doing in an area like this?
Snake!
Liquid!
I'm afraid I can't let you get past here!
You're not going any farther!
Die!
Hahaha!
It's a long way down.
If only I had a rope.
Woah!
I should be able to use that rope I got.
What are you going to do?
Take on a hide with your bare hands?
Uh, yeah, you know it.
Woah!
Wait.
Did I get a rope?
If I stay here, I'm finished.
Did I get one while I was running away from the guards?
Uh...
This isn't where I fight him.
I go...
I go down first, right?
Oh, I did get a rope!
I did get a rope.
I didn't even notice it.
Here we go.
Whee!
Woah!
That's close.
Okay.
Time to do this.
Whatever.
However this works.
Okay.
I'm moving.
I'm not moving.
Okay, it's still a cutscene.
Okay, I'm moving.
I'm going down.
Yes, please!
Thanks, Colonel!
Hahaha!
Okay.
If you kick off the wall, while pushing the control stick left or right, you make a large jump in that direction.
He's so... he's so quiet.
You can walk slowly across the wall if you press and hold the B button.
Why would I...
To move a little at a time in a certain direction, push the control stick while holding the B button.
If you're careful with the timing, you should be able to dodge the gunfire from behind while you rappel down.
Okay.
You can, Snake.
That's it.
All right.
Oh, here we go!
Ah!
Gosh.
Oh my gosh.
I'm just...
Oh, there's a... there's a ration.
Oh, nice!
Oh my god.
I somehow got it!
I don't know how I'm doing this.
I'm pushing off it.
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
Nice!
I think I'm cracked at this.
Oh!
Was that it?
Wait, I didn't...
That was
not me.
That was all Snake.
I didn't get hit once.
They were so kind with that part.
For real!
Twenty dollars for my 20th Super Chat.
No way.
Thank you!
What was that?
It was breathing.
Breathing?
Oh...
Can I...
Oh, maybe I can C4 this now.
Uh...
How do I use it again?
A button to set.
Huh?
What's wrong with the alert though?
There are people over here though, aren't there?
Yeah, I see them.
I see them.
Um...
Let's take these guys out.
Crouch.
Take my meds.
Here.
I have to be really fast though.
I have to be like boom, bam, boom.
Oh gosh.
Did I kill him?
Wait, wait.
I can't see them at all.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
They're not coming down, are they?
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
Scared me.
You guys could warn me.
Oh.
They won't be able to see me like this though.
Oh!
They can see me like this.
Ow!
Try the Nikita.
I don't wanna...
Wait, how many do I have?
40?
Hold on.
Let's see if the guys are still here.
If they respawned all three of them.
They did!
They did respawn all three of them.
It doesn't feel any easier.
You know?
Until I get them.
Hmm.
I could Nikita them.
If I Nikita one of them, will I get all three of them?
I wonder.
Wait, okay.
How do I use this thing?
Eh...
Release the fire.
Okay.
Here we go!
They're not gonna shoot it down, are they?
Oh.
Don't shoot it down.
Are they all dead?
What do you mean no use?
This is the perfect time to use a scope.
No, the other two guys are still up there, you guys.
I think it only took out one guy.
No way.
What?
They're all still standing.
I'm still standing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What?
That's insane.
Oh, dang it.
Where did they go?
Where did they run to?
Oh.
Uh.
There we go.
I think I got all three of them now.
Uh.
Easy.
Pshh.
Ah!
Oh.
Stinger missile!
Die!
That guy's so dumb.
Why?
You can't get me if you're in a helicopter.
And I can go inside.
Dummy.
Idiot.
What a dummy.
What an idiot.
You can't go inside the building in your helicopter.
What a silly goose.
Ah.
Uh.
What am I thinking?
I gotta go down the elevator.
Good one, boss.
Thanks.
Gosh.
He just doesn't have a brain.
He is the lesser...
clone.
The way to the top is blocked, huh?
Well, we can worry about that later.
Why don't you go and see what's happening below?
Why don't I need to go?
Why do I need to go to the top?
Master Miller, what do you have to say?
No response, huh?
What are you busy doing?
Snake, I'm heading your way.
What are you talking about?
There's something I've got to ask you.
What is it?
You see, I'll ask you when I see you.
Bye.
Wait a minute.
The death flags.
He's gonna confess.
He's gonna confess!
Hee hee hee hee.
You have stinger missiles.
Now you have at least got a chance against the Hind.
Only a chance?
Well, you are not exactly evenly armed.
That Hind is a monster.
You only have a small chance to win.
But at least it's better than no chance.
Analysts are a cold-hearted bunch, huh?
To shoot around that Hind, you will have to get to a place with good visibility.
Do not try to fight in that walkway.
No, no, don't worry.
Get up on that roof, where you will have a clean shot at him.
Yeah, Master Miller's in the bathroom.
It's okay.
He's human, you know?
Yeah, it's a good point.
I didn't even realize or think about that I didn't have the stinger missiles.
So I was like, Let's go fight Hind with my Nikita missiles.
What is it, Snake?
We're just fighting with the Nikita missiles.
No big deal.
If I go out there, is he still there?
Because I kind of want the ration.
The proud man does not eat rotting meat, even when hungry, nor steal water from another's well when he thirsts.
But on the other hand, you were forced to steal or find every item you've got.
Yeah.
You shouldn't say that.
You shouldn't.
It's kind of insensitive.
Thank you for realizing that.
What the?
Huh?
That's so weird.
What?
Why wouldn't the elevator be working?
Hmm...
Fushigi...
Donee...
It's kind of sus, not gonna lie.
It is a little sus, right?
Like...
Oh yeah, I should probably be making sure that there's no cameras down each way.
Okay.
Oh!
Damn!
Uh...
I didn't notice that.
I looked...
I looked at it...
Liquid is a silly goose!
Since Snake is no maverick!
Meanwhile, Otacon is slowly becoming a good wingman by melting Snake's Iceman cold heart!
Oh my...
Ah!
I would've had a...
moment.
I forgot that there's grip in this game.
Good job, Snake.
Stop, you're gonna make me wanna watch...
Top Gun again.
Wait, is Otacon here?
Already?
Our little stealth guy.
Don't shoot!
Snake, you can put the gun down!
It's me, don't shoot!
You don't recognize his voice?
It's me, Snake.
Otacon, how'd you get here?
Well, it wasn't as dramatic as your entrance, believe me.
I'm afraid of heights.
You were watching?
Yeah, I was watching.
He's watching the whole time.
I was riding in the back of their truck.
Thanks to the stealth camouflage.
Whose truck?
How did you get up here?
The elevator, of course.
Okay.
Okay, so you're telling me that these guys...
The first floor of the circular staircase was destroyed.
...are just chilling in the elevator this whole time?
That's why I took the elevator.
The elevator was working.
Yeah, that's right.
Yeah.
Yup.
Just chilling the whole...
You're incredible.
Like a movie hero or something.
Like a Japanese anime.
You're wrong.
In the movies, the hero always saves the girl.
You mean Meryl?
Sorry.
Forget I said anything.
It hurts.
It actually hurts more.
I feel like such a baby that I submitted.
There's something I've really gotta ask you.
It's why I followed you up this far.
What's that?
Have you ever...
loved someone?
Why is the music so creepy?
That's what you came to ask.
No, I mean...
I was wondering if even soldiers fall in love.
What are you trying to say?
What?
Do you think love can bloom even on a battlefield?
Yeah!
Yeah, I do.
The ending is worth it though.
You're so right.
People can fall in love with each other.
But if you love someone, you have to be able to protect them.
I think so too.
I have a favor to ask.
Uh oh.
Don't worry, it'll be easy.
He said the thing!
I told you before, I won't hurt anyone.
I don't want you to.
I'm sorry, I'm hungry.
Oh!
Look at that playful shove.
The elevator has stopped down there.
I want you to get it to move.
Wait, what do you mean down there?
Oh.
You see?
That's weird.
That is weird.
It was working before, but now it isn't.
Maybe the panel's broken.
Can you fix it?
It was working before.
If it's the mechanism, leave it to me.
Mateus!
I've gotta go and swat a noisy fly.
Okay.
I'll stay here and hold the fort.
Good luck.
You'll definitely do that.
You really look like hell.
Are you okay?
Don't worry.
If I do this, it doesn't matter.
Saku, thank you.
Aww.
Let's pretend like I'm not here.
Then I'm not scared.
Looks like he's got a mustache.
Strange logic.
I'm counting on you.
That will become a handshake later.
Here it goes.
Mysterious Sasquatch.
Monocon.
I love Snake's mocap in this.
Oh, nice!
I mean, not nice.
We're about to go fight a hindie.
It's strange.
It looks like Liquid really wants to have a showdown with you.
I'm looking at Madeleine's digitally enhanced satellite images right now.
He really wants to fight.
It seems he's waiting for you.
Like a vulture circling its prey.
Ew.
Are you?
I wish I could do something to help.
Are you guys enjoying the live broadcast?
Please don't go up on the roof.
I have to.
I can't run from this one.
Sometimes there's like a long pause between the codex.
Like when they're finishing them.
Master Miller.
What about you?
I'm about to go fight a helicopter, Master Miller.
I really need your advice.
I'm scared.
Actually, maybe Nastasha would be the most helpful here.
You have stinger missiles.
Now you have at least got a chance against the hind.
Oh, wait.
Oh, okay.
She said the same thing.
I think after I beat the hind, we'll get something to eat.
You're gonna go after that hind now?
Yep.
After you're behind.
It's just circling the tower.
He must be waiting for you.
Well, you won't hear it for much longer.
Good.
In the meantime, I'll fix the elevator so you can use it later.
Hindy.
What about Deep Throat?
I know he's not gonna say anything.
That guy's shy.
No, no, no, no.
Liquid is still hovering.
Yeah, yeah.
Hold on.
Meiling.
There we go.
What's up, Snake?
You can buy fire department elevator override keys on eBay?
What?
What does that do?
Does it just make you able to use the elevator however you want?
In China, they say, once the fox gets his nose in, he'll soon find a way to make his body follow.
That's a perfect description of you.
You can do it, Snake, but you've got to be flexible.
Adapt to each situation uniquely.
Okay.
All right.
I'm getting very hungry.
So, let's see.
Stinger missiles.
Aim in first person.
Fire with A.
Align.
Sight on target.
Wait, what was that?
Fire with A.
Okay.
Let's go.
Can you see Otacon down here?
Is he, like, chilling around in here?
I mean, there's nowhere for him to go.
Right?
Like...
He's using stealth camel.
But, I mean, it's not, like, the best.
Thermal goggles?
I don't have thermal.
I only have night vision.
Oh, my eyes.
Okay, never mind.
Okay, let's go.
Let's go!
Oh, I should have used the body armor for the stairs.
It's okay, though.
Ikimashou.
Yeah, I don't even have the thermal goggles.
What the...
Oh, my gosh.
You jerky!
Gosh...
Okay, this is where I have to start looking out for the...
For the...
Cameras.
I didn't know MGS was moved to today.
I'm sorry!
Yeah...
Like...
Some of my plans...
Got moved around last minute.
I'm so sorry.
I tried to announce it in several places.
I put the waiting room up earlier.
It's okay, though.
Honestly, a lot of it was me trying to get the dang PSG so far.
So far.
There we go.
A little too high.
Hello?
I feel like that should have hit it.
There we go.
Okay.
My last Oshi blasted off into space on a rocket ship.
Whoa!
That sounds awesome!
She also used to stream MGS.
Thanks for the stream.
Of course!
You know, I could be your new Oshi if you wanted.
Just saying.
No pressure or anything.
I also play MGS.
And...
I have no reason to go to space.
So...
I'm just saying.
I am.
Sneaky snarky.
I can't ever get this one.
Properly.
Here we go.
You're my new Oshi.
Wow.
Where's your sense of loyalty?
No, I'm just kidding.
You threw away your old Oshi that fast?
Where is your sense of loyalty?
I'm just kidding.
Hahaha.
Amazing how much easier this part is.
I know, right?
Actually, it feels unfair a little bit.
Oh my gosh!
This part is so goofy.
So funny though.
Here we go.
Nice.
We had to move on.
Yeah, I get it.
I do get it.
But if I found...
someone very similar to my Oshi...
Even if it was like a similar voice and everything...
I'd be like...
I probably would also be like...
Okay, you know what?
I get it.
Hahaha.
Okay.
I'd probably also move on.
Nice.
Health is...
good enough.
I won't grab that ration.
Well, actually, I don't think I could come back here.
So you know what?
We will just top off.
Choose!
Loyalty to your former Oshi or your loyalty to Minto.
Don't make me choose!
Where's the door?
Huh?
Oh!
Oh, here it is.
Here we go!
I noticed the ladder this time.
I noticed.
Oh.
Okay.
Have I told you lately that you're truly awful?
Really?
Me?
I'm the bad one?
Mm-hmm.
Sorry.
Only unshowered people are my Oshi.
Goodbye forever, Minto.
How do you know I didn't shower today, huh?
When will we get to see a...
Made Mint live reaction to Ocelot kissing Snake?
I don't know.
Oh, don't forget to save.
Maybe sooner than you think.
Who knows?
What can I do for you, Snake?
Yeah, I really don't want to have to go through shooting all those again.
Though usually it's pretty good about, like, just sending me back, but, you know, what if something happens to the disc?
Who knows?
He who is firm in will molds the world to himself.
Don't forget what you're here to do.
You've got to seize any opportunities that present themselves.
But I guess I don't have to tell you that, do I?
She's so flirty sounding, you know?
Liquid is still hovering around the roof of Tower B.
He's waiting for you.
He's waiting for me?
He's waiting for you to take him on.
Woohoo!
I'll repair the elevator while you're fighting that hind.
It might take some time, so don't hurry.
Okay.
I'll take my time.
Oh, wait.
I should switch to the body armor.
Seize the moment.
Brother!
So, the snake's finally come out of his hole.
Are you ready now, my brother?
Why are you calling me brother?
Who the hell are you?
He explained it.
I'm you.
I'm your shadow.
I'm the son...
Ask the father that you killed.
What?
I'll send you to Hell to meet him.
A cat is so... What?
Standing man emoji.
What?
Okay.
All right.
Okay, so we can see him.
There.
Where's our stinger?
What is he?
Oh, he's fast.
Hey!
I don't know if that'll work.
Oh, I guess it did work.
Oh my gosh.
It's so fast.
How is it so fast?
Oh.
He's so fast.
Maybe he'll come around this way.
Oh, there he is.
Ouch.
Taking a lot of hits.
Oh my gosh.
Just posting a bullet is nice.
Oh.
Where is he?
Where'd he go?
I don't think I got him.
Ouch!
Oh my gosh.
He doesn't hit me as easily though.
Oh, ouch, ouch.
I don't know if that'll work.
Are you telling me I had a bad shot?
Over here.
Over here?
Kai!
Oh.
Aah!
Where am I supposed to go?
Oh.
That's it?
That's all you got?!
That's all you've got?
Liquid?
Oh, is he doing the down, low thing.
Doh Ouchy.
Ouchy ouchy ouchy ouchy.
Liquid?
You can't tell when he's down looks like Before, the music would get so quiet.
Yeah,
I hit you.
It was a nice shot, actually.
Gosh, this fight is so much easier.
Oh my god, you're so loud, please.
It does
get a little bit quieter.
Where the heck is he?
This side?
Yeah.
I lost you.
Where are you?
I keep losing you.
I keep losing you, Liquid.
You come here first.
Um, skill issue, perhaps?
Liquid?
Oh my god.
There's this piece of junk.
Where the heck are you?
Oh my gosh.
That's so loud.
Maybe he'll come over this.
How did I avoid that?
Hey, this!
Almost there.
They did this in the original... Oh, never mind.
Where did you...
What?
Oh.
Yippee!
There's the hellfire.
Eat this!
Oh, here it is.
The best part.
Go, Snake!
Go!
Yeah!
Good thing we got that body armor on.
Come on!
Fly!
Liquid!
See you in hell, Liquid.
Yeah!
Absolute cinema.
Explosions in the background.
Yeah!
That's my action here!
Snake, the elevator's working.
You fixed it?
No, that's the weird thing.
It just moved by itself.
It's headed your way now.
Is that so?
Freaky.
So not at all.
Okay.
That explosion before, what was it?
Oh, I had to take out that helicopter.
Helicopter?
That's incredible, Snake.
You knew I was going up there.
Listen, I just want to make sure again.
This is the way to get to where...
I do not hate this ever.
Metal Gear is being restored.
I know.
It's so awesome.
Yeah.
The entrance to the underground maintenance base is towards the back of the snowfield ahead.
Okay.
Find a safe place to hide out for a while.
I'm going underground.
I know.
You don't have to tell me.
I'm going offline.
And stay out of my way.
Don't try to be a hero or anything.
Okay.
Call me if you need to.
All right.
Mm-hmm.
Let's brag to Miller.
Oh, my God.
Master Miller's going to be really proud.
He's going to be like, Sorry.
I was really...
I had some, you know, I had some Taco Bell earlier.
I just couldn't...
You know, I just didn't want you to hear that.
Snake jumping off a missile is canon to me.
Me too.
Also, are we not going to talk about Snake jumping off that missile like Mario jumped off a Bullet Bill?
We are going to talk about it.
It was awesome.
Oh, he's probably still busy, you know.
It's okay.
I get it.
Did you see that?
Did you see that, Colonel?
You did it, Snake.
You shot down the hind.
I know.
I was so worried.
Liquid couldn't have survived that.
I wonder.
But even so, just because we've taken out their leader doesn't mean they're going to give up.
They're still going to try to launch that nuke.
You're right.
Dedication is so real.
Hope you're doing well today, Mint.
You too, Nun!
The underground base is past the communications tower.
The elevator is working again, isn't it?
I'm glad that you love ace combat probably as much as I love Metal Gear.
But be careful.
Don't waste your whole paycheck, you know.
Snake, stay on the ground.
If you stop by a burger place while looking for food, maybe you'll run into why Miller couldn't help with that hindy.
Oh, he was taking care of his food chain.
You're so right.
Oh, wait.
I don't know why, but the elevator just started working again.
If you take it all the way to the bottom of Tower B and go outside, you'll be in the snow field.
The snow field.
The underground maintenance base is in the north of the snow field.
I was in the kitchen making a snack and I could hear your cheers from my headphones peeking out from my room.
Sorry.
Sorry that I'm loud.
Sorry that I'm a little loud sometimes.
But you can't blame me, right?
For cheering.
There's nothing else here?
There really isn't...
I thought I saw something.
Oh.
Oh, I was seeing the stuff landing on my camera.
Okay.
Let's go take the elevator.
Here, I'll turn my mic down just a little bit.
There we go.
And down we go.
I had to go attend to some burgers on the stove.
That guy.
He's in Burger Town, real.
Why would they give us Fem...
Oh, maybe if you use the Femus on the...
If you use the Femus on the...
What's the word?
Oh my goodness.
The cameras.
No, be louder, please.
I didn't notice that my mic was sounding a little bit weird recently.
Maybe it's just me.
I don't know.
I'll work around...
I'll work on it.
I'll see what's going on with it.
They're all still down, right?
Yeah, they're not moving or anything.
I mean, they weren't moving before, but...
Yeah, they're all pointed...
Yeah, we're good.
We're good.
I'm actually kind of low, really.
Oh, okay.
Like, I have my compressor on and everything.
I'm just...
I just get so energetic, you guys.
I'm sorry.
I haven't noticed, really.
That's good.
Sounds good.
Oh...
Mic sounds fine.
That is good.
I feel with how much you love these action cutscenes, you would love the Devil May Cry games.
I believe you.
I do love over-the-top action.
It's so fun.
Okay.
I
love my communications tower ASMR.
What's this?
Grenade.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, we'll take those.
And here, we use the FAMAS.
We got to get ready.
Oh, there's a ration right there.
I never noticed it.
Wow.
Push the button.
That's why we have Metal Gear Rising.
So true.
Don't forget food time.
Okay.
I don't know.
I hope I don't run into anyone in here.
There we go.
It's working though.
Oh my gosh.
This is it.
This is the codec call.
Snake.
There's something I forgot to tell you before.
What?
There were five stealth camouflagers.
There were five camouflage prototypes in my lab.
Yeah?
So?
If you take out the one I'm wearing, that leaves four.
Hey, this isn't first grade math class.
I thought I'd get one for you, so I went back to the lab and...
And?
The four suits were missing.
Also, about the elevator that I checked out, it's really strange.
It was like someone was intentionally holding it.
When you were riding on it, did the weight limit warning go off?
That's another thing that bothered me about it.
Yeah?
The warning went off, and I know I couldn't be over the limit.
Are you sure?
How much do you weigh?
About 135.
Whoa, he's tiny.
Skinny baby.
But that elevator had a weight limit of 650 pounds.
It would take at least five people to break that limit.
Look out, Snake.
The guys who stole my stealth prototypes are in there with you.
Oh my god!
No way!
Oh my god.
Snake, now die!
Ah!
I can't believe they're in here with us!
I can also shoot!
Shoot!
Oh my god, the spin!
Okay.
So true, Snake.
They were chumps.
They were.
Nice.
I hear...
I hear a...
I hear a camera.
In here, maybe?
What
was that?
What was that over here?
I guess I should collect everything first, though.
Oh, I...
The PSG tranquilizer version.
Tranq 1.
PSG bullet.
Oh, it's this one right here.
Okay, hold on.
Maybe I can get it from here.
Oh, there it is.
Yeah.
That's right.
That's right, buddy.
Try again.
Idiot.
Actually, don't.
Let me...
Let me go.
I just...
I just wanna live.
I just wanna go.
Okay.
Another one right?
We're good.
Too late, fool.
Oh, I thought it was cold medicine.
I thought it was cold medicine.
Okay, when the door opens...
Okay, one of my biggest issues...
Not one of my biggest.
It's not the biggest.
But it's an issue that I really have with specifically the fight with Sniperwolf and the cutscene afterwards.
In the original, the sky and everything looks like this.
It looks cold.
It looks dark.
It looks...
It looks like bleak everything.
And watching Snake walk into the darkness after the fight is one of the coldest things I've ever seen ever.
It's so awesome.
But they make it so much brighter.
But this looks like how it does in the original.
It looks so good.
What game is that?
The original Metal Gear Solid.
The original, the original.
Does anyone have to say anything before we continue?
The underground maintenance base is somewhere towards the back of the snowfield, north of Tower B.
Okay.
Thank you.
Otacon, I'm alive by the way.
Otacon, which direction is the underground base?
It's in the snowfield to the north of Tower B.
Top Cinema.
It is!
So awesome.
The door is security level 6.
It's so awesome.
Like, I don't know.
It just like, creates the atmosphere so well.
Especially when Otacon is like yelling out to him.
He's like, what are you fighting for?
It's so awesome.
I don't know.
It just like, creates the atmosphere so well.
Especially when Otacon is like yelling out to him.
He's like, what are you fighting for?
Oh, it just hits different.
Nostasha, what do you have to say about that?
As long as the strategy of nuclear deterrence continues, nuclear weapons may be reduced, but they will never be eliminated.
If you think about it, nuclear reduction does not mean much without elimination as the ultimate goal.
I used to work in the DIA.
I figured the only way to achieve nuclear elimination was to work from the inside to convince them of the ineffectiveness of the deterrence.
Deterrence?
Good question.
Oh my god.
What about you?
Are these real stats?
Hmm.
Her accent is gone.
It's mostly gone.
It's not as heavy, but it's still there a little bit.
I like Nastasha.
She's so cool.
Hmm.
Might have been even more.
So sad.
You called, Snake?
Uh, yes.
Okay.
Alright, let's go fight another boss.
Oh, you can't say melon.
Don't adjust your sandals.
That means that when things get really bad, you have to try to remember what's important.
Keep things in the proper perspective.
Okay?
I don't think I've ever heard her say that one.
Okay, Gonzalo.
Time for you to leave, Mei Ling.
I can't believe you said that.
To me.
I did save, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I saved.
Time for another ridiculous action cutscene.
See?
It just doesn't look as good.
Just doesn't look as bleak.
Bleak.
I don't want to be able to see the sky.
I want it to be pure darkness.
Oh my god, that was so loud.
Oh, that was so loud.
Ow!
Jump!
Oh no, Otacon.
Snake, are you okay?
Otacon, were there any other stealth prototypes?
No!
There were only five.
So...
Nastasha not returning was one of the big losses.
This isn't stealth camouflage then.
What are you talking about?
Arigato, arigato.
Someone's shooting at me.
Chuu!
Can you hear this blizzard?
It's her!
Wolf?
Sniper Wolf?
Yes, it's her.
It's definitely her.
Otacon, you sound like you're happy.
No, I'm not.
So then what is it?
Snake, please don't kill her.
His glasses.
Are you insane?
Please.
She's a good person.
You'd know that if you talked to her.
That woman isn't as sweet as you think.
I can see you perfectly for me.
She's so hot.
I told you, I'd never quit the hunt.
Now you're mine.
Otacon, you're- Wolf!
No, you can't!
Don't get between a wolf and its prey.
You're pretty good if you can hit me in this storm.
You see?
Women naturally make better soldiers.
Wolf, don't do this!
Emotional damage.
Snake, I'm near.
Can't you sense me near you?
It's a mistake for a sniper to reveal her location.
You think so?
The tension here is so iso.
What a message from me is a message from death.
If I'm close, you will know death is close.
Please, Wolf!
Snake!
No!
Quiet!
Don't get in our way.
That's a different sniper.
Now I'll pay you back for Meryl.
You men are so weak.
You can never finish what you start.
I'm weak.
Now, I don't necessarily want to cheese this.
I think I will- I probably will use the sniper if I can find her first.
It's like so bra- Oh, there she- I wonder where she is.
Oh my gosh, it's funny.
She also kind of runs like Sasquatch.
Oh my god.
Ouch!
Oh.
Okay, hold on.
Let's run this way.
Actually, where- Where is she?
Oh, wait.
I saw her.
Oh, my medicine!
Where?
Oh, there, there, there.
Okay.
No!
How did I miss?
Is she going over here?
No!
She doubled back!
You sneaky!
Where did she go?
Where is she hiding?
There she is!
Back.
Oh.
This is so funny.
It's so sensitive.
Wait.
I don't know where she went.
Uh-oh.
Oh.
There she is.
I lost her.
Oh, no.
Hello.
Where is she running to?
Oh, no.
Ah!
You can't get me.
Okay.
Uh.
Run, run, run.
I don't know where she went.
I don't know.
She could... before I saw like the red of her...
Oh, there.
There.
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Ah!
She just stayed behind the tree, right?
Oh, shoot.
Oh shoot.
There we go.
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh, no.
You...
Sniper wolf.
I'll get you while you're running.
As soon as you come out.
My alert sounds are adorable.
What do you mean?
What do you mean by that?
Oh, dang.
Come on, Sniper Wolf!
This way?
Oh my gosh, my aim.
My aim!
Even with the Pizazzamine.
I'm useless.
It's so sensitive.
Oh my gosh, please.
Oh my god.
Got her.
Oh my gosh.
Even with the Pizazzamine.
Like one millimeter off.
So crazy.
Got her.
Come on, Wolf.
This is too easy.
This is actually too easy.
That's not me!
That's the Pizazzamine!
You're invincibility frames, huh?
Sniper Wolf!
You're invincibility frames.
Come on out, pretty lady.
Easy.
Come on, man.
That's too easy.
It's so easy.
Actually, I don't remember struggling much with her original fight either, though.
That was a lot of blood.
And this is why...
This exactly is why I did not grab the tranquilizer.
This is why I went back to the armory.
Only for this scene.
Otherwise this scene would be useless.
I mean, pointless.
No!
She's so awesome.
Snake, stop standing in...
Stop standing in places!
Like, actually!
Oh my god.
Yeah!
Oh!
No scope!
360 no scope, literally!
He flipped!
He did a flip!
Oh, because my headshots did nothing, you know?
Somersault 360 with scope.
I don't remember that.
Welcome to the Twin Snakes.
Oh...
Oh!
See if there's anything around here.
I think I can also loot after the scene, though.
Oh, Otacon.
Otacon, don't look.
Otacon will remember that.
No!
Don't look!
Don't look, Otacon.
But this scene without the besties yet to come in the background is...
Not.
But it still makes me so sad.
I am a sniper.
Waiting is my job.
Never moving a muscle.
Concentrating.
Oh my god!
I am lungshot.
You cannot save me.
Please.
Just finish me quick.
I am a Kurd.
I have always dreamed of a peaceful place like this.
A Kurd?
So that's why you're called Wolf.
I was born on a battlefield.
Raised on a battlefield.
Gunfire, sirens, and screams.
They were my lullabies.
Hunted like dogs day after day.
Driven from our ragged shelters.
That was my life.
Each morning I'd wake up and find a few more of my family or friends dead beside me.
I'd stare at the morning sun and pray to make it through the day.
The governments of the world turned a blind eye to me.
And I to our misery.
But then...
He appeared.
My hero.
Saladin.
He took me away from all that.
Saladin?
You mean Big Boss?
I became a sniper.
Hidden.
Watching everything through a rifle scope.
Now I could see worse.
Not from the inside.
But from the outside.
As an observer.
I watched the brutality.
The stupidity of mankind through the scope of my rifle.
I joined this group of revolutionaries to take my revenge on the world.
Oh, even this small guy.
I have shamed myself and my people.
I am no longer the wolf I was born to be.
In the name of vengeance, I sold my body and my soul.
Now, I am nothing more than a dog.
Wolves are noble animals.
They're not like dogs.
So gentle.
The word for wolf is Keglanek.
And the Aleuts revere them as honorable cousins.
They call mercenaries like us dogs of war.
It's true.
We're all for sale for some price or another.
It's when Otacon comes in that makes me really cry.
Untamed.
Solitary.
You're no dog.
You're a wolf.
No.
Who are you?
Are you...
Are you Saladin?
Wolf.
You spared Meryl's life.
Even when I'm just an onlooker, I don't like to see women or children get hurt.
Rest easy.
You'll die as the proud wolf you are.
Who are you, wolf?
I finally understand.
I wasn't waiting to kill people.
I was waiting for someone to kill me.
So fortune-like.
A man like you.
You're a hero.
Please.
Set me free.
Oh no.
Little dummy.
Why?
I loved you.
What is it?
This part's so sad too.
Give it to me.
She's not even reaching out to Otacon.
She just wants her gun.
She doesn't care about you, Otacon.
She is part of me.
Ah!
It sounded like the willow scream.
Oh
my gosh.
These dogs look so goofy.
The tiny dog looks so happy.
Like a kid.
Oh gosh.
Everyone is here now.
Okay, hero.
Set me free.
Goodbye.
No.
Snake.
You said that love could bloom on a battlefield.
I mean, I didn't miss...
I couldn't save her.
I didn't say between you two.
No, I was just saying in general.
Oh, the handkerchief.
What are you doing?
Returning it to its owner.
I don't need a handkerchief.
Why?
I don't have any more tears to shed.
He cries more.
I'm going to the underground base.
We're out of time.
I know.
You'll have to protect yourself now.
Don't trust anyone.
You too, Snake.
Yeah.
If I can't stop Metal Gear, this whole place will be bombed to hell.
We might not meet again.
Don't lose the codec.
I'll be behind you all the way.
I hope I don't...
I hope I don't lose the codec.
It's in my ear.
A head start on your new life.
This...
Snake!
What was she fighting for?
What am I fighting for?
What are you fighting for?
If we make it through this, I'll tell you.
Okay.
I'll be searching too.
I love it.
Okay.
I love that light so much.
Oh my gosh.
Aww.
Oh, a sniper wolf.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, Otacon.
Wait a second.
Um...
I recognize this place.
Uh
-oh.
Don't stand up, Snake.
Snake, don't stand up.
Oh.
Uh...
Oh, I'm awful.
Okay.
This death trap.
The VTuber room.
It actually is though.
I think everyone who plays this...
Who's never played it before.
Get her dog tag.
How do I get that?
Oh.
Hello.
What am I fighting for?
Even with the music cinematic change from the PS1.
This scene still hits all the emotions.
It does.
Yeah, actually.
Wait, I'm stuck on top of her?
Loot her.
Aww.
He's here though.
I can't loot her.
I can't pick her up.
Wait, is it B?
How do I pick them up again?
No.
A?
Oh, here we go.
Oh my god.
This is so messed up.
Sniper Wolf.
I'm gonna put her back where she belongs.
Here.
Let's just...
Okay.
Hold on.
Just uh...
Okay.
Hold on.
Let me match it up.
Okay.
Oh shoot.
Hold on.
Just a little bit more.
Okay.
Hold on.
I gotta match it up so it doesn't, you know...
Okay.
Hold on.
I gotta just uh...
Look for the hindy wreckage in first person.
Oh, you can see that.
Hold on.
I'm gonna get it.
I'm gonna get it, puppy.
Okay.
Hold on.
Oh.
And uh...
Wait.
Like...
That.
Oh, what's that sound?
I think...
I think I...
I think I glitched the game.
You could still hear the sounds of me pulling her, I think.
Unless... Unless this is a different sound.
Unless this is a different sound.
Thank you!
Just because you're a ghost, you can't just disrespect a dead like that, Mint?
Is there no afterlife decency?
No one treated my body with decency!
Actually, I don't know what...
It was so long ago, I don't know what happened to my body.
I don't see the... Oh, let me try the scope.
I can't see anything now.
Where would it be?
Where would it be at?
It's so windy.
Towards the south?
This isn't where I go.
Just in case.
Oh, it's more chaffs.
Which I didn't use any of, which is crazy.
More towards the south.
Like down here?
Oh, down here?
This way?
The paranoia.
Let's try going up.
Is that gold medicine?
Oh, it's a bandage.
Nothing here.
To the right side.
Wait, like...
Is this right?
Which right?
Who's right?
Right side beyond the fence.
Snake is right.
Huh?
Look at this.
Are they gonna see me?
From the mini-map bottom right.
Okay, okay, give me a second.
I'll grab them.
Or I'll go look in a second.
There's the other one.
There you go.
More bandage.
Full on rap.
This game is so generous.
Holy cow.
Okay, so this way.
La, la, la, la, la, la, la.
La, la, la.
Here?
I can't see over the dang fence.
Maybe up here?
Oh, wait.
That was down there.
Hahaha.
Over here?
Hmm.
I saw it.
Oh!
Huh?
Oh my gosh!
Hahaha.
There it was.
Colonel, listen to me.
I found a parachute near the wreckage of the hind.
A parachute?
You don't think the liquid survived?
No way.
He'd be mad to try to escape by parachute.
As soon as he jumped out of the pilot's seat, he'd be cut to ribbons by the rotor blades.
Oh!
So what's that parachute doing there, then?
I have no idea.
He's dog food now.
A trap?
Either that or a message.
To me.
Meaning I'm not dead, I suppose?
No.
Maybe.
But I think it's more like I'll string you up.
No, I...
Well, in any case...
We took care of that guy.
Don't let your guard down.
I won't.
We took care of that guy.
He's not coming back.
We took care of Licklin.
I've never seen that before, though.
That's so interesting.
Oh,
oh, stop snake.
You're embarrassing me.
There's...
Okay, this is the way that we...
There's also here.
I know this is all just gathering supplies and a lot of it we...
Wow!
I was going to say a lot of it we already have, but...
Okay.
Yeah, we're like so full and...
We got box number three!
Two!
The snow field!
Oh my gosh, there's a little snowflake on it.
So cute!
Cold medicine doco.
I don't think we're sick anymore, are we?
Can't tell anymore.
I guess we're fine now.
We have a good... the nanomachines worked!
Oh my god, the nanomachines mutated.
Oh, whoops.
The nanomachines have mutated into...
Oh my gosh, they cure all sorts of diseases!
Naomi, you wouldn't believe it!
I think...
I think it's incredible!
How... how advanced they've become in such a short amount of time!
Is that it?
Right there?
Disc 2!
It's rumored that Kojima ended Solid Snake's story at MGS4 because he wanted to focus more on Big Boss' story in later games.
What's your opinion on this?
I mean...
I think Snake told his whole story, though.
To be honest.
The blast furnace!
Oh my gosh, how could I forget about this part?
That was...
Who's there?
No one?
No one.
Hold on.
You don't have a...
Okay.
It's so loud in here.
Holy cow.
What was that sound?
Oh my gosh.
Nothing?
What was that sound?
What are you doing?
What are you doing coming all the way over here?
Hold on.
I think I can...
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
They don't do reports in here, I guess.
It's too noisy and stuff.
Huh?
Alright.
I should probably save.
I should probably...
Even though I feel like, you know, if we die, we just start back at the door.
But it's fine.
I'll save just in case.
You know?
IWSFG.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Who are you?
Late with your status report.
Guys.
Actually, I think also, maybe it doesn't come so quickly if there's no...
Like, most of the time, I feel like I take out these guys.
It's in front of a camera.
It means that if you have confidence that what you're doing is part of your true nature, there should be no hesitation.
I don't know whether your orders are in your true nature or not, but, Snake, believe in yourself.
I'll try for you, Mei Ling.
Okay.
Nothing?
If I can save him, I'm a genius and I'll make him.
Nope.
Okay.
See you.
Bye-bye.
Bye...
Thanks.
See you.
Bye!
Hi.
Thanks.
Oh, wait.
No.
He's up here anyway.
If I can see him.
Actually, I don't know if I can see him.
Where is he?
Missed... oh!
Is there another guy?
Am I just hear... or I'm just... I'm hearing something.
I think maybe I'm just hearing that thing.
Stun gun.
Grenade.
Oh my god!
No!
I... I... I... Oh my god!
I... I... I...
Gosh darn it!
Get his head.
Oh dang, that was close.
I want to take out his radio.
Just in case.
I don't think it does anything, but you know, just in case.
I don't want to shoot you in the butt, buddy.
Yeah, there we go.
Okay, here we go.
And here we...
Don't go.
What a way to go.
Shot in the butt by a VTuber.
Pathetic.
Absolutely pathetic.
I could take him out.
Might actually be easier.
Hmm...
Um, hello?
Where is this guy?
Did he sneak past me?
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Come on.
Pss, pss, pss, pss, pss, pss, pss.
Oh.
I gave you a little bit more.
There we go.
Okay.
Okay, controller.
Was this...
You know what?
Maybe this part would be easier with the D-pad.
I'm not so sure, though.
Actually, no.
I don't think it will be.
Okay, here we go.
Slow and steady.
My hand is getting sweaty!
Steady!
Stinger the crane, get revenge-en.
Okay, I'm gonna wipe my hands.
Okay.
Oopsie.
There we go.
I don't think I got his butt.
Oh, man.
I didn't get his butt.
Oh, it's fine then.
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
There we go.
Okay.
Okay,
it's coming back.
Oh, I have to be just a little rat.
No Terminator thumbs up.
Zero out of ten.
Bad game.
Oh, to be just a little rat who can crawl right under.
Okay.
Oh, wow.
The fake-out was real?
Okay.
Let's get him so sweaty.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, I remember!
Keep going.
Please, please, please.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh.
There's some... some things though.
Yay, you did it.
Yay, I did it.
Where'd those... where'd that...
Where'd that camera go?
Oh, there's one.
Well, we just need to go through there.
So I think we're good.
Actually, I can't see anything.
It's so hard to tell where I'm going.
Oh!
It's so easy!
No way!
Oh.
What's going... what is that?
Oh!
Oh, wait.
I have the dog tags.
That's so cool.
I didn't know they'd be in my inventory.
Oh, here we go.
Hmm.
Seems a little suspicious to me.
Oh, dang.
Oh, what's this?
Gotta check everything.
Yes!
Very good.
Okay.
Here we go.
Beep boop bop.
Boop beep boop.
Ready for Raven?
Yes.
Yes!
Oh, yeah.
Oh, wait.
We have to fight some more people on here, don't we?
Oh, no.
I think this is my favorite updated cutscene really.
Wow!
Oh!
Whoa!
Why did it explode in the middle?
Why did it do that?
Ooh.
Whoa!
Oh, my gosh.
Look up.
He's doing the pose.
Oh, not anymore.
Why did the hat explode?
Oh, wait.
I'm fixing my contact.
Okay.
Oh, he's right behind me.
Are they all just running around?
Ouch!
Oh!
Hi!
Ouch!
If this...
I'll just have to get back in the cake.
Ouch, okay.
Yeah, I have the body armor.
I'm reloading.
Oh.
Okay.
No problems here.
Thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
I didn't see who raided, but thank you so much.
Are you hurt, Snake?
Hang in there.
I know you can do it.
I'm hanging in there too.
For you, Snake.
You keep hanging in there, Merrill.
You're doing amazing.
Oh my god.
Hey!
Delayed much?
Oh, there it is.
Yeah, I got it.
This also has mines in here though, doesn't it?
Am I just being...
I'm not being paranoid, am I?
I could have sworn there's some mines somewhere around here.
Whoa!
Oh, this... now this is the elevator.
To...
To Raven.
You guys... did I tell you guys that I'm playing through OBS?
So, it might be a little delayed sometimes.
But actually, so far, I think it's been pretty good.
Beep boop, boop boop, boop boop.
Boop boop, boop boop, boop boop, boop boop.
The plot elevator.
Yes!
This is my... one of my... this is like my favorite part of the game.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so excited.
Have you ever tried Acid 1 and 2?
I know... I know what kind of games they are.
But I have not played them.
Eww!
Come here, bird.
Actually, I'm not going to use...
Oh, just kidding.
Snake, I've got something to tell you about Naomi Hunter.
What's that?
Yeah, what is it?
What's up?
What is it?
I was in the FBI too, you know.
Oh, really?
Don't be rude.
Dr. Hunter's story about her background.
About her grandfather being an assistant secretary to Hoover in the FBI.
Uh-huh.
And then going undercover to investigate the mafia.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, what about it?
It was all a big lie.
What did you say?
It was really bothering me.
Why would she lie about it?
She lied?
She might be a spy.
Ridiculous.
I believed?
She lied?
Even a high school student could see past it.
Didn't Naomi say that her father was Japanese?
Uh-huh.
At the time when Edgar Hoover was head of the FBI, there wasn't a single Asian investigator.
Also, in the 50s, the undercover mafia sting operations hadn't even started yet.
Oh my god.
They started in 1960 in Chicago, not New York.
You better check it out.
The chief and the president mysteriously died.
That ninja.
Too many strange things are happening.
Her last name being Hunter?
Are you saying that Naomi might be behind it?
And Cyborg Ninja being Frank Yeager?
Could it be?
If I find out anything, I'll call.
In the meantime, be careful.
Thanks, Master Miller.
You're the only one who has my back.
Gosh, Master Miller, you're so cool.
You're really the only one that has my back.
He's asleep.
Wait, what if I get one in the sky?
Burn!
I'm sorry!
Oh, it's getting cold.
I'm chilly, I'm chilly.
I'm chilly, I'm chilly, I'm chilly.
Nice.
Okay.
Ah, let's save.
Oh, let's call people too.
Colonel, where's Naomi?
Me out.
Naomi, I have some questions for you.
Actually, not you.
Just kidding.
Snake, by now those terrorists...
I have questions for you, Colonel.
Stop wasting time.
I'm not wasting time.
Metal Gear's base is up ahead.
Snake, it's over 30 below outside.
Yeah?
What's wrong?
I don't want to talk to you.
Forget it.
Thanks.
Stop lollygagging around and get to Metal Gear's base.
Sorry.
There's no time.
Sorry, Colonel.
Oh my gosh.
Master Miller, I'm so worried about her.
I want to ask you about Naomi.
Yeah.
I'm looking into the details now.
But it doesn't look good.
I like how her mouth went, even though nothing came out.
Snake, keep your guard up.
You're the only one I can trust, Master Miller.
You're the only one I can trust.
Oh my gosh.
Very subtle, Snake.
What the hell are all these crows doing around here?
Crows?
You got me.
There were crows around from before.
But for some reason they started to increase in number about the same time that Foxhound came to the base.
It's really weird.
What it could mean.
I don't know.
I wonder.
If we do not drastically reduce the number of stockpiled nuclear weapons, it's going to become easier and easier for terrorists to get their hands on them.
Sorry, it's just really funny that everyone's talking about Naomi and she's like, we need to get rid of some of this stuff.
There was some talk about both sides reducing their nuclear stockpiles to a core deterrent force of less than 500 missiles each.
And declaring that there would be no nuclear counterstrike in the event of the use of conventional or chemical weapons.
But talks fell through.
It seems that America is unwilling to relinquish its position as the most powerful country in the world.
The pride.
Pride.
Then the...
Mei Ling, how's Naomi?
She's fine, I guess.
What's up?
If you want to talk to Naomi, why don't you call her?
Yeah.
I guess so.
Strange guy.
Shy guy, shy boy.
Strange boy.
Boys are weird.
U.S.A.
Good luck, Snake.
Thanks.
About to go fight another person.
Oh wow.
It's a good thing we walked through there.
We would've been crushed.
Like a little ant.
Okay.
What's that?
Oh
my god, they're eating her.
Then they're gonna eat me.
Oh my god.
Welcome, Cossack.
What'd you call me?
This is the end of the road for you.
Right, my friends?
Yeah.
Caw, caw, caw, caw, yeah.
They're becoming excited.
Me too.
Ravens aren't scavengers like most people think.
They're simply returning to the natural world, that which is no longer needed.
Sometimes, they even attack wounded foxes.
Well, I'm a snake.
You were the one in the M1 tank.
Must've been a tight fit for a big boy like you.
I love...
But that is no true battle.
Isn't he freezing?
No, he's a big boy.
I love that line so much.
The Ravens and I were testing to see what kind of man you were.
The judgment is decided.
The Ravens say you are a true warrior.
What?
Snake, you're hallucinating.
Yes, you are.
Snake?
I can't move.
What?
The Raven has put the mark of death upon you.
Blood from the East flows within your veins.
Ah,
your ancestors, too, were raised on the barren plains of Mongolia.
Psycho-Mintus.
Inuit and Japanese are cousins to each other.
We share many ancestors, you and I.
There's no crows in my family tree.
You ready?
I am not fond of snakes.
But you are family, so I cannot complain.
But there will be no holding back.
Japanese princess.
Snake's a Japanese princess.
Wow!
Reminds me of Nonomi from Blue Archive.
I need Vulcan Raven Nonomi art together.
You live in Alaska, too.
You know of the World Eskimo Indian Olympics.
Now we're talking about the Olympics?
With that strength, you must have been training in the stick pull and four-man carry.
Yes, you are right.
There is another event that I excelled at.
But actually, Snake's mom is Japanese.
It is called the ear pull.
Wow.
It's an event where two opponents pull each other's ears while enduring the harsh cold.
That sounds awful.
This is the worst thing ever.
It tests spiritual as well as physical strength.
You want to pull each other's ears?
The form is different.
But the spirit is the same.
Rejoice, Snake!
Ours will be a glorious battle.
I thought of Kotori for Nonomi because of her hair.
Oh, I see it!
It's just plain killing.
I never thought of it.
Well, we will see if there is iron in your words.
Yeah, I take supplements every day.
What is going on?
Oh, he's got that iron grip.
Oh!
What?
Oh my god!
Oh
my god!
Stop!
He did not just blow it up with...
No.
Oh my god.
He just threw a whole container at him.
And Snake stopped it once again by blowing it up with missiles.
Oh no, sorry.
The first time was a grenade.
Oh my god.
Blast radius doesn't exist.
Not for Solid Snake!
Oh my god.
That thing is huge!
Snake, how did...
Oh, but if I do it...
If I do it, I get blown up, you know?
But if there is cutscene buff, then it's fine.
Hey, get out of here, Crow!
You're gonna get shot at!
Oh!
Oh, he's yelling at him!
He's yelling at Snake!
Draw!
What is going on?
Okay.
I missed.
Okay, so there is a way to like kind of cheese this.
Where you can just shoot him in the back of the head constantly.
Oh, well I missed my chance.
Oh, hold on.
I unquit my gun, so I'm stupid.
Oh, I missed my chance.
Oh, hold on.
I unquit my gun, so I'm stupid.
Let's see.
You know what?
Maybe I won't.
Maybe I'll just do it with the Nikita.
You know what?
Maybe I won't.
Maybe I'll just do it with the Nikita.
Maybe I will just Nikita it.
Where is he though?
Oh, I think he is.
Pew!
Oh my god.
Ouch!
Oh no, no, no.
Ah!
You jerk.
You son of a gun.
You have a big gun.
Actually, I don't know where he is.
Actually...
Oh, he's over there.
Somewhere.
There he is.
Did that work?
Oh my god.
Wait.
Oh, he's coming.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Oh, he's coming.
I just used the stinger.
I guess that's fair.
But I think you blow it up, right?
Like there is a way to just like literally shoot him like this.
Oh, he's running.
He's so fast.
He's so furious.
Oh, he's really fast.
Hey buddy.
What are you...
You're wasting your bullets.
Pull his ear.
Pull his ear!
Let's try the...
We can try the stinger.
He's breathing heavy.
Oh my god.
Wait, there's...
It's...
It's like focusing in on all the crows too.
No way.
That's so funny.
Let's just stand right here.
And um...
Where
did he go?
Oh, there he is.
Uh oh.
He's gonna see me.
I'm gonna use this.
And then I'm gonna switch the body over.
Oh my god.
Why are you heavy breathing so much?
Stop!
You're scaring me!
I heard that this fight was so much easier...
Oh.
Oh my god.
It was so much easier in this one.
And I mean, all the fights pretty much are.
But...
I wanna try and do the cheese.
Wait.
Oh, maybe I can do it here.
Oh shoot.
Ah!
Hold on!
Oh my god.
Please.
As long as I don't die.
Oh my god.
Maybe I have to get him in the head.
Stop shooting me!
I take a couple hits.
You take a couple hits.
It works out this way.
I take a couple hits.
You take a couple hits.
I'm just a little tankier than him, you guys.
Body armor for the win.
For real.
Just as the boss said.
Beep beep beep.
It is my existence which is no longer needed in this world.
Oh, our body armor is on.
It's not very sexy.
But my body will not remain in this place.
The blood looks fake.
My spirit and my flesh will become one with the Ravens.
Maybe because like in the other...
With the other people, they were wearing clothes.
But with this, he's not.
It's just his skin, so it doesn't like...
Snake!
I will be watching you.
Understand?
Should have worn a shirt.
Snake, take this security card.
It will open that door.
Oh, it's so funny.
Honey, take the card to advance in the game.
Why?
You are a snake which was not created by nature.
You and the boss, you are from another world.
A world that I do not wish to know.
Go and do battle with him.
I will be watching from above.
First, I'll give you a hint.
The man you saw die before your eyes.
Yeah?
Oh, yeah.
The Diaper Chief.
That was not the Diaper Chief.
What?
Who was it?
It was Decoy Octopus.
No!
Oh, no!
We never got to fight Decoy Octopus!
No way.
He was a master of disguise.
Wait, did we get to see him?
He copied his subjects down to the blood.
Stop!
So he drained the Chief's blood and took it into himself.
We actually get to see Decoy Octopus?
But he wasn't able to deceive the Angel of Death.
I thought he was about to take off his pants.
The Angel of Death.
That's awesome.
We actually get to see him.
That's me.
I'm the Angel of Death.
But why go to so much trouble?
Why impersonate the Chief?
That is the end of my hint.
You must solve the rest of the riddle yourself.
Yeah.
What questions was he asking me?
He was asking a lot of questions to me, you know, when I met him.
Voldemort, stop.
How would the fight be with Decoy since he only knows how to disguise himself?
He could disguise himself as the wall.
It's like hide and seek, you know?
You have to go find him.
They're eating him!
Oh god.
Oh, it's really nasty.
Oh, gross.
In the natural world, there is no such thing as boundless slaughter.
There is always an end to it.
But you are different.
What are you trying to say?
The path you walk on has no end.
No matter how far you go, or how many corpses you crawl over.
The killing will never end.
It's a future without hope.
I hate how...
Oh.
Laughing octopus.
My spirit will be watching you.
Wow.
It was... it was like a balloon.
There's nothing to him.
It's really, uh, sad how... kind of true that ends up being.
Poor Snake.
Snake has had a hard life.
No bones.
Yeah, Raven wasn't wrong, unfortunately.
The music.
Oh!
Colonel!
Is Naomi there?
No, she's away.
She's taking a short nap.
Oh, I wish I could take a short nap on the job.
So what is this about Naomi?
Okay.
Maybe we'd better let the Colonel hear this, too.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
Go on, Master.
Well, basically, Dr. Naomi Hunter... is not Dr. Naomi Hunter at all.
What?
I thought her story of her background sounded kind of fishy.
Yeah.
I believe you.
So I checked it out.
And?
There is an actual Dr. Naomi Hunter.
Or I should say, there was one.
Skinwalker.
She took her body.
She's not the woman we know.
The real Naomi Hunter disappeared somewhere in the Middle East.
She buried her in the sand.
Now Naomi must have somehow obtained her identification papers.
Oh, my gosh.
So then who is she really?
She must be some kind of spy.
Spy?
A spy.
Among us?
Yes.
Maybe she's been sent to sabotage this operation.
Are you saying she's with the terrorists?
Oh, my God.
I don't want to believe it either.
But she is working for Foxhound.
So you think she had a part in the uprising?
Or she could be working with some different group altogether.
Sand curse.
How do you know I have a sand curse?
A different group.
It couldn't be.
Place her under arrest, Colonel.
Yeah.
What?
She's betrayed us, Colonel.
Yeah.
She needs to be arrested and interrogated to find out who she's with.
If she's one of their spies, then we're in big trouble.
What do you mean?
What have you told her, Colonel?
Nothing.
Colonel, have you let her in on some kind of vital secret or something?
Uh-oh.
Does this have anything to do with the mysterious deaths of the DARPA chief and the arms tech president?
I have no idea.
Colonel, that is the least convincing answer I've ever heard in my life.
We cannot allow her to participate any further in this mission.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Without her, we can't complete this mission.
I knew it.
You're hiding something.
Thank you.
Give me some time.
Have a good rest of your night, Alan.
Thank you.
Hurry, then.
We've got to figure out who she is and what she's doing here.
I understand.
Snake, give me some time.
I don't have any time left for you.
Yeah, you tell him, Snake.
You tell him.
Oh, my gosh.
Master Miller.
What's that sound?
Are you ready?
I got his dog tags.
Vulcan Raven.
Wait.
Oh, could I have gotten Psycho Mantis' too, I wonder?
Oh, no.
That's a shame.
I didn't get it because I didn't know.
It's so chilly in here.
Let's put the body armor back on.
I don't see anything else, maybe.
I think maybe we're okay.
Have you ever listened to all the Snake Kodak calls from Smash Bros.?
If not, it would be a very fun watch.
I have seen...
A good amount of them.
I don't remember if I watched like a compilation of all of them or if I finished that compilation if I watched one.
But I have seen some.
Yes.
Miller is the only honest guy in this game.
Truly.
I remember you.
I...
You.
Check...
Check your rations.
Yeah, I do need that, don't I?
Wait a second.
Is that a person and not...
Wait.
Is there a person here?
I think I saw it turn around.
This room never...
I think there's an actual person in here.
Oh my god, there is.
Oh my god.
You scared me.
There's a person in here.
I got it.
Now, I also know that no one is in here.
Oh, oh.
Oh my god.
Yes.
Ah.
Where are you going?
It's him.
Robin!
Give me some backup!
Robin, no!
Oh my god.
Oh, shoot.
I thought the cameras were the only issue here.
And suddenly they're adding people?
Oh my god.
I'm also trying to shoot.
Please.
Oh.
Hi.
Ouch.
Oh my god, please.
Snake.
There we go.
Anyway.
You trapped his call.
Oh, that's why he ran into there.
Zoom.
Wait, where's the zoom?
My
god.
What a little baby.
Baby Rex.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Part of my Metal Gear order that I did the other day.
I got a...
A Paper Craft Rex.
Zoom.
There's no zoom.
I wanna cry right now.
What is that?
Oh.
I was like, what is that?
I think I know who that is actually.
That's so funny.
I can see the camera from here, though.
Zoom.
I'll just do it myself, then.
Lame ass.
Sound track.
Worst part of the game is the soundtrack, truly.
Wait, is there someone actually down there?
Oh no, he's above me.
Oh.
Thank you, thank you.
Zom... thank you for the zom...
Zombeenies.
Zom...
Oh, hello?
Supplicatory Metal Gear?
I had no idea you like Metal Gear.
I love Metal Gear!
Oh, I got stuff to do.
I'll catch you on the rerun.
Love ya!
Thanks, AP!
Good luck with your stuff!
The music in this version seems very subdued.
Yeah, it is very absent, yeah.
There's nobody here.
No guards.
No mechanics.
It's too quiet.
There's some guards.
They said they even input the PAL codes.
What should I do?
Oh my god, no.
All we can do is use the override system that President Baker told you about.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we gotta override, we gotta override.
But I've only got one of the three keys.
And besides that, like Ocelot said, there's some trick to using the keys.
Leave it to me.
There's also actually an easier way here, too.
Well?
I'm in the computer room right now.
I'm trying to access Baker's private files.
Okay.
Baker's files?
Don't you need a password?
Of course.
But there are ways.
Are you a hacker?
Yep.
That describes me pretty well.
Are you a hacker?
I don't know yet.
I'll give it a try.
Hacking to the gate.
Na na na na na na na na na na na na.
Where are the guards, you said?
There's guards literally right above me.
I think.
Wait.
Where are they?
Huh?
Actually, where is the guard?
I heard someone walking, though.
Are they one above?
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Is there somebody there?
Oh.
Ah!
Oh, my God.
Oh, gosh.
I didn't see your stupid ass.
Oh, my God.
Snake, it's me again.
No guards at all.
Yeah.
It's so weird.
There was never guards in this part before.
I just got past his third security level.
He was a pretty careful guy.
Do you think you'll break in soon?
I've never met a system I couldn't bust into.
I couldn't even see where he was going.
Where is he coming from?
Man.
Man, this...
Oh.
Uh.
We're both loading at the same time.
But I'm faster.
Oh, my God.
No.
No, he's not.
Where's your stupid shield?
Where's my shield?
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Now, I can run and hide.
Where's my box?
Snow box.
I saw people running up.
But they're gonna see me, aren't they?
Aren't they gonna see me?
They're gonna see me, aren't they?
They're gonna see me.
Do you think I can walk?
Okay.
Oh.
It was a dead end.
I could've just...
I should've just stayed here.
Okay.
We'll just wait until the caution's over.
Can I see them in this room?
I don't see them.
They're just like... probably being like, What's going on down there?
Nothing much.
Don't worry about it.
Why would you need to worry about it?
You know?
Middle of a hallway.
I didn't know where this lead to.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Oh, wait, hold on.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh my god, what?!
I tried to...
What?!
No, I shot your thing!
I shot your thing!
This is so unfair.
It's so unfair.
I shot the radio!
No sign of the AWOL man.
No, no, please.
No, god, no!
I shot... I shot your radio.
I shot your radio.
Wait, where's my body armor?
Oh, there it is.
I always pass it, like a bajillion times.
I can't believe I got scammed, for real.
Oh, thanks!
How am I supposed to get out of this, though?
How am I supposed... They're just gonna all keep coming.
They're all just gonna keep running up here and over here.
Doshio.
Gonna
run out of rations.
I feel like...
I should just...
Just gonna have to blast on my way...
Blast my way through them, I think.
My grip is not good enough, I think, for hanging over the railing.
I think my grip is too... too small.
That's okay.
But...
What's that?
Just as I thought.
The nuclear warhead is designed to be fired from the railgun like a projectile.
It doesn't use fuel, so it isn't considered a missile.
That way it can get around all sorts of international treaties.
Oh my god.
Pretty sneaky.
Sneaky.
Yes, but effective.
And that's not even the scariest thing about this weapon.
I can't wait to hear this.
It's a stealth weapon.
So scary.
It won't show up on radar.
Yeah.
The truth is...
They've been working on a stealth missile since the late 70s.
Why weren't they able to develop one up until now?
Because of the missile's rocket propulsion system.
It would be picked up by enemy satellites.
Because of that?
But unlike a missile, the railgun doesn't burn any propellant.
So it can't be detected by any current ballistic missile detection systems.
Insanity.
An invisible nuclear warhead.
So scary.
Totally impossible to intercept.
Oh my god.
And on top of that, it's got a surface-piercing weapon.
A warhead designed to penetrate hardened underground bases.
We learned that less than the Gulf War.
This thing could mean the end of the world.
It's the ultimate weapon.
And from a political point of view, it avoids the problem of nuclear reduction and nuclear inspections.
Colonel, is this true?
Are you listening?
I'm listening.
It would push back the signing of the START III treaty.
If word gets out about this weapon, it'd cause a whole world of trouble.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It would be nasty.
The United States would be denounced by the UN.
It could even bring the President down.
Oh my god.
Did you know this, Colonel?
Not the President.
I'm sorry.
You've changed, Colonel.
God, I'm so disappointed.
I won't make any excuses.
I'm disappointed in you, Colonel.
Listen to me.
This new nuclear weapon, it's never actually been tested.
Only simulated.
You mean with VR experiments?
Yeah.
That's why they were conducting this exercise.
Man, they love VR.
They needed to get actual experimental data to back up the simulation.
VR is the future.
What were the results of the exercise?
It looks like it went better than they hoped for.
But I can't find the data anywhere on this network.
You'd think the data as important as that would be carefully recorded.
Cal built the mech?
It was.
Didn't build the railgun?
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
The President gave me an optical disc with all of the test data.
What?
Do you still have it?
No.
Ocelot took it from me.
Damn.
The terrorists have replaced the dummy warhead with a weapon.
A real warhead.
Oh my god.
Once they input the detonation codes, they should be ready to launch.
So, you think they can do it?
Well, the dummy warhead was designed to be identical to the real thing.
So, I think so.
Did you find out how to override it yet?
Not yet.
It must be in a separate file.
Right now, I'm looking through all of Baker's personal files.
We're counting on you.
We're count...
Oh, shoot.
Uh, shoot.
For real.
Oh, hello?
Oh, it's empty!
Oh, no.
Anyway.
Uh...
Snake.
Yeah?
Did you find it?
No.
That was fast.
Oh.
I haven't found out about the override system yet.
But I found Baker's ulterior motive.
He's just looking to get rich, isn't he?
That's part of it.
Arms tech is in much worse financial trouble than I thought.
I know they lost their bid to make the next generation fighter jet.
That, plus the reduction in SDI spending.
It looks like they were working on it.
There was even some talk of a hostile takeover.
Oh.
Everything was riding on this project, I guess.
And it looks like they were paying a lot of bribe money to the DARPA chief.
That guy.
Bride money, huh?
Yeah.
He's the worst.
And Baker was a big proponent of the nuclear deterrent theory.
The DARPA chief is the worst!
So anyway, what about the override?
Just give me a little bit longer.
Oogie.
Are there people?
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Ah!
Time to go!
Cuss in!
Oh, no!
Cutscene time!
Oh!
Yes!
Go, Snake!
I've entered the PAL codes and disengaged the safety device.
We can launch any time.
There's still no response from Washington.
It looks like we'll have to show them that we mean business.
Yeah.
Oh.
Dummy.
Should I set it for 10 seconds?
Oh.
No.
There's been a change.
Oh?
The new target is Lopnor, China.
Why, boss?
Oh!
Oh, he's so beautiful.
Liquid... liquid.
I'm sure neither you nor Mr. Golukhovich would really like to see a nuclear bomb dropped on your motherland, right?
Mr. Golukhovich.
... but why?
There's nothing there.
Wrong.
It's a nuclear bomb.
A nuclear test site.
If we nuke a major population center, the game's over.
But a nuclear explosion at a test site can still be concealed from the public.
Meanwhile, Washington will be worried about the retaliatory strike from China.
That'll probably mean top-secret talks between both countries' leaders.
Top secret.
Of course.
And in the process, the president will be forced to divulge the existence of a new and highly destabilizing nuclear weapon to the Chinese.
What do you think that will do to the U.S.'s reputation?
Or the president's?
Oh my god.
And with the CTBT, that means that China and India...
I think you missed a letter there.
Wait.
Ocelot, what?
The C...
Yes.
When the other countries hear about the new weapon, they'll all want to contact us.
Washington won't be very happy when we start selling their own system to the highest bidders.
Yes.
The president will break.
He will give in to our demands.
Big Boss's DNA and one billion dollars.
One billion dollars!
All for money?
No.
That money will be used to cure our genome soldiers as well.
Ocelot doesn't care about the money?
I'm also including the fox dye vaccine in our demands.
Fox dye.
It killed Octopus and the arms tech president.
Fox... dye.
So it's true that it affects older people first.
Mantis might not have been affected because he wore a mask.
Wolf wasn't infected either.
Perhaps due to those tranquilizers she always took.
Hmm...
Something to do with amphetamine and adrenaline levels in the blood.
They deployed a product still in development into live combat.
No surprise it was unreliable.
Ridiculous.
They must have been desperate.
Desperate.
In any case, have you heard from your friend Colonel Sergei Golukovich at Spetsnaz yet?
He still has doubts about the ability of Metal Gear.
It's so funny when they're just like, By the way, this person's full name and where they're at.
Do you...
You know, I gotta give you some context.
He's a very prudent man.
There's nothing to worry about.
The Colonel wants Metal Gear and the new nuclear weapon so bad he can taste it.
Will the Pazaza Beam save me from Fox dye?
Oh, maybe.
Russia wants to regain its position as a military superpower.
They need to reinforce their nuclear arsenal.
They need a nuclear weapon that can't be intercepted.
Wow.
Metal Gear will allow them to gain power.
And first strike capability over the rest of the world.
Oh my god.
Their regular army is in shambles.
In shambles.
And they think they can restore their country's military power with nuclear weapons?
That Golukovich, he's no warrior.
He's a politician.
Maybe so.
He's the one who gave us the Hind and most of our other heavy firepower.
Dang it, Golukovich.
He's got over a thousand soldiers under his command.
Wait, what just happened?
He joined forces.
Did I just accidentally zoom in?
You could put up quite a resistance here.
Sorry, I almost dropped my controller.
Since Mantis died, the genome soldier's brainwashing has started to wear off.
Can you zoom in and cut scenes?
I'm worried about the man's morale.
An alliance with the Russians would boost that as well.
What are you saying?
Oh my god.
We're not going anywhere.
We're going to dig in here.
What?
It's going to be a long war.
We could still escape.
We have the new nuclear power and we're going to ally with Golukovich's forces.
Are you going to fight the whole world?
What's wrong with that?
Fighting the whole world?
But I can't move around.
I can only just zoom.
We can launch a nuclear warhead at any target on this planet.
A nuclear warhead invisible to radar and totally immune to interception.
I can't move it though.
And on top of that, this base is full of...
Oh, I can with the other one.
Once we get the DNA and the money, the world will be ours.
But boss, what about your promise to Colonel Golukovich?
I have no interest in the revival of Mother Russia.
You're not thinking of reviving Big Boss's dream.
From today, you can call this place...
Don't say it.
Outer Heaven.
No!
Big Boss's dream.
Outer Heaven?
Boss, you're not worried about the POW being overridden?
If the code is entered again, it will be deactivated.
That was the most convincing delivery ever.
The DARPA chief and the arms tech president are both dead.
Does Snake know how the override system works?
Boss, he doesn't know how to over...
Oh my god, his neck.
Good.
Then no one can stop Metal Gear now.
Oh my god.
Boss, he doesn't know how to put in the detonate or the...
What should we do with that woman?
Want me to kill her?
Let her live.
She's Campbell's niece and Snake cares for her.
We'll keep her as our ace in the hole.
Meryl, she's alive.
Meryl.
Moshi moshi.
Snake, I found Baker's top secret files.
Great job.
How's it going there?
They finished inputting the POW codes.
Oh my god.
So, how do we deactivate them?
Okay, you see, the override system that the president was talking about...
Did he figure out how to deactivate the POW codes?
It can also be used to input the detonation codes.
You see, if you insert the keys when the warhead is active...
Boss, did he figure it out?
You deactivate it.
And if you insert them when it's inactive, it becomes activated.
And you can only use the keys once.
Only once, huh?
You need the keys for input.
Three of them.
But I only have one.
Where are the others?
Hold on a minute.
You see, that's the trick.
You already have all three keys.
What are you talking about?
The card key is made of a shape memory alloy.
Shape memory alloy?
Yes.
It's a material that changes shape at different temperatures.
The key is made out of it.
This card key?
Yeah.
The card key changes shape at different temperatures.
So this key is actually three keys in one.
Clever.
So clever.
So, so clever.
Can you see the input terminals in the center of the control room?
I do.
They're very obviously laid out.
Yes.
I see them.
I think I need a... okay.
Those three laptop terminals are for the emergency input.
If you're gonna whip out your binoculars, at least zoom in.
Okay, thank you.
There should be a symbol on each screen.
Each symbol corresponds to a different key.
You input the keys in order from left to right.
The left ones for the room temperature key.
See the symbol?
Yes.
Next to that goes the low temperature key.
Ah.
The one on the right is the high temperature key.
Okay.
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
First I change the shape of the card, and then I input them in order, right?
That's right.
All you do is insert the card keys.
After you insert the key into the module, a hard disk...
They're just standing there.
They're not even talking.
Once you've finished with all three terminals, the code input process is complete.
But here's the thing.
You can only use the key three times.
It's an emergency system, and it's only meant to be used once.
In awkward gatherings, I employ solid snake conversation.
The world is riding on that key, snake.
I just say what they said, but ask it in a question.
Smar.
Who's that?
Oh my god!
Snake!
Oh, oh, oh.
He's looking at the bullet.
Oh no, I forgot about this part.
Our card key!
Oh, so clumsy.
The key fell in the drainage ditch.
Ouch!
This is bulletproof glass.
There's no way in.
Kyle and Joy watching you die.
This is bulletproof glass.
Snake.
You've got to get that key.
This is bulletproof glass.
Okay, I'll go get it.
So...
The people I'm seeing walking is them, right?
Like...
Oh.
Wait.
Yeah, it's them inside.
That's so funny.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's go get us...
Let's go get us a card key.
I could use some more bullets, especially since I ran out.
Where are my famas?
25...
Oh.
Oh my god.
No way.
Who's there?
Where were you?
Where?
Where were you the whole time?
Where were you?
Wait, actually...
Let's see.
Let's...
Maybe we can...
Oh, but if I...
I don't know.
If I put him down...
If I make him sleepy...
Where is your status report?
It's fine.
Maybe it's fine.
Excuse me.
Um...
Are there any other guys?
They're not showing up if there are.
Wait.
Can I go down here?
What's down here?
Uh...
Okay.
There's a lot of...
Wait.
I don't...
This is...
This is not used to be here, right?
Right?
This is...
This is new, right?
Bandage.
Okay.
I feel like I hear someone else walking around.
I don't think it's me.
But I don't see anyone else on the radar, so it's just...
This is completely different.
Okay.
Sorry.
I'm gonna shoot your bow.
But...
Okay.
All right.
Uh...
Wait.
I came this way.
Okay.
Now I...
At least I know where they're at.
Before, I think what the trouble was, was I was like seeing them on the radar, but there's so many tiny little stairs areas in here that I'm like...
I didn't know where they were walking at, you know?
But now, we at least know where...
Wait.
How do I...
How do I get down?
Um...
I'm lost.
Wait.
Uh...
Here.
Let's grab this.
Nope.
Just kidding.
Okay.
I'm hearing something.
What the heck am I hearing?
Look at them.
They're in there talking with each other.
Okay.
Nice.
If I put on the body armor, does it help?
Ta-da.
How do I find this thing?
Oh.
We got more bullets?
We got a...
A time bomb?
Wait a second.
Ocelot!
Where is that?
Where's the time bomb?
Oh.
Wow.
Gosh.
Uh.
Please, Snake.
Hmm.
Oh.
Maybe it's down here.
Ration.
Nice.
Take it.
Rex's bath water.
If you drink this, you will literally get super power.
I hope these guys aren't awake.
Okay.
Palky!
There we go.
Very nice.
Gotta go all the way back.
You will be...
You will...
You will become the world's most powerful soldier if you drink this water.
Any VTuber fan will be honored.
Hopefully these guys are still...
Just take you there.
Yeah.
Give you a little extra.
And this guy too.
Yeah.
Oh, you only got two.
There you go.
Now you got three.
Okay.
They do come back here, right?
Yeah.
Right?
Then I go inside.
Oh, they're gone.
Where could they have gone?
Very good.
Hmm.
Nicely.
Do I just...
Okay.
So this one...
First our little Palky.
Insert!
Call Otakon now that you found the key?
Okay.
Oh yeah.
I should be calling people.
Snake, we input the PAL codes.
Colonel, I'm scared.
What if it doesn't work?
I'll get you.
What if you're... What if you're tricking me?
Yes, of course, Master.
He's the only one I can trust, so it's fine.
Yes.
Ooh.
It's been changed to the correct shape.
It won't be recognized by the PAL code input terminal in the control room, and the detonation code won't be entered.
So...
I could just...
What if I... What if I mess it up a little?
What if I just...
Oh, wait.
It's not activated.
Oh, I mean, sorry.
We're deactivating it.
But I think I mentioned this earlier, but there's actually an easier way to do some of these...
Like...
I think...
I think it's...
Well...
You, like, have to shoot a pipe, and it will allow you to do the hot and the cold, not having to go all the way back.
So...
We'll see.
Anyway.
Beep, beep!
Yeah, there's a land with a hot and a cold pipe.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
So, I'm... I don't know.
I might do it the quick way, because I think it's kind of cool that it's unique to this game.
Alright!
Rex, you're not getting activated today!
And...
Oh!
Gas attacked!
Nice.
Oh.
Wait.
Do I get gas attacked when I complete them?
Let's go.
Oh, I forgot.
Oh, he's still down.
Let's go.
Now, I...
OK.
Now, the issue is...
I don't actually know where these pipes are.
I think...
Ah!
Look at them.
Slumbering baby.
I think they're over on...
this side.
I missed the zoom.
Me too.
This music is kinda creepy.
But it's just... it's not the vibe, you know?
I don't know exactly where these are.
Top floor, right side, hang drop, catch, down.
Like here?
Wait, hang drop from where?
Oh gosh, I have to catch going down?
Oof.
We might have a problem.
Wait.
Hold on.
Can I see it?
Where I need to drop?
I love that I just walk all over their bodies.
Let's see.
Is there one that...
Maybe.
Or just take the stairs.
I'm looking to see... like this!
There it is!
Okay.
Okay, so I... right?
Okay, so you can't access it.
That's what I was just checking.
So you have to hang from here.
Okay.
Wait.
So...
To drop, down, catch...
I don't know the controls.
I don't know the controls actually.
Hmm...
Okay, hold on.
Shoot.
It's action...
And...
Uh...
Drop...
Nope.
Uh...
Wait, I don't know the controls.
I did it!
First try, baby!
First try!
Nice!
Nice, nice, nice!
Okay.
Alrighty.
Uh...
Liquid nitrogen.
Ouch!
Did that actually hurt me?
Nice.
Oh!
It's already cold!
That was so fast.
Alrighty.
Um...
Al...
Ali...
Oop!
Where's this gonna drop me?
Oh, whoops.
Uh...
And...
Drop.
Oop.
My bad.
We're fine.
Come on, snake.
Shake it off.
It's actually...
Okay!
That's so cool!
Oh my gosh.
How nice.
I'm just gonna keep shooting these guys every time I go past them.
No use in having them wake up.
I mean, honestly, I could just kill them.
Then they...
Then they'd never be a bother.
Ne...
They would never wake up.
Yeah.
Is that just for twin snakes?
Yes, it is just for twin snakes.
So...
Um...
You will not find that.
Because you can't hang in, um...
In, uh...
Regular Metal Gear Solid.
Number two!
You've killed so many, why hold back on these two?
That's true.
They did give me a really hard time.
They did.
I am still annoyed at the fact...
At the fact that they...
I'm still annoyed at the fact that they...
Gave me a hard time because I didn't know where they were.
Yeah.
Pal code number two confirmed.
Yahoo!
Awaiting pal code number three.
Mint, this saves you like 15 minutes.
I know!
Okay.
Here goes pal code number two.
It's kind of awesome.
Next comes pal number three.
Warm the key.
Which is so funny because like...
I was so...
Maybe...
Maybe I feel like I'm more okay with doing this because...
I was so adamant about the, um...
About the...
Sniper...
About the PSG-1 that like...
And it took so long for me to get it.
That I'm like, you know what?
We can save a couple.
We can save some minutes because I...
Um...
I messed up.
I was so bad at the beginning.
But it's also funny because I'm trying to like...
I'm not trying to remain like faithful to the original.
It's just that I feel like the cutscenes work better when you don't use like...
A tranquilizer.
Like...
Everybody...
Everybody in this game dies.
It's not...
It's not a happy ending.
Okay.
Shoot.
What was it?
Okay.
Uh...
You...
Nice!
Hey, yo!
Ouch!
Oh...
Uh...
Falky...
And it's hot, baby!
Oh!
It's on fire!
It's...
It's hot!
They die in MGS3 too?
Uh...
They die from explosion.
So it doesn't matter...
It doesn't matter what I do.
Reek!
Thank you!
Hati has her own route and occupants...
I have...
Also the Metal Gear...
Solid...
Oh, hold on.
I'll read it.
Reach in a second.
I didn't want the Colonel to hear.
Okay, so what's up?
I've got a good friend in the Pentagon.
Yeah.
Yeah?
He's the one who told me about it.
It looks like the DIA recently developed a new type of assassination weapon.
An assassination weapon?
Snake.
Have you ever heard of something called Foxdye?
No.
That's what they mentioned earlier.
Foxdye?
Foxdye.
Yeah.
Liquid and the others were talking about it.
Yeah, the others.
The one other.
It's some kind of virus that targets specific people.
Ocelot?
I don't know all the details, but...
What are you trying to say?
Oh, yeah.
What are you trying...
It's too similar.
What is?
The cause of death.
Didn't the arms tech president and the DARPA chief, I mean, Decoy Octopus, die of something that looked like a heart attack?
Yeah.
Well, apparently, Foxdye kills its victims by simulating a heart attack.
No!
No.
You're right.
Is he telling me that Naomi was behind it?
Snake, try to remember.
Did Naomi give you some kind of injection?
The nanomachines.
She was in the best position to have done it, but I don't know what her motive was.
Oh my God.
Does the Colonel know?
I'm not sure, but he still hasn't questioned it.
Jedi.
Okay.
Foxdye.
Jedi.
Colonel, what's new with the Naomi situation?
I just placed Naomi under arrest.
She's arrested.
Yeah!
Arrested.
Take her butt to jail.
She was sending coded mails.
Oh my god.
She's working with them.
Yeah.
That's the true stuff, right?
Fox alive.
I can.
Is that all you think about?
But Snake, you might be infected too, you know.
Uh oh.
All I can do is leave it up to the Colonel.
I mean...
Uh...
I don't know, I mean...
I think it's pretty important to think about.
That's the last one.
Hurry to the control room.
I'm on my way!
Faster, faster!
I'm doing it!
So, Naomi is a spy.
Just like I thought.
Campbell is hiding something too.
He is.
But that's okay.
Foxdye is a virus, a biological weapon.
There must be a vaccine.
We can worry about getting that later, Snake.
But right now, you've got to focus on re-inputting those detonation codes, okay?
Yeah, there's gotta be a...
There's gotta be a... a vaccine.
Important to note, this was originally an elevator scene for backtracking.
But because of skipping in Twin Snakes, they put it here.
Oh, yeah!
Yes, yes!
I love going in the elevator and getting all the exposition and everything.
It's so fun.
Hey, Otacon.
You don't even know her, Otacon.
You don't know her!
You've got to concentrate on re-inputting that detonation code.
Yeah.
You're right.
We've got to stop Metal Gear Rex from launching.
For sure.
What is it, Snake?
Good luck, Snake.
Thank you!
Sorry, I didn't mean to...
You know what?
We don't need to save.
We're fine.
All right.
Let's go.
Let's go stop...
Oh, okay.
Good.
I was like, wait a second.
It's purple!
But no.
It's red.
We're good.
Let's go stop Metal Gear...
from launching.
Let's go.
Oh, hello?
Snake, can you hear me?
It's Naomi.
How'd you get this number?
Naomi?
What the hell?
Gamble and the others are busy right now.
I'm on a different codec.
Naomi is what the Colonel says true.
Yes, but not everything I said was a lie.
Who are you?
I don't know anything.
My parents' face is my name.
The name and ID I have now I just bought.
But the reason why I study genetics, that was true.
Because you want to know yourself, right?
I want to know myself.
That's right.
I want to know where I came from.
My age, my race, anything.
Naomi.
I was found in Rhodesia sometime in the 80s.
A dirty little orphan.
Rhodesia?
What's now known as Zimbabwe?
Yes.
But you were born in Rhodesia?
You were found by who?
There were lots of Indian laborers around.
That's probably where I got my skin color from.
But I'm not even sure about that.
Naomi, you're too worried about the past.
Yeah.
Isn't it enough to understand who you are now?
Understand who I am now?
Why should I?
No one else tries to understand me.
I was alone for so long.
Until I met my big brother.
And him.
Him?
Your big brother?
Yes.
Frank Yeager.
What?
He was...
He was a young soldier.
When he picked me up near the Zimbabwe River.
Yeager.
What is this music?
I was half dead from starvation.
Yeager meets a hunter.
Oh my god.
Yes.
Revelation.
Frank Yeager.
The man who you destroyed was my brother and my only family.
No.
Gray Fox.
We survived that hell together, Frank and I.
He protected us.
He protected me.
He is everything to me.
Oh my god.
The only proof I have of my existence.
Of my existence as an individual.
And he brought you back to America?
No.
I was in Mozambique when he came.
He.
Who's he?
No Save Endurance MGS Game Challenge.
Big Boss.
Yes.
Maybe.
He brought us to this land of freedom.
This America.
Big Boss.
But then he and my brother went back to continue the war.
And that's when it happened.
When we killed him.
You killed my benefactor.
And sent my brother home a cripple.
I vowed revenge and joined Foxhound.
Oh my god.
I knew it was my best chance to meet you.
And I prayed for the day that I would.
So, were your prayers answered?
Yeah.
How do you feel now, huh?
Yes.
I waited two long years.
To kill me?
Is that all you cared about?
I mean, two years is long, but it's a long time.
I'm a little bit worried.
But it's like not that long.
Two years.
You were all I thought about for two long years.
Rent free.
For real for real.
I sent them twisted obsession.
Do you still hate me?
Not exactly.
Did they re-dub Naomi's lines?
They re-dubbed everybody's lines.
I was probably wrong about you.
What about Liquid and the others?
I'll have my revenge on them, too.
Yeah.
Naomi.
You didn't kill that doctor, too, did you?
The one that used Gray Fox for his genome experiments.
Dr. Clark?
Yeah, but they got rid of Naomi's lines.
Naomi's accent.
That was my brother.
Afterward, I covered it up and helped him hide out.
Now he's obsessed with me, Naomi.
So that ninja, I mean Gray Fox.
That ninja.
He's come here to kill me.
I don't think so.
I think he just came here to find you.
He loves you.
He loves you, Snake.
I wasn't sure before, but now I think I understand.
A final battle with you.
That's all he lives for.
Soldiers are so weird.
Fox.
They're all just like, I need to have, I need to have, I need to have, I need to have, I need to fight one more time.
Tell me something.
About FOXDIE.
FOXDIE is a type of retrovirus that targets and kills only specific people.
Yeah.
First, it infects the macrophages in the victim's body.
What's that?
FOXDIE contains smart enzymes created through protein engineering.
Ooh.
They're programmed to respond to specific genetic patterns in cells.
I don't...
I mean, I know that the...
Those enzymes recognize the target's DNA.
Right.
Original recordings were bad.
They respond by becoming cells.
But I don't think they stand up for themselves.
They have soul.
Thank you.
It's a type of cytokine.
Do you know Jaeger means hunter?
Psst.
No, it doesn't.
That's a spoiler.
The TNF epsilon is carried along the bloodstream to the heart, where they attach to the TNF receptors in the heart cells.
I can fix him.
And then, they cause a heart attack.
Yeah.
The heart cells suffer a shock and undergo an extreme epitosis.
A-apoptosis.
Then, the victim dies.
Scary.
A-apoptosis.
Naomi.
You must have programmed that thing to kill me too, right?
You did.
Naomi!
I don't blame you for wanting me dead.
Answer!
I can't go yet.
I still have a job to do.
Why can't you ever give us a clear answer, Naomi?
I'm not the one who made the decision to use Foxdye.
Huh?
You weren't?
No.
I'm not.
You were injected with Foxdye as a part of this operation.
I just wanted to let you know that- No.
That's not the whole truth.
Huh?
The real thing I wanted to- Why are you such a pathological liar?
Snake.
Hey!
What are you doing?
No!
Live, Snake.
You must live.
Naomi?
Snake.
I can't allow Naomi to make any more unauthorized transmission of the virus.
No!
What?
Naomi's been removed from this operation.
What happened to Naomi?
What did she mean when she said that Foxdye was a part of this operation?
Colonel, let me talk to her.
I won't.
She's under arrest.
Twist after twist after twist!
Colonel!
You double-crossed me.
Snake, there's no time for that.
Colonel!
Right now, your job is to stop Metal Gear.
You'll die when you die, Naomi.
That's her, alright.
Oh my gosh.
What do you mean there's no time?
When I've been injected with a poison, essentially.
Oh my gosh.
The camera angles sometimes get me a little motion sick.
Naomi yapped a little too much.
Here we go.
Final PAL key.
Nice and steamy.
Insert we go.
Yeah, there's no time to talk about my double-crossing.
Yeah, he's just like, just get your job done before you die.
Which is also so sad.
Snake just being like, I have one friend.
It's the Colonel.
It's like...
Snake, you're just a tool to everybody.
You know, if you rearrange Rat Patrol...
What's that mean?
Oh, here we go.
Here it is.
What?
Oh!
Oh my god!
No!
Why?
Welcome
to Membo Ship!
Thank you!
I deactivated.
Oh, here it is.
Who's calling?
Master?
Please!
Thank you, Snake.
Now the detonation code is completed.
Master Miller!
Nothing can stop Metal Gear now.
No!
Master, what's going on?
Master, please.
You're the one who's calling.
You found the key and even activated the warhead for us, too.
I really must express my gratitude.
No.
Sorry to have involved you in that silly shape memory alloy business.
What are you talking about?
We weren't able to learn the DARPA chief's code.
Even with Manta's psychic powers, he couldn't read his mind.
Then Ocelot accidentally killed him during the interrogation.
No!
In other words, we weren't able to launch the nuclear device...
...and we were all getting a little worried.
Without the threat of a nuclear strike...
We were getting a little worried.
...our demands would never be met.
Gotta launch that nuke.
Without the detonation codes...
He played us like a fiddle.
...we had to find some other way.
That's when I decided you might prove useful, Snake.
Oh, my God.
We were just a pawn in everyone's game.
Well, for starters, I had Decoy Octopus disguise himself as the DARPA chief.
Oh, my God.
We thought we'd get the info from you, but there was FOXDIE.
Yeah.
You mean you had this plan from the beginning?
Just to get me to input the detonation code?
Huh.
You didn't think you made it this far by yourself, did you?
Are you telling me he didn't actually regrow that arm?
In any case, the launch preparations are complete.
Once the world glimpses the power of this weapon...
Master, I trusted you!
...the White House will have no choice but to surrender the FOXDIE vaccine to me.
I trusted you, Master.
Their ace in the hole is useless now.
Doshite Miller-senpai.
Ace in the hole.
The Pentagon's plan to use you was already successful.
Doshite.
Ha ha ha.
Snake, you're the only one...
Master baited you.
I can't believe he did that.
Who are you anyway?
I'll tell you everything you want to know.
Wait.
If you come to where I am, that is.
Is there the little jump scare of...
Where are you?
Very close by.
Snake, that's not Master Miller.
What?
Campbell, you're too late.
Master Miller's body was just discovered by...
Say, psych!
Right now!
Master Muller!
Oh my god.
Why didn't you check this sooner?
Brother!
Yeah!
This is how everyone betrays snakes in these games.
Glad I never did.
Dramatic stare off.
No!
Oh my god.
Call...
Colonel!
Snake!
Gas!
Do something!
Snake!
Call!
Emerick!
Snake!
Do!
Something!
Snake!
I hope we get the little liquid jump scare as he runs by.
Very close.
But that's why he didn't pick up when we were fighting the hindee!
Gas!
All you can do is wait for Dr. Emerick to open the door.
Stay alive, Snake.
Fox alive.
If only Snake would throw up here.
Oh no.
Wait, never mind.
He would throw up in his mask.
That'd be awful, actually.
Um, Otacon?
Uh, Otacon!
O-Otacon.
Otacon.
Wait, Otacon.
O-Otacon.
O-Otacon!
O-Otacon, this is bad.
O-Otacon.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, this is actually bad.
Otacon, this is bad!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh my god.
Wait, Otacon!
I know the
gas mask doesn't do anything anymore, but Otacon!
Um, Otacon, please!
Oh, thank god.
Thank you.
Took you long enough.
Gosh!
I had to use a ration!
Okay, here we go.
I love this part.
Please.
Also, we're in for a really...
We're in for a treat of a cutscene coming up.
Okay.
Please.
It sucked.
Nick, did you like my sunglasses?
Oh, you'd point a weapon at your own brother?
Why did you disguise yourself as master?
So I could manipulate you more easily.
You performed quite well, I must say.
I must say.
Although the boys at the Pentagon are probably saying the same thing.
Like my sunglasses?
Following orders blindly with no questions asked, you've lost your warrior's pride.
And become nothing more than a pawn, Snake.
A pawn?
What?
Stopping the nuclear launch?
Rescuing the hostages?
We managed to avoid choking.
It was all just a diversion.
A diversion?
The Pentagon only needed you to come into contact with us.
That's what killed the arms tech president and decoy octopus.
They wanted to kill them on purpose.
That's right.
You were sent here to kill us.
Did you like my sunglasses?
So they could retrieve Metal Gear Undamaged, along with bodies of the Genome Soldiers.
Oh my gosh.
From the beginning, the Pentagon was just using you as a vector to spread Fox Dye.
No!
Fox Dye?
It can't be.
Are you telling me Naomi was working with the Pentagon?
Oh, no, no.
They thought she was.
But it seems that Dr. Naomi Hunter couldn't be controlled so easily.
Thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
We've got a spy working in the Pentagon.
He reported that Dr. Hunter altered Fox Dye's program just before the operation.
But no one knows how or why.
I wonder.
Maybe they arrested her so they could find out the answer to that.
No doubt.
But I had no idea she was motivated by such petty revenge.
We still don't know what changes she made to Fox Dye's program.
Oh well.
Doesn't matter.
I've already added the Fox Dye vaccine to my list of White House demands.
There's a vaccine?
There must be.
But that woman is the only one who really knows.
It might prove to be unnecessary.
Oh, yes!
Here it is!
You were successful in coming into contact with all of us.
So we must have all been exposed to the virus.
You're just young.
It's true that the arms tech president and decoy octopus were killed by Fox Dye.
But Ocelot, myself, and you, the carrier, were apparently unaffected.
Why?
Why is it so extra?
In any case, if it doesn't kill you, then I'm not worried either.
After all, our genetic code is identical.
It's so awesome!
So it's true.
You and I are...
Clones.
Oh!
Oh, he's breakdancing now?
Yes.
Twins.
Twins!
But we're not ordinary twins.
We're twins linked by cursed genes.
Les enfants terribles!
You're fine.
You got all the old man's dominant genes.
I got all the flawed, recessive genes.
Everything was done so that you would be the greatest of his children.
The only reason I exist is so they could create you.
So you're saying I'm the dominant one?
That's right.
I'm just the leftovers of what they used to make you.
Can you understand what it's like to know that you're garbage since the day you were born?
He's freaking out.
But I'm the one father chose.
So that's why you're so obsessed with Big Boss.
Some warped kind of love.
Ha!
Love?
It's hate.
His choosing me knowingly to be the inferior one.
Two sides of the same coin.
For this, I want revenge.
You don't even understand this.
You, who could kill your own real father.
You stole my chance for revenge.
Now I'll finish the work that father began.
Hey, that's a skill issue.
You had two tries.
You had two tries, Liquid.
You're just like Naomi.
Well, I'm not like you.
Unlike you, I'm proud of the destiny that is encoded into my very genes.
He's going full monkey.
Oh!
You missed your last chance.
You'll regret that forever.
Uh-oh.
Snake!
Come!
Kneel down to this historic weapon!
Consider it an honor!
A gift from your brother!
Now, you shall bear witness to the demon weapon!
It will drag the world into the 21st century!
Oh, Rex!
Rex is huge!
Oh my god!
Oh!
The demonic weapon!
Wait!
Oh my gosh, I should have killed those guys.
They're gonna get crushed.
At least they'll die in their sleep.
The music's kind of awesome, though.
Kick its butt, man!
I'm gonna kick its butt!
Some kind of Metal Gear revengeance.
How do I stop it?
It's huge!
Oh my god, it's so big!
After Zanzibar, take one!
Action!
Wipe his ass!
Wipe his butt!
Oh, he's so cute!
Oh my god!
Now, roller!
Oh my god, it's so cool to see!
Oh!
Punch it!
We're all sub-characters!
He's so cute!
Huh?
Alright.
Um, anyway...
Colonel!
God help us.
Metal Gear is moving.
No!
You help me!
Snake, it's all riding on you now.
You've got to stop that thing!
But how?
You'll have to ask Dr. Emmerich, the guy who made it.
Gotta take out the... first the radom, right?
Snake, Rex's armor is impregnable.
You can't do any damage with the weapons you've got.
Rex uses the latest advances in compound armor.
Can you speak up, Otacon?
I can't hear you over the music.
Huh?
The music!
Rex's pilot seat operates exactly like a VR system.
We got the chorus back!
Finally!
There are multiple sensors connected to a high-tech interface used for the controls.
It's completely self-enclosed and shut off from the outside environment.
He's not using his naked eyes.
So if you could somehow destroy the sensors...
The sensors?
Do you see that round plate on Rex's left arm?
Yes!
That thing that looks like a shield...
That's a radom.
If you can destroy that thing, it won't be able to use its electronic equipment.
It's so funny, because when I was putting together...
Try to hit that radom with a stinger missile.
Okay.
Stop it.
No!
Um...
Great.
The part that looks like a beak is where the pilot seat is.
In an emergency, it will open up.
But I knew how to put it together, because I was like, Oh, the radom is on its left shoulder.
But the interior is a different story.
Yeah?
I get it.
First, I destroy the radom.
That will force him to open up the pilot seat.
Right.
If you can shoot a missile into the cockpit, you'll destroy the computer controller.
You intentionally designed it with a weak point?
It's not a weak point.
More like a weakness.
A weakness.
People and weapons just aren't very appealing without a weakness of some kind.
So true, Otacon.
I guess so.
I owe you one, Otacon.
I mean, you can't make something entirely perfect, right?
You can't make something perfect.
Um...
Any bettakers on how many tries it will take her to beat the Zanzibar Shuffle?
Stop!
Okay, let's see.
Oh my god.
The music is so awesome, but it is also so loud.
Alright, stinger missile.
Oh, uh...
Turn around and look at him.
Oh wait, also...
I think here I can use the chaff grenades.
Oh god.
Yeah, you don't know where I am now, dummy.
So, lock onto that.
And boom.
Chaff away!
And
uh...
stinger?
I didn't have my...
rations on.
I didn't have...
Oh, everything was so right.
Except...
Except... oh my god.
Okay, it's fine.
Ah!
Oh my god.
Uh oh.
I need to throw the chaff as soon as I can.
Oh my goodness.
Ah, crunch.
I got crunched for real.
Oh, I don't think that hit.
It's not even like...
Oh!
Chaff!
That's not coming for me, right?
Yeah, you don't know where I am.
Haha.
You can't see me, dummy!
After Xanthabar, take two!
Hey, hey, hey!
It is my fault that I forgot the...
It is my fault I forgot the...
the rations, yeah.
It's my fault.
I should have noticed.
Here he comes.
Damn!
Oh, he's so cute!
Nice try, Snake!
Snake, stop standing there!
Oh!
Oh my god!
Gray Fox!
Oh!
This is so Raiden.
Hahaha.
A name from long ago.
It sounds better than Deep Throat.
So it is you.
You look terrible, Snake.
You haven't aged well.
It's because I'm a clone.
And I age fast.
Deep Throat was...
was Gray Fox?
He was Gray...
He was Deep Throat the whole time!
Gray Fox was Deep Throating me!
Sorry, calling me as Deep Throat!
Nice.
Fox, why?
What do you want from me?
Only you can free me.
Ninja!
Fox, stay out of this.
What about Naomi?
She's hell-bent on taking revenge for you.
Oh, my chat just broke.
Naomi...
You're the only one who can stop her.
No, I can't.
Why?
Because I'm the one who killed her parents.
Oh my god.
I was young then.
And couldn't bring myself to kill her, too.
Oh, I think you two broke it.
Uh-oh.
I felt so bad that I decided to take her with me.
I raised her like she was my own blood.
Sorry, I'll have no chat for a minute.
To soothe my guilty conscience.
To read.
Even now, she thinks of me as her brother.
Aww.
Fox?
Outwardly, we may have seemed like contented brother and sister.
But you...
I looked into her eyes.
I trembled with fear.
We're back.
Tell her for me.
Tell her that I was the one who did it.
No!
There you are!
We're just about out of time.
Here's a final present from Deep Throat.
I'll stop it from moving.
Fox!
What kind of present is this?
Oh my god, so awesome.
Oh yeah!
You dodged those missiles!
Yeah!
Okay.
This isn't gonna stop it from shooting again.
Oh my god.
Fox!
Ugh.
Oh my god, Fox.
He doesn't look so good.
Oh no, he doesn't look so good.
Oh my god.
In the Middle East, we don't hunt foxes.
We hunt jackals.
Oh, it looks so brutal.
I mean, it is brutal.
But oh my god.
We use royal harriers.
Fox!
How strong is that exoskeleton of yours?
Snake!
Are you just going to sit by and watch him die?
He's so awesome.
Cornered Fox is more dangerous than a jackal!
Yeah!
He had that the whole time and just never used it.
It's our turn.
Oh god.
Wait a second.
Wait.
He destroyed the ray dome.
Impressive.
You are indeed worthy of the code name Fox.
But now, you're finished!
Now, fire the stinger!
Fox!
Can you really shoot?
You'll kill him too!
I can't do it.
No, I can't do it.
I can finally die.
After Zanzibar.
Zanzibar land?
Taken from the battle.
Neither truly alive.
Nor truly dead.
It's no good.
I can't do it.
After Zanzibar land.
They changed it.
They changed it to Zanzibar land.
Oh no.
I don't think I can watch this.
Oh my god.
No, no, no.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Huh?
Snake.
We're not tools of the government.
Or anyone else.
Fighting was the only thing.
The only thing I was good at.
But at least...
I always fought for what I believed in.
Snake.
Farewell.
Oh god.
Oh
god.
Oh my god.
When death is entreated.
He just like...
Oh my god.
He just smooshed him.
The battle is decided.
Good lord.
You see?
You can't protect anyone.
Not even yourself.
We changed the teleprompter.
Just chuck it at him.
Maybe you'll get lucky.
Nice.
Why?
Why are you running at him?
Okay, everybody.
Wait, I cannot...
I cannot see where you are.
I do want to see if I can find some more.
Oh my god.
Did I get hit?
I think I got hit.
Okay, good.
There's a ration right here.
I do want to find some more.
That was sneaky.
It unequipped my...
It unequipped my rations.
It unequipped them.
Oh wait.
Can I stinger him from here?
Here?
There?
There.
What are you doing?
Oh my god.
There?
Why are you just yelling?
That
should be me.
Right there.
Right there, please.
Oh my god.
Did that hit?
I don't know actually.
I don't think it did.
I don't think it hit.
That's okay though.
It's kind of...
Next one!
Can I get him again?
Oh shoot.
Run, Snake!
Run!
I'll crush you into dust!
To end dusted.
It is truly that this game is easier.
It is just truly that this game is easier than...
It is just the fact that this game is easier.
But...
Aaaaah!
Yeah, it's less janky.
I knew it.
That was nothing for you.
It really looked easy.
It's so much easier.
It's so...
Uh...
What do you mean, as usual?
Do you know me?
This guy has nine lives.
Okay, now I think this is the real fight.
This is the more difficult part, I'd say.
Keeps people waiting.
Snake, have you heard of Big Chungus?
Yeah, Meryl is dead in this one.
Well-needed men like us.
We were valued then.
We were desired.
You don't have to just be a weapon, though, man.
You can just live your life.
Get a hobby.
With all the liars and hypocrites running the world, war isn't what it used to be.
We're losing our place in a world that no longer needs us.
A world that now spurns our very existence.
Yeah, I wanted to get the ending with Otacon, so...
You should die.
There's one specific part that is so funny.
After I launch this weapon and get our billion dollars, we'll be able to bring chaos and honor back to this world gone soft.
Conflict shall breed conflict, new hatreds will arise, and our own biosphere shall steadily expand.
But as long as there are people, there will always be war.
But the problem is balance.
Father knew what type of a balance was best.
Is that the only reason?
Isn't that reason enough for warriors such as us?
I don't want that kind of world.
Ha!
You lie.
Is it because I...
So why are you here, then?
Is it because I enjoy all the killing?
Why do you continue to follow your orders while your superiors betray you?
Why did you come here?
Why?
Well, I'll tell you then.
No.
Oh, here, I love this part.
You enjoy all the killing.
That's why.
What?
Are you denying it?
Haven't you already killed most of my comrades?
The mocap actor is so great.
The hand flare.
I watched your face as you delivered the coup de grace.
No, you didn't.
Oh, it reflected such vitality.
Yes.
Why did you strip me?
You're wrong.
Why did you strip me, Liquid?
There is a killer inside you.
You don't have to deny it.
Why did you take off my shirt?
We were created to be that way.
Created...
Terrible children...
The terrible children.
The terrible children?
Terrible children Terrible children
I never understood why... Snake wakes up with his clothes off.
I know, it's so weird.
Big boss!
Let's put that.
They fertilized an egg with one of father's cells.
And then, let it divide into eight clone babies.
I ate the other babies.
Then they transferred the clones to someone's uterus.
And later intentionally aborted six of the fetuses to encourage strong fetal growth.
I don't... that's...
You and I were originally octuplets.
Octuplets?
We could have had more.
The other six of our brothers were sacrificed.
To make us.
We could have had gassy snake.
Oh, gassy snake.
Oh my god.
So, it was you and I.
Two fertilized eggs with exactly the same DNA.
But, they weren't finished yet.
They used me as a guinea pig.
To create a phenotype in which all of the dominant genes were expressed.
To create... you.
I got all the risks.
You're too obsessed with the genes.
You took everything from me before I was even born.
We're too obsessed with the genes.
But, you and I aren't his only children.
Oh no.
What?
The genome soldiers.
They too are his progeny.
Carrying on his genetic legacy.
But unlike us, they carry it digitally.
Oh my god.
With the completion of the human genome project in the last century.
The mysteries of humanity were laid bare.
Thanks to father's DNA.
They were able to identify more than 60 soldier genes.
Responsible for everything from strategic thinking to the proverbial killer instinct.
Those soldier genes were transplanted using gene therapy.
Into the members of the next generation special forces.
That's how they became the genes.
The genome soldiers.
I know a little bit about the story of acid 1 and 2.
That's right.
The genome soldiers that you've been killing right and left.
And it's wild.
Are our brothers with the same genes as ours.
The genome soldiers.
They are misshapen creatures.
When he grins or shows teeth he reminds me of Willem Dafoe.
They are our blood brothers.
And they were born of many an ultimate sacrifice.
Good thing Solid Snake doesn't smile.
Why is he looking at me like that?
1991.
The Gulf War.
The military secretly injected soldiers with the soldier genes.
Real footage.
The Gulf War syndrome that hundreds of thousands of returning soldiers complained about.
Real people.
Was a side effect of it.
Ha.
Flesh.
Flesh being.
Everyone knows that the Gulf War syndrome was caused by exposure to pesticides.
And radiation from depleted uranium rounds.
Ha.
Idiot.
That was just a cover story.
Issued by the Pentagon.
First they tried to say it was post-traumatic stress disorder.
Then chemical or biological weapons.
The poison gas detection units.
And the anti-serine injections.
They were all just to cover up the secret genetic experiments.
Oh.
They were just crazy.
They were just.
Getting the genes.
The so-called Gulf War babies that have been reported by Gulf War veterans are.
Yes.
They too are our brothers and sisters.
I cut Ken Blossom in the battlefield.
Absolutely.
So the genome soldiers mean that the experiments were a success?
Success?
Don't be a fool.
They're a complete failure.
We're on the verge of extinction.
What?
Have you ever heard of the asymmetry theory?
Nature tends to favor asymmetry.
Those species which have gone extinct all show signs of symmetry.
The genome soldiers suffer from the same problem.
Isn't this not real?
Signs of symmetry.
So do I.
Oh.
As do you.
Isn't this not real?
That's right.
We are all on the verge of death at the genetic level.
Oh my god.
We don't know when or what type of disease will occur.
A lot of this is outdated there.
That's why we need the old man's genetic information.
You want Big Boss's DNA so you can save your family?
Save your family?
What?
In nature, family members don't mate with each other.
And yet they help each other to survive.
Do you know why?
Why?
Because it increases the chances that shared genes will be transmitted to future generations.
Altruism among blood relatives is a response to natural selection.
That we will help our blood relatives is inscribed in our very genes.
In our genes.
You're telling me that your genes are ordering you to save the genome soldiers?
Thanks, Ransom.
Ransom.
She can't fight your genes.
It's fake.
All living things are born for the sole purpose of passing on their parents' genes.
Oh my god.
Whoa, whoa.
That's why I will follow what my genes tell me.
And then I'm going to go beyond in order to break the curse of my heritage.
He doesn't have as much cake as Snake does.
And to do that, first, I will kill you.
You had every opportunity.
You have had every...
She's on the verge of She looks like...
Oh there's the bomb!
Is she alive?
I'm not sure.
She was alive.
A few hours ago.
Poor girl kept calling your name.
Synth genes.
Meryl.
Stupid woman.
Falling in love with a man who looks like a baby.
I have a name.
Yeah!
Let Meryl go.
Not all dominant genes are good.
Hmm...
Yeah, it's just... it's uh...
Historical fiction.
Science fiction.
And historical fiction.
Which is always fun.
Uh-oh.
Uh, Colonel, you have some explaining to do.
What for?
To bomb the place.
Yeah, shut it, Eli.
B-2 bombers just lifted off from Galena Air Force Base.
Uh-oh.
Uh -oh.
They're carrying B-61-13 surface-piercing tactical nuclear bombs.
Uh-oh.
What?
Metal Gear is destroyed.
Tell the Secretary of Defense.
Uh-oh.
The Secretary of Defense heard that Naomi double-crossed us, and he's worried about Fox die.
Now that there's no more danger of a nuclear strike from Metal Gear, he's going to do whatever's necessary to cover up the truth of what really happened here.
He's going to drop a nuclear bomb to vaporize all the evidence, along with anyone who knows anything.
Ah!
Don't worry, Snake.
I'll stop the nuclear strike.
I don't know anything!
I promise!
I may be only a figurehead here, but I'm still officially in command of this mission.
Uh, for now.
And if I use you in order to delay the strike, it'll confuse the chain of command and at least buy you some time.
For now, Colonel.
It'll give you a chance to escape.
Yeah.
But Colonel, if you do that...
It's okay, Snake.
The truth is, Foxhound was already the subject of an undercover investigation.
Meryl was transferred to this base just before the terrorist attack as a way of manipulating me.
Those bastards!
I'm sorry.
They forced me to cooperate in exchange for her life.
He's gonna punch the nukes.
You'd better get out of there, Snake.
Are you sure?
It'll be bad for you.
Don't worry.
It's the least I can do for you after all the lies.
Colonel.
I'm ordering them to cancel the bombing run.
After that, there's no turning back.
Huh?
What are you doing?
Uh-oh.
Snake!
Mei Ling, what happened to the Colonel?
I don't believe it!
What happened?
What's happening?
The Colonel!
Sit, speak!
Roy Campbell has been relieved of duty.
I always forget about this guy.
This is the Secretary of Defense, Jim Housman.
Jim Housman, yes.
Bring the Colonel back on.
He's been placed under arrest.
Jim Hate.
Boo!
For leaking top secret information and for the crime of high treason.
Boo, Jim!
Ridiculous.
Boo!
This isn't what you promised me, Jim!
Yes, he is a ridiculous man.
This is not what you promised me!
He truly believed that he was in command of this operation.
You can't see, but I'm like pretending I'm whacking him with my cane.
There won't be a speck of evidence left.
I'm sure the President would want the same thing.
The President ordered this?
The President is a busy man.
I have complete authority here.
How do you plan on explaining the nuclear attack on Alaska to the media?
Second favorite character after Bliskin.
Don't worry.
We've prepared a convincing cover story.
We'll simply say that the terrorists exploded a nuclear device.
Oh my God.
Damn it.
You'll be murdering everyone here.
The scientists.
The genome army.
Everyone.
Donald.
The DARPA chief.
And the DARPA chief is already dead.
Nah.
So you didn't mean to kill the DARPA chief after all.
Ahhh.
He was my friend.
And you could care less about what happens to everybody else, huh?
Well, if you give me the optic disc.
If only, if only the other guy...
I might consider saving them.
Had a...
What are you talking about?
Metal Gear's test data.
Donald was supposed to bring it back.
Had a...
I don't have it.
Accidentally got killed by Ocelot.
I see.
Oh well.
That's okay.
We brought you.
Baker.
Oh, wow.
He's still a person!
Let's finish this before the airstrike.
You stole everything from me.
Got my Naruto gloves on.
I even have my Naruto headband.
Sexy no jutsu!
Oh no!
Nothing changed!
I'm already sexy.
Do you see this?
This will be the time limit for our final battle.
When death comes for this girl, this nuclear module shall vanish from this world as well.
If you win, you might still be able to save her.
Is he gonna talk over the timer again?
Like before?
You could enjoy one brief moment of love.
Of love!
Let's get this over with.
Yeah!
Oh, wow!
Here we go, everybody!
And if you cross this line, you'll fall.
At this height, it'll kill even you.
What about you then, huh?
Oh my god, not him fixing his hair.
Down.
Have at you, Snake!
Yeah!
Oh, he doesn't talk during... Stop running away!
Oh my god.
Oh shoot.
Stop!
God, you are so annoying!
Oh my god!
Uh... uh...
Oh my god.
I still have the dog tags.
Um...
Stop running!
What's wrong, Snake?
Better hurry!
It's going to blow!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's right.
You come here.
What's wrong, Snake?
Ah!
Yeah, that's right.
Better hurry!
It's going to blow!
What's wrong, Snake?
Come here.
Better hurry!
Oh my god.
I don't think I'm gonna make this.
I don't think I'm gonna make this at all.
What's wrong, Snake?
Stop running!
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
I'm gonna crush your little hand.
Oh, nevermind.
I got his dog tags!
Ouch!
Oh my god, he hits so much harder than me!
Oh my god.
Uh oh.
Better hurry!
It's going to blow!
Don't come at me.
Oh, this is not good.
This is not good.
What's wrong, Snake?
Um, wait.
Oh.
The recessive dreams.
It's the recessive dreams.
Better hurry!
It's going to blow!
Ouch!
Yeah, that's right.
Oh, shoot.
I'm gonna die.
Better hurry!
It's going to blow!
We're so done.
We're...
This is...
It's so over.
Not him laughing at me!
It's going to blow!
Hey, you didn't get me either.
So, uh, you know...
What's wrong, Snake?
That's right.
Did I get...
Did I get his dog tags again?
Still?
Or...
Yeah.
I'm going to...
Gotta be like a little bit more...
A little bit more aggressive.
Oh, ah, shoot.
What's wrong, Snake?
Better hurry!
Oh, shoot.
Oh!
I counter-kicked.
I don't know if I still got his dog tags or not.
The camera change is so confusing.
I don't know.
It's just...
Is that all you've got?
Oh, oh, oh!
Oh my god.
Oh, that was totally on purpose.
Ew!
Stop!
Stop being such a...
Oh my god.
Oh, oh.
Ouch!
Oh, ouch.
Oh my god.
Stop.
Owww-ji!
Better hurry!
It's going to blow!
Oh, oh, oh!
Oh, shoot.
Oh my god.
Stop!
Out!
We're like running into each other.
Nice.
Oh, no, no, no!
No, no, no, no, no.
You get off my butt!
Oh, shoot.
I don't know why I tried to... it was like...
Oh, no, no, no!
Dang.
That was so close!
Yeah, little... little...
I hope I still get his...
Oh my...
I hope I still got his dog tag, though.
Oh.
Oh, nice.
I still ended up kicking him.
Oh, no!
Not the counter!
Oh my god.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Stop being so slippery!
Oh my god.
Why was I doing so well last time?
This time, I can't hit... get a single hit in.
I'm just gonna redo it.
Oh, wait.
Can he not get me?
Look at him go.
Oh, shoot.
He stepped on me.
He's spam-charging.
Yeah, it's not fair!
It's not fair!
Oh my gosh.
That was so funny.
Okay, but you need to stop running all around.
You know?
I gotta kinda like fake him.
Like that and...
Oh.
There we go.
Kinda gotta fake him.
And then...
Oh.
Fake, fake, fake out.
Oh, oh, oh, okay.
Uh, sure.
Yeah.
And...
I'm gonna step on your hands!
Oh, never mind.
Okay, I think I do have the dog tags then.
Because they didn't show up.
Oh, shoot.
Fake.
Okay.
Get up here!
Oh, shoot.
Oh!
Nice, nice, nice.
At least I got the kick in.
I think if you...
Oh, no.
I think if you get him into this corner...
Oh.
You can like kind of cheese it a little bit, but I'm not good enough with the timing.
Obviously.
Oh, nice.
Shoo, shoo, shoo.
Don't charge at me.
Nice.
Ouch!
Oh, I can't get the kick in.
There we go.
Nice.
Oh.
I know he can get me with that move too.
He'll like get up and kick me.
Yeah.
Oh.
Nice.
Dang it.
Ah!
Dude!
I knew he was gonna...
Oh, my God!
You!
You're so annoying.
Oh, my God.
I'm gonna...
I'm actually...
Please.
So close!
Come on!
No, please.
Don't charge.
Don't charge at me.
Fuck.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
I'm so close.
I'm sweating so bad.
We trade a jank X-Fight for an extra jank.
No, this fight was also really...
I remember this fight was hard in the first one too, because it's so tight.
Oh.
Contacts.
I need to put in some eye drops.
Oh, no.
Ah!
Ugh.
Okay.
We still have one last little bit.
One last little bit and we're done, guys.
We got this.
Just like MGS4.
I know.
This is so MGS4.
Oh, my God.
This part is so MGS4.
Ah!
Oh, my God.
Oh.
Thank you for the raid!
Thank you!
If you just came in, we're at the very end of Metal Gear Solid, so if you don't want spoilers...
Well, Metal Gear Solid the Twin Snakes, but if you don't want spoilers, maybe head on out.
Murphy, thanks for the fine gift!
Thank you!
Raymak, thanks for the fine gift!
Damn!
She looks really buff here!
I mean, I know she is, but like...
That angle...
Meryl
Silverberg's ghost!
Oh, that was guttural!
Oh my gosh!
Gabo, thank you for the fine gift!
Star Creator!
Thank you for the fine gift!
Meryl!
They turned this into a Yakuza game?
No.
Yakuza turned itself into a Metal Gear game.
Pac-Tai, thanks for the fine gift!
Oh, Meryl...
Jay, thanks for the fine gift!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, you guys, stop!
I'm trying to watch the scene.
Tick, tock!
Oh my gosh, he looks really dead.
It's okay, Snake.
It was me.
I did it.
Not you.
Don't take the...
Oh, I don't like what I... I don't like seeing him, like, putting this on himself when it was me.
Meryl, I'm sorry.
Dog Strike, thanks for the tech update.
Forgive me.
Thank you.
Meryl can't forgive anyone anymore.
Okay, you don't gotta say it like that, Otacon.
Come on.
Shh!
She's gone, Snake.
Because of me.
No, because of me.
I guess blaming yourself makes it easier, huh?
Focusing on that will keep you from thinking about her death.
What the hell do you know?
Meryl's dead.
I lost.
So... are you gonna stay here and die?
Along with her?
Snake... people die.
But death is not defeat.
He... he grew up so fast.
That's what Hemingway said.
I lost Wolf, too.
But that wasn't defeat.
She and I will be together forever.
People die when they are killed.
We didn't lose anything.
Together.
Forever.
It's true that Wolf is dead.
But our love didn't die with her.
Life isn't just a game of win or lose.
Don't you think?
Yeah, you can start new love.
Let's live, Snake.
Together.
There's a parking garage right next door.
We can get to the surface from there.
The way he like dropped down so fast.
Come on.
I released all the security locks.
It'll be okay.
We can escape.
Come on, Snake.
You have my word on it.
He's gonna...
Otacon is protecting him.
Otacon, you've changed.
You have...
I'm through regretting the past.
You have to protect the ones that you love.
Life isn't all about loss, you know?
You've changed.
God, she looks really bad.
I mean, she's dead.
So, of course, but like...
Oh my God.
It started.
Otacon falling over.
Number two.
Those guys seem like they only hurry when they're destroying things.
He grew up.
Good.
Let him destroy it.
But they can't destroy the human spirit.
You should like leave.
Okay.
Let's go.
Bye, Meryl.
I hope you're still watching me.
You'll see if I'm the legendary man or not.
The only reason I don't like this, I think, is because it's so sad for Snake.
So sad for him.
I love Snake so much.
I love him...
Come on.
Hustle.
So much.
Snake, it's cold outside.
You'll freeze like that.
Give me my clothes.
Not because Meryl died.
I like Meryl too.
But watching Snake's reaction to it is... makes me the most sad.
My sneaking suit.
Eevee!
You better hurry.
You just... you just stepped on it.
Wait a second.
The abs are fake?
The abs are drawn onto the suit?
Looking good, Mr...
Oh.
Now
you look like yourself again.
Why are you standing there like that?
Meryl.
Who put a sniffer over you?
You don't like this, are you?
It's cute!
That histria...
He set the world on fire.
Plenty of things being said this year.
It was just supposed to be that vein in that.
preceding the announcement.
Why are you acting like you're not in danger anymore?
Amen.
Oh!
Why didn't you turn off the cameras?
When you turned off everything else!
Wait...
Uh...
Okay, hold on.
Oh gosh.
Oh my god.
Yeah, let's go, let's go, let's go!
Uh, hold on, hold on.
I'm trying to get in!
I'm trying!
Uh, how do I use this?
Oh, shoot, uh...
Oh my god.
Can I...
Can I lower it?
Wait...
Can you please?
How do I lower it?
Uh...
Wait, how do... No, seriously, how do I lower it?
Why isn't it...
Uh...
How do I lower it?
Oh my god!
I don't know!
Oh, in first person!
Oh, great.
Oh my gosh.
What a mess.
I'm just gonna shoot ahead.
It's unlimited ammo anyway.
Why did...
Why did I do that?
I'm trying!
I got him.
Oh!
I'm in a real, like, adventure...
Oh, gosh.
I can't see anything, Otacon.
Wait, how do I... There we go.
Oh my god, why do you...
do that every time, Otacon?
It's not very helpful.
Snake, I'm... I mean, Otacon, I'm trying.
This thing is...
God,
I have, like, no life left!
Otacon, I'm gonna die!
Otacon, I'm gonna bleed out!
Okay.
One HP and a dream.
Otacon, I'm gonna bleed out!
Snake, it's not over yet!
Yeah!
I won't let you... I won't let you take my one life left.
I won't let you take it!
Oh, dang!
You took it!
Hey, I'm shooting this.
Oh my gosh, ouch!
Why am I not hitting... There we go.
Yeah, that's right.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, ouch!
Come on!
Yeah!
I'm shooting!
I am shooting your butt!
You cannot...
Yeah, that's right.
Put it on a shirt!
Please!
If I die here, that would be insane.
The music is awesome.
Oh, are you okay?
Are you okay, Otacon?
I need you to drive the car, Otacon!
Otacon, I need you to drive the car!
His glasses!
Oh my god.
Shoot, Snake!
Shoot!
Oh my god.
He's gun dancing!
Yeah!
Oh my god!
Oh no!
Oh!
So close!
Are you okay?
Are you okay, little baby?
Is this CQC?
Otacon, are you okay?
How many Matrix scenes are there?
You have to understand, I think the Matrix was like...
Otacon, can you move?
...was so popular around this time.
Oh my god, he's...
He's all bent backwards!
It's no use, pulls him out anyway.
There you go.
I'm surprised he can stand.
Don't get his toes.
Damn.
This guy and his nine lives.
Snake.
There's less tension here because in the original...
Snake!
They're trapped under the car.
But here he's just standing in front of...
Do something, Snake!
You can stop him!
Oh!
Oh no!
Oh, MBS!
Fox!
Fox?
Die!
Yeah!
Oh, that was it?
Oh, never mind, it wasn't...
Oh, he's away!
Give it up.
Oh, he's standing back up?
Excuse me?
Are you...
Otacon being like, am I third wheeling?
Oh my god.
You guys, they're brothers!
Stop!
Oh my gosh.
If he's dead...
That means...
No, Snake.
Don't say it.
Don't think about it, Snake.
Don't spray it.
Snake.
Don't.
What happened to the air raid?
No stealth bombers in sight.
The Colonel.
Chat is so down bad.
Colonel!
Are you okay?
Colonel, what happened?
The Secretary of Defense has been arrested.
Early retirement.
Arrested.
I was able to get into contact with the President.
Metal gear.
The training exercise.
All of it.
It was all the Secretary of Defense acting alone.
Of course it was.
What happened to the air raid?
And the nuclear strike?
The orders were rescinded.
The F-117s and the B-2 bombers have returned to the base.
Once again, I have complete authority over this operation.
I see.
Your Oshii's graduation is not too late.
I wonder about that.
In any case, the danger's over.
Thanks, Snake.
Colonel, about Meryl...
I already know.
Aww.
I'm sorry, Colonel.
Here's where we learn.
Meryl was... my daughter.
What?
I didn't find out until recently.
I got a letter from her mother.
My dead brother's wife.
You should have told her.
I was going to tell her after this operation was over.
No, you can't wait.
It's okay, Snake.
Thanks anyway.
What?
Snake, I'm sorry I kept a lot of things from you.
It's okay, Colonel.
Bro, I'm stuck.
I'm not a Colonel.
Oh, that's right.
Colonel.
I've got a present for you.
There's a snowmobile close to you.
Mei Ling saw it on the satellite photos.
This time of year, the glaciers are pretty calm.
You should be able to ride right out of there.
Yippee!
Oh, but the boys at the D.I.A.
and the N.S.A.
never expected you to come home alive.
Me neither.
I'd better not show my face right there.
No danger of that.
You two officially died after your jeep sank into the ocean.
It's not too far from the truth.
There's also a helicopter waiting for you at the Fox Islands.
Okay, Roy.
Are you going to be okay?
Don't worry.
I've got an insurance policy.
A hard copy of all of Mei Ling's data.
As long as I've got that, you, me, and Mei Ling will be fine.
Oh, yeah.
The battery on these nanomachines will run out soon.
They won't be able to follow us.
I guess we won't meet again.
Don't worry.
I'll pay you a visit sometime.
Really?
I'll look forward to that.
Roy, just tell me one thing.
The save data.
You guys say it's save scumming, but no.
It's preserving the evidence.
Naomi said she wants to talk to you face to face about that.
Duh.
How is she?
Don't worry.
Mei Ling's with her right now.
I'm switching over to Naomi.
Snake.
Oh, God.
Sorry.
I heard.
About my brother.
Uh.
Fox.
No.
Frank.
Wanted to tell you something.
He told me to tell you to forget about him.
And to go on with your own life.
Snake is such a good guy.
Frankie said that?
Yeah.
He also said he'll always love you.
Snake is such a good guy.
God, that moment was so ruined by Naomi.
Your brother just saved you, me, and the whole world.
Snake is such a good guy.
He fought on sheer willpower until the very end.
Maybe.
Maybe now he's finally found some peace.
Tell me when I spread false information on the internet.
My brother was already dying.
Oh.
Ever since he fought with you in Zanzibar land.
He's been like a ghost.
A ghost looking for a place to die.
He's been looking for a place to die.
Naomi.
Liquid died from Fox Die 2.
What about me?
Oh boy.
I can't wait to get some real answers here.
It's up to you.
What do you mean?
Everybody dies when their time's up.
Naomi, that- yeah.
It's up to you how you use the time left to you.
You gave me this virus.
Live snake.
That's all I can say.
Naomi, you gave me a virus.
How long do I have left to live?
Each person is born with their fate written into their own genetic code.
Inscribed into their genes.
Naomi.
But that's not all there is to life.
I finally realized that.
I told you before.
I killed everybody around me.
The reason I was interested in genes and DNA.
Naomi, everybody around me is dead because of this virus.
Because I wanted to know who I was.
What do I have left?
I thought that if I analyzed my DNA.
I could find out who I was.
Nobody cares who you are.
And I thought that if I knew that.
Oh, God.
Then I'd know what path I should take in life.
I secretly wish Snake would princess carry Otacon here.
It's not a secret.
I just wish it.
I didn't learn anything.
Yeah, you didn't learn anything.
Just look at the genome soldiers.
You can input all the genetic information.
Okay, here it comes.
Make them into the strongest soldiers.
Oh, Otacon.
I love this part so much.
The most we can say about DNA is that its genetic information houses a person's strengths or destiny.
And...
He looks so freaky.
You mustn't allow yourself to be chained to fate.
To be ruled by your genes.
Humans can choose the type of life they want to live.
Well, you...
Oh, here he goes!
Oh, no!
Whether you've been programmed or not isn't important.
The important thing is that you choose life.
Just carry him!
And then...
Oh, no!
Here he goes!
Don't you think, Snake?
I'm gonna choose life, too.
Until today, I've always looked for a reason to live.
I'm going to just live.
He just doesn't stop!
Genes exist to pass down our hopes and dreams for the future for our children.
Living is a link to what will come.
All life is tethered to the future.
That's exactly why I got this ending.
Because that part is so funny.
Then the world can change.
He just keeps going.
He just keeps sliding.
I can't even listen to Naomi.
Oh, gosh.
Okay, she's finally done.
This is what Meryl died for.
Until today, I've only lived for myself.
Survival has been the only thing I cared about in my life.
That's not just you.
That's how everyone is.
I only felt truly alive when I was staring death in the face.
I don't know.
Maybe it's written into my genes.
What about now?
I want to enjoy life.
I really do.
Yeah.
How about you, Otacon?
Me?
I feel like a new man.
Like how that implied that no one was listening to Naomi.
So what are you going to do?
Continue your research?
No.
Science and technology are fine, but...
The music is so whimsical.
What a whimsical...
Sounds good.
The whole reason I got into science in the first place was because I was no good with people.
I was scared of them.
I was scared of life.
I thought that I could never understand them because they're so illogical.
But I've finally learned how to like people.
There's no reason for me to be afraid anymore.
You and I are more alike than I thought.
Nooo!
You're so isomotical.
Yeah.
Yeah, I've seen this scene quite a few times.
It's so funny.
Oh god, I'm tears streaming down my face.
Oh god, I'm crying.
I'm laughing so hard.
Oh, I'm in.
Our new loves, though.
I'm in.
That's why Snake doesn't say anything.
Yeah, your driving was kind of, you know...
I'm in.
I'm Hal, Dave.
Oh, that's right.
Hal.
Hal and Dave.
That's a good one.
Maybe we should take a trip to Jupiter.
So, where are you going, Dave?
Oh god.
I think it's time for me to look for a new path in life.
A new path?
A new purpose.
Will you find it?
I'll find it.
I've already found it.
I know I'll find it.
Sorry, I'm freaking out over my own delusions.
I don't think I'm okay in the head.
God, I'm crying.
In the 1980s, there were more than 60,000 nuclear warheads in the world at all times.
The total destructive power amounted to one million times that of the Hiroshima A-bomb.
In January 1993, START II was signed and the United States and Russia agreed to reduce the number of deployed strategic nuclear warheads to 3,000 to 3,500 in each nation by the end of the year 2007.
However, as of 2003, there still exist more than 20,000 nuclear warheads in the world.
Time to reveal my favorite theory.
The Twin Snakes is actually your retelling of the events of MGS.
Always a real treat to see you playing these games and sharing your passion.
This song brings back so many memories.
Yippee!
It was definitely not as dramatic as maybe the first time I played MGS1.
But I still had so much fun with this.
Congrats on finishing Twin Snakes!
PirateBug thanks for the 10 gifted!
Thank you!
It was an absolute riot experiencing it with you.
I'm so glad we got to see you stream it.
Yeah!
I'm so glad that I streamed it.
Can't hit the high notes right now.
My throat is still...
Almost no tension in the boss battles, unfortunately.
It's so funny.
The one that I struggled with the most...
The tank.
The tank of all things!
But yeah, in this it makes the boss battle so easy.
But...
I think it's also worth just playing because of the redone cutscenes and everything too.
Even though some of them I don't like as much.
But...
Thank you for finishing Twin Snakes, boss!
This is good, isn't it?
Don't make me cry anymore!
I'm gonna choose life too.
Yeah, sure thing.
Naomi, see you in MGS4!
So true!
Gosh.
Naomi, you!
Oh, so cute!
Oh, little meese.
Little wolf.
Oh, sniper wolf.
Little bears.
Some say Otacon is still falling to this day.
This song is so awesome.
Thank you for the five gifted.
Thank you!
Sorry if I said your name wrong.
I
don't know the words.
It's not...
What's the language again?
I'm not sure.
Thank you for the Aqua Sofa!
No.
Just found the director of Godzilla Final War and made all the cutscenes for this game.
No wonder why Snake kept doing the Matrix only.
Yeah, exactly.
Thanks for getting another wild ride.
Congrats on beating the game.
Thank you for the Aqua Sofa!
Down!
Thank you for the 30 gifted.
Thank you so much.
Gaelic!
Gaelic, yeah.
Or Celtic.
Which is it?
Celtic?
Glad you have joined MGS Matrix Edition.
Welcome back from Outer Heaven.
Thank you!
Thank you.
Oh, man.
Shirakuma!
Thank you for the 10 gifted.
Thank you.
Of course we have to wait for the ending.
Oh!
Zone of the Enders!
Thank you.
It's fun seeing you experience something that was both familiar and different.
Right?
Can't wait to see what other Metal Gear shenanigans you might have in the future.
Replays?
Delta Acid?
Monkeys?
Smash?
A lot of possibilities.
Yeah.
I gotta...
I gotta hold my titles.
The Metal Gear VTuber.
Or maybe reclaim it.
Yanwei, thank you.
Have you seen Mitchell Hammond's...
Metal Gear MSX animations?
As of 2023, there are 12,512 nuclear warheads.
Okay.
That could be less.
They wanted 3,000, but...
You know.
Congrats on finishing the...
Thank you, Maya!
Yeah.
A VTuber to surpass Metal Gear.
I'm so glad I could return to MGS1, Twin Snakes.
But...
You mustn't allow yourself to be chained to fate.
God, sorry.
To be ruled by your genes.
Humans can choose the type of life they want to live.
She always has to have the last line.
Snake.
She thinks she's the main character when Ocelot is the main character.
The important thing is that you choose life.
And then Meryl died.
Meryl walks in to grab a coffee, side-eyes Otacon.
And then...
I think we're the pink.
Just live.
Yes, sir.
The entire unit was wiped out.
Yes.
Yes, sir.
Thanks for the vaccine.
Yes.
Those two are still alive.
Yes, sir.
The vector.
The bactite should be come activated soon.
Right on schedule.
Yes, sir.
I read a letter.
No, sir.
Yes.
Oh, no, sir.
Yes, sir.
Yes.
Liquid is dead.
The inferior one was the winner after all.
We were the inferior one?
That's right.
What?
He was the inferior one?
Of course, the other one thinks so, too.
Yes, sir.
I agree completely.
It takes a well-balanced individual such as yourself to rule the world.
No, sir.
Yes.
No, yes, sir.
Yes, sir.
No, sir.
Dang it, I missed it.
No one knows that you were the third one.
Solidus.
Solidus?
What should I do about the woman?
Wait, what?
Yes, sir.
The surveillance will continue.
Yes.
Yes, sir.
Thank you.
Mr. President.
Goodbye, Mr. President.
Dun-dun.
Yippee.
By the way, Vinny Vinesauce knows that you know about...
Wait, what do you mean he knows that I know about the Diver Chief?
What do you mean by that?
Oh, there's a whole link and everything.
Yes, sir.
Clear code.
My code is hyena.
What's hyena mean?
I got stealth.
Save.
Yeah, we'll save.
Yes, sir.
No, sir.
He reacted to a chat message about it.
Oh, wait, what?
No way.
Yes, sir.
No, sir.
Oh, that was so fun.
That was so fun.
Ocelot doing a mega try-depression.
Oh, impersonation, yeah.
I always go on about it, but Game Boy Metal Gear is essentially a Metal Gear 3.
And Acid 1 is the game that is the closet... closet?
Closest?
Oh, closest to an MGS1 sequel vibes-wise.
I don't know about a sequel.
It's really weird.
Code Hyena means pretty good.
Oh my gosh, Romper Rambit!
You can sing!
Holy cow!
I was watching your videos.
You sing so well.
Hyena is an anagram of Henya.
It was meant to be.
Yeah, he can.
Yeah!
Congratulations on clearing the game!
Thank you!
There we go.
Okay, I don't want to wear out my CD so much, but...
Thank you.
Metal Gear Solid Twin Snakes?
It was an honor?
Wait, let's see the special real quick.
Oh!
I never got a camera.
How do I get the camera?
Hmm...
Boss Survival?
Oh, cool!
Previous Operations?
What?
Emo Theater?
Otacon Chapter?
Wait.
Wait, does it have the MSX games on here?
I had no idea.
They're definitely going to have the MSX games on here.
That's really weird.
But the juice is worth the squeeze.
Oh my god, there's so many that we never got.
Okay, I have to press manually.
Go, go.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Normal?
There we go.
Oh!
There, there, there, there!
Hmm.
There's only 28.
But, if you want to get the MSX, you have to get the MSX.
Okay, the viewer is literally nothing.
Maybe because we don't have their date of birth or anything.
It's kind of lame.
Okay, never mind.
That's all it is?
Okay, I'm going to test this real quick.
Oh!
We got baited so hard.
It's just a summary.
Wait.
Oh my god!
Look at Young Snake in the back!
Look at him!
He's so baby!
We got baited.
He's a baby!
Cool.
Welp.
Okay, I'm going to turn off my GameCube now.
Actually, hold on.
Give me a second.
We're going to move over to...
What the heck?
Oh, never mind.
Give me a second.
Here we go.
There we go.
Oh, and you can't hear anymore.
And off!
There we go.
Turn it off.
Let me put on some...
Oh, that's not what I wanted to do.
Oh wait.
Did I mess it up?
It's mostly fine.
Sometimes if I put it on...
the wrong way...
it sticks to my bangs instead...
and it becomes weird.
The...
Oh, wait.
Stop it!
There was a Japanese collector's console bundle for this...
which comes with NES Metal Gear on a separate disc.
Oh!
That's so awesome.
What?
Let me get some music real quick, you guys.
Give me a second.
I feel so...
so good.
I feel so good.
That was so much fun.
Even if the bosses aren't...
like...
super difficult...
it's still a lot of fun.
It also makes you feel good...
when you're just like...
Yeah, I can beat it easily.
Any chance of the Zone of the Enders playthrough at some point, boss?
To the series near and dear to...
close to...
near...
dear...
and dear...
to my heart...
for being my introduction to Kojima-san.
Um...
I would like to.
So...
Um...
It's not like a...
It's a...
It's an eventually.
So, yes...
but I don't know when.
Just a...
an eventually.
The Ocelite fight...
fight was so much easier.
Every fight was so much easier.
It was so funny.
And I couldn't get the cheese for...
quite a few of them, but...
we kind of cheesed...
Raven.
Vulcan Raven.
Yeah.
So much fun.
What did you guys think?
Did you guys like it?
Try Ghost Babble.
I...
want to.
I do...
Hello?
Why do I keep breathing?
Uh-oh.
Everything okay?
Might need to...
Might need to let my computer rest a little bit today.
I'm just now becoming a fan.
Hi, Kyle.
Congratulations for getting this ending between the original MGS and this game.
Yeah, I'd really choose the former.
On your time, look up Metal Gear Stereo TV.
See you then.
Thanks, Kyle.
Thank you for the pink.
Just BEC.
Oh, look at the membership.
Thank you.
Um...
Oh my gosh.
Why do I keep freezing?
What's going on?
Eh?
Oh.
I'm frozen.
Hold on.
Give me a second.
I'm gonna disappear.
I think maybe...
my webcam is overheating.
Okay.
It might be overheating.
Uh...
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
I'm here.
I'm a ghost.
I can just poof in and out of existence, you know?
I can poof in and out of existence.
I actually got really lucky with this because, um...
I was like, you know...
I was like, I'm gonna come back.
But...
In the past, I used my giant iPad.
But I was like...
I don't really have room for my iPad on my desk.
I don't know what to do.
And then, my friend was just like...
Well, actually, I have a...
I have an iPhone that I can sell to you.
Thank you for the five gift.
Thank you.
Um...
And it's an older...
It's an older iPhone.
They bought it because they thought that, um...
Well, not they thought.
Well, yes.
They...
They thought that they had lost their phone.
And so, they bought it.
And then, they ended up not needing it.
So, super-duper lucky.
Yeah.
So...
I was like...
Otherwise, I would have had to probably buy like a whole new phone.
How old is old?
Is it 10X?
I think it's the first phone that introduced like the...
The...
The better stuff for VTubing.
Hmm.
Yeah.
It's the first one with tracking.
So...
It ended up working out really well.
Hmm.
Yeah.
I think it's the iPhone X.
X.
2017 isn't retro.
It's still new, right?
Yeah.
Still new.
Thank you for this interesting...
Oh, sorry.
In-testing.
No, I'm just kidding.
Experience with MGS and teaching me love can bloom on the...
In the battlefield.
Mia-chan.
Thank you.
100% can bloom.
We're a sting glitch face.
Thanks for the five.
I think... I don't know if maybe now more recent... I don't know.
If more recent... Android phones can be used.
I'm not sure to be honest.
This is all still new to me.
Paperbacks!
Thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you!
Hey boss, I'm here to remind you to talk to your Kamiyoshi.
I have!
In fact...
Now...
I'm not gonna say.
But I saw like a clip...
Where she was like...
If Mint wants to collab with me...
She has to suffer.
What does that mean?
Awesome!
Yes sir!
What is that game?
And he has an S.
No sir!
Sisyphus game?
What's it called?
Is it on Steam?
I'm looking for it.
What's it called?
Sisyphus...
Oh the game of Sisyphus?
Roll the boulder to the top.
Oh this looks like...
Like...
Real shit game.
Oh...
Oh no...
Um...
If I have to play it...
The um...
If I...
To collab with her...
No...
Sisyphus...
The first one is difficult.
It's difficult!
Right?
Sisyphus...
Maybe she meant to say...
Why are we still here?
Just to suffer.
You can do what Mint believe in you.
Do for her.
Why?
I guess I have to suffer...
For my Kamiyoshi.
But it's okay.
If my Kamiyoshi wants me to suffer...
Then I don't mind it so much.
May Kenya play Atlantis no Nazo.
We gotta play Atlantis no Nazo!
You guys!
Well do we?
Do we actually?
I say that but now I'm like...
Wait a minute.
Do I actually have to play that?
Hmm...
Do you want to?
Yeah, I do want to play it actually.
I think it's fine to...
Also play...
Games like that.
It's a challenge.
I'll increase my...
My gamer...
My gamer skills.
Thank you!
Space...
Ghost...
Coast to coast.
Congrats on beating the game.
I really love how...
Over the top all the animations were in this one.
I was dying over a snake dodging the bullets while in the car...
In the car chase.
I know it's so...
There's so much going on.
Yes, Minto.
No, Minto.
Of course.
Madam Ghost.
I am Dragon.
Thank you for the 10 gifted!
Blue Echo, welcome to Mambo Show.
Seymour, thank you.
Marilyn, thank you.
I really like the OG better but this is a really fun alternative take.
Yeah.
Of course.
I agree.
I like the OG better.
But this one is also so silly, goofy, fun.
I think I just love every Metal Gear.
I think I just...
I can't...
Just say that I like one more than the other.
Well, no.
I can't say that.
But you know what I mean.
I just can't say like...
This is the bad one.
They're all really good.
Play Snatcher.
I wanna play Snatcher.
I wanna play Policenauts.
I own Policenauts.
Still looking for Snatcher.
Unfortunately.
Prove it.
Buy a second pachinko machine.
I'll have them stare at each other.
Oh my god.
It's Isla.
Marilyn, thank you.
Yeah.
There's so many games I want to play.
So...
Oh, we have time.
We have time no worries.
I don't wanna...
I don't wanna rush through everything so fast, you know?
And then be like...
Burned out a little bit or something.
I don't know.
Revolver Ocelot.
Parentheses.
Make them kiss.
Play what you enjoy.
Yeah.
So far I am, so...
So far... I mean...
It's like, whatever.
You know, I'm just like...
It's like... whatever.
It's not like I'm having a blast or anything.
It's not like I'm having the time of my afterlife or anything.
It's just like, you know...
Revolver Patches.
My time of my afterlife.
I'm...
Wink.
Cute.
It's not a wink!
It's just...
Twinkle.
More twinkle.
It's not a wink.
Twinkle.
Would you consider HeartGold SoulSilver?
Maybe.
Uh...
I don't think I ever actually played...
Oh, sorry.
I don't think I ever actually played HeartGold or SoulSilver.
Wrong!
Wrong.
I've never played...
I've played original Gold and Silver, but I've never played the Remix.
I don't...
I actually don't... So I don't own them either.
Pokemon games sell...
They're so expensive.
Even second hand.
Like, let's see.
Hold on.
If I go to eBay...
eBay.com HeartGold.
What's it for, too?
Oh, it's a DS game!
So I can play it on my 3DS.
Oh, wait.
This isn't so bad.
It's 40.
Oh, wait.
This isn't so bad.
It's 40.
It's 40 without the case.
I don't need the case.
Let's see.
SoulSilver.
I always get SoulSilver... or I've played Silver before because I like Lugia.
I always get SoulSilver...
or I've played Silver before because I like Lugia.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
A thousand and one?
What?
Pokemon SoulSilver Walmart exclusive.
Big box rare.
See notes.
USA seller.
A thousand and one dollars with 22 bids.
Wait.
What's the notes?
What?
Why is it so expensive?
It comes with...
Oh, it comes with a Lugia figure and a PokeWalker jacket.
It doesn't even come with the PokeWalker!
Oh, wait.
Is it...
It does.
It does come with the PokeWalker.
Just kidding.
Wow.
That's a lot of money.
And it comes with all the sleeves and everything that comes inside.
Sheesh.
I didn't know there was a walker.
I had a Digimon...
I did have a Pikachu one when I was a kid.
And I had a Digimon one.
For some reason, I never had a Tamagotchi.
Oh my gosh.
This ends in 22 minutes.
Wait.
I kind of want to see how high does it get.
Okay.
It's still at a thousand and one.
When's the last bid?
Oh, I don't have an eBay account.
Or I do, but I don't remember the login.
Debbie Orange!
Hey, boss.
Exciting news.
I got myself a crush.
But the problem is she's cold and she's cruel.
But she knows what she's doing.
She pushed me in the pool at her last school reunion.
She...
Thank you, Debbie Orange.
No surprise.
I saw someone on eBay sell Final Fantasy 7 OG for 20k.
What?
I had a Tamagotchi.
I never had one.
But I had the Pikachu one and the Digimon one.
It's not that I didn't want one.
I think my mom just...
It was always my mom that I would ask.
Wait.
There's another one.
This one...
The heart gold one is even more expensive.
Ends in 14 minutes.
With only 17 bids.
Thank you.
If you ever wanted to cover the best is yet to come, Donna Burke did an English lyrics cover.
Yes!
I've seen that before.
Since you own Ace Combat 3, which Ace Combat 3 do you have meant?
Is it from the global version or the JP version?
I will check.
I got it a long while ago so I don't remember.
I don't remember.
I will check though.
Tamagotchi is nostalgic.
It's nostalgic, right?
I've always wanted one.
The Tamagotchi now is amazing.
Tamagotchis now are so different.
They're so crazy.
They're like...
They're like the green and everything.
Pandal!
Welcome to my bush.
Thank you.
Since you own a gamecube, any interest in other big game made by a studio that co-developed Twin Snakes Eternal Darkness?
If you guys have any...
Since I said I've never had a gamecube growing up.
If you guys have any gamecube recommendations, please let me know.
I will definitely see if I can find it and I will play it.
If I'm interested, of course, obviously.
I'm open to anything.
I'm in bootcamp.
I'm so tired.
Please give me a PON!
Ganbare!
Gotcha Force.
Get out of here, mod.
Mario Sunshine?
Mario Sunshine!
Yay, yay!
I've still been playing Korone.
The wow, wow, wow Korone box.
Leave them in the comments though.
Like, OG Resident Evil 4 is for the GameCube.
Oh, really?
But yeah, leave it in the comments because if you put it here, I'll forget.
So once the VOD is up.
Comment, like, for engagement.
That way I can go back through and see.
Hmm.
I realize I have not had dinner.
And it's almost 11pm.
And as much as I want to keep talking with you guys.
I'm starting to feel my head get foggy.
All I had was some Twin Snake Haribo gummies.
Which I was going to make this into my thumbnail.
I was going to print out a picture.
And take a picture of...
I was going to print out like a fan art.
And cut it out.
And paste it onto the Twin Snakes packaging.
And take a picture and use that as my thumbnail.
But then I saw the thumbnail art.
And I was like, this is just so beautiful.
I have to.
I have to use this.
Spank!
Thank you, Dinner and Bio.
Yeah, I have to go.
I'm probably going to go make some.
Eggs and tomatoes.
Because I have to finish up my eggs.
Or.
If anyone is having a delicious meal.
Please.
Let me know.
One.
So that I can bless it with my Moi Moi Kyun powers.
And two.
So I can possess you and eat it.
Myself.
Oh.
I think the stream labs are a little backed up.
But I can still read them on my end.
Yeah.
I made eggs and tomatoes too today.
It's so yummy.
I'm having a burger right now.
Rogu.
I'm coming over.
Hey.
Don't finish it.
Right after this.
I'm possessing your body.
Leave like the last bite for me.
Okay?
Cheese quesadilla a while ago.
That doesn't help me.
I need it now.
Pizza and cinnamon buns.
Stop.
You guys are...
Yummy.
Having a bacon omelette.
No.
I need my nutrition.
You're still gonna get it.
I just get the taste.
You know?
Okay.
Tomorrow I have a pretty long day.
Oh.
If you are in...
If you are close to...
Wait where is this at again?
I'm doing an event tomorrow called Kusaland.
Which is an anime DJ event.
I will be singing.
I will be performing.
Not doing...
Um...
Not doing you know...
Ah...
The...
The DJ-ing.
But if you are in the United States, In... hold on... what... any party... any party...
Go to at any... wait, account suspended.
Uh oh.
Wait, I don't think that's the right one.
Thank you!
Wait, I retweeted it.
Where is it?
Oh.
Oh, at any song party.
Sorry, my bad.
At any song party on Twitter.
It's in... if you're close to Virginia.
Virginia, America.
Then, I will be there.
Singing.
It's pretty short.
Just a couple songs, but...
Springfield, Virginia.
I don't know where that is.
But, uh...
If you like things like doing calls and mixes...
You know...
If you want to experience that...
Listen to anime music and meet people that like anime music...
You should go!
Part of the DC metropolitan area.
It's part of the DC metropolitan area!
That's only 5 hours away!
About 20 to 30 minutes south of DC.
Oh!
But, um...
If not...
Maybe...
Off-Kai?
Somewhere else?
We'll have to see.
And, uh...
If anyone...
If anywhere else...
Once...
Or...
You can recommend me as a guest to your favorite anime convention in your area.
And then maybe they'll accept me as a guest.
And then maybe I can say yes.
I'll tell you that.
Yeah.
When is it?
Tomorrow!
It's tomorrow night!
Uh...
I'll...
I'll retweet it again on my Twitter.
But go...
You can go to any song party on Twitter as well to see the information.
It's tomorrow!
Tomorrow!
Tomorrow.
Ena intensifies.
Ok guys.
I'm gonna gooo...
I'm gonna go eat...
Ok guys.
And I'll see you guys...
Not tomorrow...
Well, maybe tomorrow if I see you there?
Um...
If not...
I'm going to see you on Sunday.
Yeah.
Uh -huh.
I checked for Anime NYC and the guests have to apply themselves.
As much as I want to be an announcer.
I'm unable to request you.
Well, we'll see.
We shall see.
Became a member today, so this was my first stream.
No way, really?
I have to go now, but I had a great time.
Look forward to the next one.
Thank you so much, TikTakTiger.
Thank you.
Have a good night.
Thanks for sticking around for so long, too.
Really appreciate it.
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, thank you.
Sunday, I'm still figuring out what I want to do.
I'll figure it out.
Please go to AMYC.
It's not up to me, but I'll do my best.
I guess.
Will the KusaLand performances be strong?
Yes!
It will be streamed on Twitch.
They have a Twitch.
I'm pretty sure it's...
Wait, hold on.
They're on Twitch at the same name.
At least they told me it would be streamed.
Yes.
On Twitch, any song party.
So it will be... it should be.
It should be also on there, too.
Thanks for another fun episode.
I'm going to stream again.
Thank you, customer Johnson.
Hal and Dave, or is it Dave and Hal?
I think I actually like Hal and Dave better.
No, Dave and Hal.
If you ever end up in Salt Lake or Denver, I'll be sure to get a ticket.
Hope you have a great time tomorrow.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, thank you.
Take care of yourself.
Have a great weekend.
Since I might not see you on Saturday.
But...
Get lots of rest.
If you're working, do your best.
Do you know when you show up?
I think it's like...
6...
Around 6.30 p.m.
or so.
If everything goes right, I think.
Haha.
Series I is on hiatus.
And I don't have contacts at Anime Revolution anymore.
But I'll try.
Thanks, Corin.
Alrighty.
I'm going to go eat.
Lots of Minto!
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
And thanks for letting me finish The Twin Snakes.
Yeah!
Thank you, guys.
Thank you so much.
Otsu, Otsu, Otsu, Otsu, Minto, Minto, Minto, Minto.
Otsu, Minto, Otsu, Minto, Otsu, Otsu, Otsu, Minto.
Otsu, Otsu, Otsu, Otsu, Minto!
Take care!
Bye-bye!
Thank you, guys!
Bye-bye, bye-bye!
See you later!
Bye-bye!
Oh!
Double, double, double.
This is awkward.
Ah.
Wait.
Bye!
Oh.
I was going to say something and I forgot.
You know what?
Ah.
Wah!
Bye!